>> HERE THE PITCH.
-- HERE IS THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES IT DEEP.
WHAT A PLAY.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
OH MY!
>> WELCOME EVERYONE.
IT IS THE GAME OF THE WEEK
PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY STATE
FARM.
WE ARE AT GLOBE LIFE PARK, TEXAS
RANGERS AT HOME AGAINST THE
FORMER DIVISION LEADERS OF THE
A.L. WEST, THE OAKLAND A'S,
BRIEFLY KNOCKED OUT OF FIRST BY
THE ASTROS.
THEY HAVE WON EIGHT IN A ROW.
THEY ARE A GAME OUT OF FIRST.
COLE IRVIN VERSUS TAYLOR HEARN,
YOU WILL SEE THE GAME RIGHT
HERE.
A BIT OF A SURPRISE, THE WAY THE
RANGERS HAVE SUNK QUICKLY.
THE A'S, I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS A
SURPRISE AFTER THE LOSING
STREAK, THEY ARE A POWERFUL
CLUB.
>> YOU THINK ABOUT THE SEASON,
THEY START OFF 0-6.
I SAW THEM PLAY IN SEATTLE AND I
WAS LIKE THEY DON'T LOOK WOULD
BUT THEY HAVE TURNED IT AROUND,
13 AND FIVE IN JUNE.
0-3 RIGHT NOW BUT THEY HAVE
TURNED IT AROUND AND THEY WILL
BE IN IT ALL THE WAY THROUGH
SEPTEMBER.
>> A QUALITY TEAM.
I THOUGHT AFTER THE FIRST WEEK
MAYBE THIS IS THE YEAR IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN BUT THEY COOLED
OFF OVER THE WEEKEND AGAINST THE
YANKEES, FINISHED OFF BY THE
TRIPLE PLAY.
THE YANKEES ARE GOOD AT TRIPLE
PLAYS.
AND GAME ONE LAST NIGHT, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> IVAN HAS -- IBANEZ HAMMERS IT
TO LEFT AND IT IS GONE.
THE FIRST BIG-LEAGUE HIT AND THE
FIRST HOME RUN FOR IBANEZ. A
COUPLE BASERUNNERS FOR JOSÉ
TREVINO.
HE HITS THIS DEEP TO CENTER
FIELD.
LAUREANO ON THE RUN.
IT IS GONE.
A THREE RUN SHOT BY TRIVINO.
>> THE RANGERS GET TO 26 AND 46.
THEY ARE 18 GAMES OUT.
THEY HAVE HAD SOME TERRIBLE
RUNS, 16 GAME LOSING STREAK ON
THE ROAD, LOST 19 OF 23 BUT BEAT
THE A'S LAST NIGHT.
THE A'S FALL TO 44-30, TWO GAMES
BEHIND, ONE GAME BEHIND THE
ASTROS.
WE GROUP THE A'S AND THE RAYS
TOGETHER AS THE VANGUARD DEFYING
THE ODDS DESPITE THE PAYROLL.
THEY HAVE MATT CHAPMAN, MATT
OLSON, THEY HAVE STARS ON THE
CORNER OF THE INFIELD.
TELL ME ABOUT OLSON.
IS HE GOING TO BE AN ELITE POWER
HITTER?
LOOKS LIKE WE ARE GETTING THE
ANSWER.
DAVE: IF YOU LOOK AT LAST YEAR,
THE PANDEMIC THING, I WOULD
THROW THAT YEAR OUT.
HE STRUGGLED BUT HE DID GIVE YOU
A CONCERN ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
HE CAME INTO THIS SEASON AND
MADE SOME CHANGES.
FOR ME, THE FIRST THING IS PLATE
DISCIPLINE.
ONCE YOU HAVE PLATE DISCIPLINE,
YOU WILL START SEEING THE BALL
BETTER.
WHEN YOU SEE THE BALL BETTER,
YOU WILL START HITTING MORE.
THIS IS LAST YEAR.
EVERYTHING IS JUST A TICK SLOW,
JUST A LITTLE OFF.
WE WILL SHOW YOU A COUPLE THINGS
THAT HE TWEAKED IN HIS SWING.
RIGHT NOW, MATT OLSON IS NOT
SLOW.
HE IS ON EVERY PITCH, WHETHER IT
IS A FASTBALL AWAY, HE IS GOING
OPPOSITE WAY.
MAKE A MISTAKE ON THE INNER HALF
AND HE IS CRUSHING BASEBALLS.
TAKE A LOOK.
IN HIS SET UP, TAKE A LOOK AT
THE BAT ANGLE.
THE LEFT SIDE IS 2020, RIGHT
SIDE IS 2021.
MUCH MORE UPRIGHT THIS YEAR.
IT HAS CHANGED THE BAT PATH AND
HE IS NOT LATE ON THOSE
FASTBALLS.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DO, HIS CONTACT
PERCENTAGE IS UP TO 80% IN THE
ZONE.
EXIT VELOCITY, RANKS SIXTH,
O.P.S., .997, HOME RUNS, 20,
THAT IS THIRD-BEST.
R.B.I.'S, FIFTH.
SLUGGING, THIRD-BEST IN THE
LEAGUE.
THIS GUY MADE SOME ADJUSTMENTS
AND HE IS AN ELITE PLAYER.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT VLAD
JUNIOR, IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
NUMBERS, AND WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT AN INCREDIBLE YEAR HE
IS HAVING, MATT OLSON IS JUST A
TICK UNDER WHAT HE IS DOING.
HE HAS DONE IT BEFORE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE A STRONG
SEASON.
BRIAN: ELITE NUMBERS.
HE IS THERE WITH JESSE WINKER.
I DID A THING ON HIM ON MLB NOW
AND IT SEEMS LIKE -- YOU ARE
RIGHT, THE DROP IN THE WITH
FREIGHT -- THE WHIFF RATE, AND
SELECTION AND AGGRESSION AND
DAMAGE TO THAT PITCH, IT IS A
NUANCED THING BUT HE'S GOT IT
WORKING.
DAVE: IT IS A DISCIPLINE THAT
WHEN YOU CAN RECOGNIZE PITCHES
IN THE ZONE AND YOU ARE NOT
MISSING THEM, YOU HEAR PLAYERS
GO I GOT MY ONE PITCH, I MISSED
IT, HE IS LOOKING IN THE ZONE
AND WHEN HE GETS HIS PITCH, HE
IS NOT MISSING.
BRIAN: AN AMAZING BLEND OF
TECHNOLOGY, SCIENCE, HITTING
COACHES.
WE HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU AS WE
GET CLOSER TO THE A'S AND THE
RANGERS.
WHO WILL WIN TONIGHT'S GAME?
COLE IRVIN ADDING THE START FOR
THE A'S, A THREE .0 SIX E.R.A.
IN JUNE.
HE IS EXPECTED -- HEARN IS
EXPECTED TO GO TWO OR THREE
INNINGS.
COULD BE A BULLPEN GAME FOR THE
RANGERS.
LET US KNOW WHAT YOU THINK RIGHT
HERE ON THIS CHANNEL.
WHEN WE COME BACK, CHRIS BASSI N
BASEBALL.
WE WILL SPEAK TO HIM WHEN WE
COME BACK.
>> SWUNG ON, LINED TO LEFT,
CAREER BASE HIT 1000.
GET HIM THE BASEBALL.
A MILESTONE FOR MITCH MORELAND.
>> THAT IS HIT WELL.
CANHA MAKES A PHENOMENAL CATCH
UP AGAINST THE WALL.
FIRE IS THE BALL BACK TO THE
INFIELD AND THE RUNNERS GET
BACK.
KEMP, RIGHT FIELD, AND THAT BABY
IS GONE.
TONY KEMP, A THREE RUN HOMER.
THE A'S LEAD 5-3.
>> TONY KEMP ONCE AGAIN COMES
THROUGH FOR THE ATHLETICS.
>> THAT WILL BRING UP JARED
WONG.
DIVING, AND HE MAKES A
PHENOMENAL CATCH.
WHAT A PLAY BY SKYE BOLT ON A
WICKED SHOT BY JARED WALL --
JARED WONG.
>> HIGH FLY BALL TO CENTER.
LAUREANO GOES BACK TOWARDS THE
TRACK, JUMPS AT THE WALL AND
RAMON LAUREANO IS BACK IN THE
HOUSE.
A GREAT CATCH BY RAMON, LIKE HE
NEVER LEFT.
IT IS A 1-2-3 INNING FOR THE
ATHLETICS.
♪
BRIAN: WELCOME BACK TO THE
PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY STATE
FARM.
WE ARE GETTING READY FOR GAME
TIME A FEW MINUTES AWAY.
THE A'S AND THE RANGERS.
TAKE A LOOK, I MENTIONED CHRIS
BASSITT IS ONE OF THE TOP
STARTERS IN BASEBALL.
SINCE THE START OF 2020, THAT
WAS A TWO-MONTH SEASON BUT THE
SAMPLE SIZE IS GETTING LARGER.
CHRIS BASSITT HAS THE FOURTH
BEST E.R.A. IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
SHANE BIEBER, GERRIT COLE, LANCE
LYNN, CHRIS BASSITT.
ADNAN VIRK, TOM VERDUCCI AND
DAVE VALLE CAUGHT UP WITH HIM.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOU TOLD US WE STARTED OUT
0-6 AND THE WAY WE STARTED OUT,
WE ARE IN THIS POSITION, I THINK
YOU HAVE TO BE HAPPY WITH IT.
THREE LOSSES IN A ROW IS NOT
GREAT.
BUT TIP YOUR HAT TO THE YANKEES,
THEY PLAYED TWO GOOD GAMES
AGAINST US.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK ON TRACK A
LITTLE BIT.
>> TOM VERDUCCI.
I LOVE WATCHING YOU PITCH
BECAUSE YOU CAN CHANGE SPEEDS
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO I THOUGHT
MAYBE YOU WERE GIVING AWAY SOME
OF YOUR PITCHES OUT OF THE
STRETCH.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT AS A
PITCHER YOU WOULD NORMALLY DO,
SELF SCOUT, ASK PITCHING
COACHES, TEAMMATES, DO YOU SEE
ANYTHING GOING ON?
>> NO DOUBT.
WE'VE GOT VETERAN GUYS LIKE
ELVIS, MITCH MORELAND, I MEAN,
MORELAND IS UNBELIEVABLE AT
PICKING STUFF UP.
HE IS CONSTANTLY WATCHING US.
DUE TO THE PAST OF ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE GONE ON, WE ARE
VERY OBSERVANT OF EACH OTHER,
WHO IS DOING WHAT, WHAT IS GOING
ON.
WE ARE CONSTANTLY BREAKING EACH
OTHER DOWN, TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT, ARE YOU TIPPING?
ARE YOU NOT?
ARE YOU TIPPING FROM SECOND IF
SOMEONE IS ON SECOND?
WE TRY TO KEEP EVERYTHING AS
CLEAN AS POSSIBLE.
>> IS THAT SOMETHING YOU HAVE
GONE THROUGH REASONABLY?
>> I HAVE CHECKED MYSELF, I
WOULD SAY EVERY TWO WEEKS, TO
MAKE SURE I'M CLEAN.
DAVE: YOU HAVE BEEN ON QUITE A
JOURNEY WITH THE OAKLAND A'S.
I KNOW YOU HAVE MENTIONED THEIR
FAITHFULNESS IN YOU.
WHAT HAS THAT LOYALTY MEANT?
>> EVERYTHING, HONESTLY.
WHEN I WAS COMING BACK FROM
TOMMY JOHN, IT COULD HAVE BEEN
EASY TO D.F.A. ME, TO SAY IT IS
NOT WORKING OUT, YOU ARE
STRUGGLING, NOT BOUNCING BACK
HEALTHWISE BUT THEY BELIEVED IN
ME.
THEY BELIEVED IN WHO I WAS AND
MY WORK ETHIC.
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT I'M
ABLE TO REWARD THEM FOR TRUSTING
IN ME.
>> YOUR CONSISTENCY HAS BEEN
REMARKABLE.
YOU PITCHED AT LEAST FIVE
INNINGS, 14-15 STARTS, ALLOWED
FOUR EARNED RUNS OR FEWER IN ALL
OF THOSE STARTS.
IN 11 OF THOSE STARTS, TWO RUNS
OR FEWER.
WHERE DOES THE CONSISTENCY STEM
FROM?
>> IT IS JUST -- WITHOUT HIM AND
HIS TRUST, IT IS NEAR IMPOSSIBLE
TO DO ANYTHING.
I SEE A LOT OF STARTERS GET
YANKED OUT EARLY.
WITH OUR STARTING STAFF,
ESPECIALLY MANAEA, HE IS
TRUSTING IN US TO GO DEEP INTO
GAMES.
HE EXPECTS THAT FROM US.
I THINK IT IS A CONFIDENCE THING
IN ALL OF US, BUT IT IS ALSO, WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE WORK WE PUT
INTO GET TO THIS POINT.
>> LOTS OF FANS PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE SO-CALLED CRACKDOWN WITH
UMPIRES LOOKING AT PITCHERS
DURING THE GAME.
YOU HAVE BEEN OUTSPOKEN ABOUT
THIS.
WHAT HAS BEEN THE TALK AMONG THE
A'S STARTERS AND THE RELIEVERS
ABOUT ANYTHING MAY BE DIFFERENT
IN THIS LANDSCAPE.
>> I THINK THE LEAGUE HAD TO DO
SOMETHING.
I DON'T QUITE AGREE WITH THE
TIMING OF IT ALL, BUT I MEAN --
PERSONALLY FOR ME, I'M A PERSON
THAT HAS NEVER USED ANYTHING.
THE ONLY TIME I EVER USED
ANYTHING WAS IN THE FALL LEAGUE
AND IT WAS SO HOT IN ARIZONA, I
LITERALLY HAD NO CHANCE TO FEEL
THE BALL.
I FEEL LIKE OUR TEAM IS IN A
GREAT SPOT.
I DON'T REALLY THINK ANY OF OUR
STARTERS REALLY USE STUFF.
IT HAS NEVER BEEN PREACHED HERE,
NEVER BEEN TAUGHT HERE.
IN MY OPINION, IT IS AN
ADVANTAGE FOR US, BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO GO OUT THERE NEXT START
AND I DON'T HAVE TO CHANGE
ANYTHING.
LITERALLY NOTHING.
AGAIN, I FEEL SOMETHING HAD TO
HAPPEN, BUT I DON'T AGREE WITH
WHEN IT HAPPENED.
>> YOU CURRENTLY LEAD THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE WITH NINE BUT --
HIT BY PITCHES.
THIS WOULD ADD CREDENCE TO YOUR
THEORY.
YOU ARE STILL HITTING GUYS.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, I DON'T KNOW
THE NUMBERS ON THAT BUT I
GUARANTEE YOU SEVEN OR EIGHT OF
THOSE ARE TWO STRIKES AND IT IS
A SLIDER OR CURVEBALL THAT POPS
OUT OF MY HAND AND GETS AWAY
FROM ME.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THOSE BACK,
BUT I NEVER FELT COMFORTABLE,
NOT IN THE ASPECT OF SO-CALLED
CHEATING, BUT I NEVER FELT
COMFORTABLE WITH THE WAY IT FELT
SO I SAID I DON'T NEED IT, I'M
NOT GOING TO USE IT.
I UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE DO AND
WHY -- THE BALLS ARE NOT GREAT.
YEAH, JUST -- EVERYONE HAS
TALKED ABOUT THIS.
IT IS A BIG TOPIC.
LOTS OF THINGS STILL NEED TO BE
CHANGED.
BRIAN: THAT IS CHRIS BASSITT.
I THINK, I'M GLAD THIS IS BEING
CRACKED DOWN.
MIDDLE OF THE SEASON IS NOT
CONVENIENT THAT IT WAS AGAINST
THE RULES EVEN IF THE CULTURE
WAS ALLOWING SOME OF THAT.
I WISH THERE WAS A WAY OF
GETTING AROUND KIND OF DOING THE
STOP AND FRISK ON THE FIELD.
IT IS LIKE, PUT YOUR HANDS ON
THE HOOD OF THE CAR.
DAVE: YOU HAD PRACTICE LIKE THAT
WHEN YOU WERE YOUNGER.
BRIAN: IS THERE ANOTHER WAY OF
TRYING TO ENSURE THEY ARE NOT
PUTTING SO MUCH STICKY STUFF ON?
DAVE: OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD,
CAN WE DO IT IN THE DUGOUT?
OUT OF THE SIGHT OF THE KIDS?
THE FANS, THE KIDS ARE LIKE,
DAD, WHY IS JACOB DEGROM BEING
FRISKED?
HE IS TAKING HIS BELT OFF ON THE
FIELD.
CAN WE MOVE IT TO THE DUGOUT
DOOR THE TUNNEL, HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE DO IT?
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THE UMPIRE.
THE FIRST BASE UMPIRE COULD
FOLLOW THEM IN AND CHECK IT IF
YOU ARE GOING TO DO THAT.
I DON'T LIKE THE LOOK OF THAT
FOR OUR GAME.
BRIAN: MAKING SURE E -- HE IS
NOT CHEATING.
AND YET -- OK, IT'S GOOD, GET
BACK THE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
THE BALL WAS DOING THINGS THAT
HAD NEVER BEEN DONE IN 100
YEARS.
TIME FOR THE GOOGLE ALL-STAR
BALLOT.
WE CONTINUE TO WHITTLE THINGS
DOWN.
IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE OUTFIELD,
TROUT, JUDGE AND BYRON BUXTON,
WHO IS HURT AGAIN.
AT POLICE GARCIA OF THE RANGERS
IS IN FOURTH -- ADOLIS GARCIA OF
THE RANGERS MOVES UP.
THERE ARE YOUR TOP OUTFIELDERS.
CEDRIC MULLINS BREAKING INTO THE
TOP NINE.
HE COULD IN.
-- BREAK IN.
MICHAEL BRANTLEY IS KILLING IT.
THEY HAVE THE NUMBER ONE OFFENSE
IN THE GAME.
DAVE: THAT IS A TEAM THAT I
THINK -- THEY PUT IT ALL
TOGETHER AND YOU GO DOWN THE
LIST AND THEY LOST SPRINGER,
BREGMAN IS HURT, BUT THE LIST OF
QUALITY HITTERS, PROFESSIONAL
HITTERS, MICHAEL BRANTLEY IS ONE
OF MY FAVORITE GUYS TO WATCH.
WILL HE MAKE THE ALL-STAR TEAM?
I DON'T KNOW BUT MICHAEL, YOU
ARE AN ALL-STAR.
BRIAN: ANOTHER GUY ON THE
RANGERS, THE RANGERS ARE HAVING
A BAD YEAR BUT ISAIAH KINER FOR
LEFT IS THE BEST -- KINER FOR
LEFT -- KINER-FALEFA IS ABOVE
AVERAGE IN HITTING.
O.P.S.+ WAS UP AND HE WAS THE
NUMBER ONE BASERUNNER IN THE
GAME LAST WEEK.
NUMBER ONE FIELDER, TOP FIVE
BASERUNNER, ABOVE AVERAGE AT
HITTING AT SHORTSTOP.
AND HE CAN CATCH.
DAVE: IF YOU ARE A CATCHER THAT
MEANS YOU ARE A GREAT ATHLETE.
YOU CAN MOVE ON OVER TO
SHORTSTOP AND BE THE BEST.
BRIAN: COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
TIME I BELIEVE FOR THE
SPOTLIGHT.
SCOTT MORGAN'S CHANNEL IS SCO
MOMLB. HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
BRIAN: TELL ME ABOUT THE
BASEBALL CONTENT YOU PUT ON.
>> I'M BASICALLY A CONTENT
CREATOR SURROUNDING MLB, THE
SHOW, THE VIDEOGAMES.
IT HAS BEEN A HUGE YEAR
INTEGRATING XBOX AND
PLAYSTATION.
THEY OPENED UP -- I DO DAILY
CONTENT OF NEW CARDS, NEW
LEGENDS, UPGRADES, WE OPEN THE
PACKS, GAME PLAYED, IT IS
SURROUNDING THE DAILY CONTENT
THAT THE GAME IS DOING.
IT IS A LOT OF FUN.
YOU -- GIVING UP THAT DREAM OR
CHASING THE DREAM OF GAMING FOR
A LIVING IS ALWAYS AWESOME.
BRIAN: YOU ARE A DODGERS FAN.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE DODGERS?
>> OBVIOUSLY, THEY FINALLY GOT
THE CHIP OFF THE SHOULDER,
FINALLY GETTING A WORLD SERIES.
I HAVE BEEN A DODGER FAN MY
WHOLE LIFE.
THEY WON ONE WORLD SERIES RIGHT
BEFORE I WAS BORN AND ANOTHER
WHEN I WAS SIX SO I DIDN'T
REALLY GET TO ENJOY THOSE TOO
MUCH, THEN OBVIOUSLY THE LAST
FEW YEARS GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER, IT WAS AWESOME TO SEE
THEM WIN ONE.
NOW, WE HAVE THE MARK ON OUR
BACK.
THE GIANTS GOT A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE, THE PADRES GOT A BUNCH
OF PEOPLE, THE DODGERS ARE TWO
GAMES BACK NOW AND YOU HAVE TO
-- PADRES WITH TATIS, THE GIANTS
WITH CRAWFORD, THEY ARE HARD
WITHIN THE DIVISION, NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT OTHER TEAMS LIKE
RED SOX AND ASTROS AND THE RAYS
THAT ARE PUTTING UP TONS OF RUNS
.
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN PULL OUT
EVERYTHING.
YOU HAVE TO STAY HEALTHY AND GET
TO THE PLAYOFFS AND SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO.
BRIAN: A FASCINATING DIVISION
ESPECIALLY WITH THE SURPRISING
GIANTS.
ONE OF YOUR FAVORITE BASEBALL
MEMORIES INVOLVES THE BASEBALL
HALL OF FAME.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> I GREW UP AROUND BASEBALL.
MY DAD WAS A BASKETBALL COACH, I
GREW UP AROUND BASEBALL AND
SPORTS MY WHOLE LIFE.
I PLAYED EVER SINCE TEE-BALL,
COLLEGE, AND GOING TO THE HALL
OF FAME, I GOT TO GO A FEW TIMES
BUT I WAS A HUGE NOLAN RYAN FAN
GROWING UP.
GOING TO THE INDUCTION WERE
NOLAN RYAN, GEORGE BRETT AND
ROBIN YOUNT IN COOPERSTOWN,
ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN THERE KNOWS
IT IS A LITTLE TOWN STUCK IN
TIME.
IT IS BASEBALL ALL AROUND,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, ONE OF THE
LARGEST INDUCTIONS IN THE
HISTORY OF COOPERSTOWN.
IT WAS AWESOME TO SEE, MEETING
EVERYONE, THE WHOLE TOWN IS
BASEBALL.
IT WAS AWESOME.
YOU CAMP OUT BECAUSE THERE ARE
NO HOTELS.
YOU ARE CAMPING AND IT IS ALL
BASEBALL ALL NIGHT LONG.
BRIAN: THERE ARE HOTELS.
THEY ARE HARD TO GET INTO.
>> YOU HAVE TO PLAN FIVE YEARS
IN ADVANCE.
BRIAN: THE 1999 CLASS WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST MONSTER CLASSES TO GO
IN.
THAT WAS MONSTROUS.
HOW OLD WERE YOU?
>> I WAS LIKE 16, 17.
I THINK I TURNED 17 THAT JULY.
RIGHT AROUND THAT TIME.
BRIAN: IT WAS BOILING HOT.
>> IT WAS SUPER HOT, AND YOU
WERE SO FAR BACK AND -- IT WAS
LIKE WOODSTOCK.
IT WAS ROWS OF PEOPLE AND IT WAS
AWESOME.
BRIAN: I WAS THERE.
I WAS ON RADIO.
NOT WOODSTOCK.
THE 1999 CEREMONY.
THAT WAS A GREAT DAY.
I KNOW THE BIG MOMENT FOR YOU
WAS DODGERS POSTSEASON, GAME
SEVEN NLCS AGAINST THE BRAVES.
WHAT STANDS OUT IN YOUR MEMORY?
>> WITH EVERYONE'S MEMORY, IT
WILL BE THAT BELLINGER HOME RUN
BUT THE WHOLE THING, BEING A
DODGER FAN, EVERYONE THINKS THE
DODGERS ARE SO GOOD, THEY SPEND
ALL THIS MONEY.
BEING A DODGER FAN IS ROUGH
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WIN THE WORLD
SERIES BUT EVERYBODY THINKS YOU
ARE THE BEST.
YOU KIND OF GET THAT HATE A
LITTLE BIT.
OBVIOUSLY GETTING SO CLOSE FOR
MANY YEARS, IT REALLY FELT LIKE
LAST YEAR WAS THE YEAR AND THEN
YOU GET INTO THAT GAME AND THE
BRAVES GO TWO GAMES TO NONE.
THEY WERE ABSOLUTELY JUST
KILLING THE BALL.
THE DODGERS WERE STRUGGLING.
FINALLY CAME BACK ON SCORED 15
RUNS I THINK THE NEXT GAME BUT
THE BRAVES CAME BACK AGAIN.
IT WAS 3-1 IN ATLANTA.
AS A DODGER FAN YOU ARE LIKE,
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
GAME FIVE, DODGERS WIN IN
ATLANTA.
GAME SIX, SEAGER STARTED OFF THE
GAME.
GAME SEVEN IN L.A., THE PITCHING
STAFF COULDN'T DO ANYTHING AND
IT WAS TOUGH TO START THE GAME.
THE ENTIRE GAME WAS BACK AND
FORTH, BRAVES TOOK THE LEAD,
DODGERS CAME BACK.
AND I WAS ON EDGE THE WHOLE
TIME.
IT FELT LIKE THE WORLD SERIES.
WHEN I LOOK AT IT NOW, IT FEELS
LIKE THAT WAS THE WORLD SERIES.
WHEN BELLINGER HIT THE HOME RUN
AND FLIPPED THE BAT, I THINK I
WENT THROUGH MY BASEMENT TO MY
LIVING ROOM UPSTAIRS.
IT WAS AWESOME.
BRIAN: I FEEL LIKE I JUST
WATCHED THE GAME AGAIN.
SCOTT, GOOD STUFF.
BEST OF LUCK ON YOUR CHANNEL.
AND BRINGING MORE PEOPLE IN
THERE.
ENJOY THE GAME TONIGHT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
BRIAN: SCOTT MORGAN IN OUR
CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
SCOMOMLB AND SCOMORW.
A BIG HALL OF FAME FAN, BIG
DODGERS FAN AS WELL.
THAT IS SCOTT MORGAN.
PICKS TO CLICK WILL FOLLOW,
NEXT.
♪
>> HERE IS THE 1-0.
A LITTLE TAMPER UP THE
THIRD-BASE MALL -- THIRD-BASE
LINE.
HE GOT IT.
THE BREAKAWAY BY TRIVINO.
MAKING THE THROW, THE P ROWENTA
INSIDE THE THIRD-BASE LINE.
>> 3-2.
HE SHOOTS THIS OUT TO RIGHT
FIELD.
IT IS CARRYING PRETTY WELL.
IT IS GONE.
ELI WHITE GOES THE OTHER WAY.
>> THIS BALL HIT WELL.
DEEP TO RIGHT AND THAT ONE IS
GONE.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
ELI WHITE HITS HIS FIRST
BIG-LEAGUE HOME RUN TONIGHT AND
WASTES NO TIME IN GETTING HIS
SECOND.
>> LEADING IT OFF OR MINNESOTA.
LINES IT TO RIGHT AND A SLIDING
GRAB BY JOEY GALLO.
A BIT OF DEFENSE IN THE SECOND
INNING.
>> HE HITS THIS ONE IN THE AIR.
IT IS GONE.
HE TIDED UP IN THE SEVENTH WITH
HIS 17TH HOME RUN OF THE YEAR.
>> GALLO HAS BEEN ON TWICE
TODAY.
>> HIT WAY OUT OF THIS BALLPARK.
HOW FAR WILL IT GO?
HOW ABOUT THE FAÇADE OF THE
SECOND LEVEL IN RIGHT FIELD?
♪
BRIAN: WELCOME BACK TO THE GAME
OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
TAYLOR HEARN VERSUS COLE IRVIN,
RANGERS AND A'S COMING UP
MOMENTS AWAY.
TIMES -- TIME FOR PICKS TO
CLICK.
HERE ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
DAVE, WE WILL USE YOUR BASEBALL
KNOWLEDGE.
WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE TO WIN THE
A.L. WEST?
DAVE: RIGHT NOW PROBABLY AN EASY
PICK, THE ASTROS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THEIR OFFENSE.
THEY ARE FIRST IN ALMOST EVERY
CATEGORY ALL THE WAY DOWN.
THE PITCHING STAFF, GREINKE HAS
BEEN THROWING WELL, ARKADY ADVIL
AS OUR BACK.
A NUMBER -- AND VELEZ ARE BACK.
A NUMBER OF THINGS ARE GOING
WELL EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE
BREGMAN.
BRIAN: MANY GUYS ARE MAXIMIZING
THEIR OFFENSIVE PERFORMANCE.
SIX GUYS, GURRIEL IS KILLING IT,
ALTUVE AND CARLOS CORREA ARE
KILLING IT.
OVER-UNDER RUNS SCORED, THE
OVER-UNDER IS AT NINE.
DAVE: OVER.
BRIAN: I WOULD THINK SO.
LOOKING AT IT BASICALLY WITH THE
STARTING MATCHUP ALTHOUGH LORMAN
HAS BEEN GOOD.
DAVE: THE RANGERS GOING WITH THE
BULLPEN GAME, I THINK THE A'S
WILL PUT SOME NUMBERS UP THERE.
BRIAN: YOU KNOW I LIKE A BULLPEN
GAME.
I HOPE HEARN COMES OUT SMOKING,
GIVES TWO INNINGS, AND FIVE OR
SIX GUYS, NO ONE PAYS ATTENTION.
WILL THE RANGERS SCORING THE
FIRST INNING AGAINST THE A'S AND
COLE IRVIN?
DAVE: SI, SENOR. THE CENTER
FIELDER WILL GO DEEP.
YES.
I'M CALLING IT.
RIGHT HERE, RIGHT NOW.
BRIAN: THEY GOT FIVE LAST NIGHT.
THAT IS -- YOU CAN TAKE A SHOT
AT IT.
I HOPE THEY GET THE FIRST GION
AND THEY DON'T BUNT.
THAT IS MY ONLY PRAYER.
TIME FOR THE POLL RESULTS.
WHO DO YOU THINK WILL WIN THIS
GAME?
HERE ARE THE RESULTS.
70% ON THE A'S, WHICH MAKES
SENSE GIVEN THEIR RECORD.
MAYBE THE RANGERS ARE STARTING
TO TURN THINGS AROUND.
LOSING 19 OF 23.
DAVE: THAT IS ROUGH.
THEY HAVE THAT BEAUTIFUL
BALLPARK, THE FANS ARE BACK, MY
DAUGHTER WAS THERE LAST WEEKEND
SAYS IT IS AMAZING.
THEY NEED TO PUT RUNS ON THE
BOARD AND THE PEOPLE WILL SHOW
UP.
JUST BEING AT A BALLGAME, IT IS
100 DEGREES IN JULY AND AUGUST
AND YOU ARE SITTING ON PLASTIC
SEATS.
IT IS NOT A GOOD LOOK WHEN YOU
GET UP.
BRIAN: WE HAVE AN UPDATE IN
BALTIMORE.
THE TEAM THE A'S ARE CHASING.
>> THAT IS HAMMERED WAY BACK,
LEFT FIELD, THE LEAP AND NO.
AUSTIN HAYS PICKS IT UP.
IT IS IN PLAY.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE HOME RUN
SIGNAL.
>> GETS BACK PRETTY QUICKLY.
HE IS A GIFTED OUTFIELDER.
AND YOU THINK MAYBE --
>> EVERYBODY IS LOOKING.
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> HERE HE IS.
WE HAD --
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THE BALL IS
IN PLAY.
HIT THE TOP OF THE FENCE.
RIGHT ON THE TOP.
>> WE HAD A SECOND GLOVE FROM
THE FAN IN THERE, AS WELL.
LOOKS LIKE IT IS BETWEEN THE TWO
GLOVES OFF THE TOP OF THE FENCE.
>> I'M SURE THEY WILL SAY MAYBE
THE BALL HITS THE GLOVE AND GOES
STRAIGHT DOWN.
IT PROBABLY DID.
REALLY HARD FOR A BALL TO
VERTICALLY DROP WITHOUT BEING
TOUCHED AS MUCH AS THIS BALL
DOES.
MAYBE THIS WILL BE A BETTER
ANGLE.
THEY HAVE TO DETERMINE, WAS THE
FAN IN THE STANDS?
YOU CAN SEE HOW MUCH HIGHER HIS
GLOVE WAS.
RIGHT THERE.
DOES IT HIT THE BOTTOM OF THE
SECOND GLOVE?
CERTAINLY DOESN'T -- I THINK IT
DID.
>> LOOKS LIKE THE SECOND GLOVE
MOVED A LITTLE.
>> THEY MAY CALL THAT A HOME
RUN.
NICE EFFORT OBVIOUSLY BY AUSTIN
HAYS.
JUST A MATTER OF HOW THEY
INTERPRET THAT.
>> THE NEW YORK CREW, WAITING.
>> SCORED A DOUBLE UNTIL THEY
CHANGE IT.
>> TOUCH 'EM ALL.
THAT IS A HOME RUN.
>> THERE IT IS AGAIN.
LINED INTO CENTER.
SEVERINO TAGS AT THIRD, NICE
PLAY BY STRONG.
SEVERINO SCORES ON THE SAC FLY
ON THE GAME IS TIED AT 1-1.
>> THROWS THE SLOW CURVEBALL AND
IT IS NOT THAT HE CAN'T HIT IT.
BRIAN: FASCINATING WITH MYLES
STRAW.
IT TOOK A LITTLE BIT TO SEE THAT
IT HIT THE GLOVE OF THE FAN,
BOUNCED OFF THE WALL, HIT THE
FAN'S CHEST AND WE HAVE A HOME
RUN.
DAVE: I'M SURPRISED FAN DIDN'T
REACT AFTER THE BALL HIT THE TOP
OF THE WALL, HIT HIS CHEST AND
HE DIDN'T JUMP BACK, HE TOOK IT
LIKE SUPERMAN.
BRIAN: A TOUGH FAN.
THE RIGHT THING HAPPENED.
WE TAKE IT FOR GRANTED WITH
REPLAY, BUT EVEN IN THE LAST
THREE DAYS I HAVE SEEN THINGS I
COULDN'T QUITE TELL.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T MIND THE DELAY.
THAT LOOKED LIKE A LENGTHY
DELAY.
I'M FINE WITH THAT, ESPECIALLY
FOR A HOME RUN.
DAVE: THE HITTER WAS GLAD THEY
TOOK THEIR TIME.
OTHERWISE HE WOULD BE AT SECOND
THINKING I JUST WENT DEEP,
SOMEONE STOLE A HOME RUN.
BRIAN: COMING UP, THE OAKLAND
A'S CHASING THE HOUSTON ASTROS.
MELANIE NEWMAN, BUCK SHOWALTER
ON THE CALL.
YONDER ALONSO WITH THE CALL ON
YOUTUBE.
DAVE: THEY ARE DOWN THERE.
ARE THEY IN THE HOUSE?
ARE THEY?
BRIAN: THEY ARE HERE.
BUCK IS FLOATING IN SPACE,
HOVERING ABOVE.
ALL ENCOMPASSING.
DAVE: IN THE CLOUDS SOMEWHERE.
BRIAN: VOTE FOR ISAIAH CONNOR
FOR LEFT -- KINER-FALEFA.
DAVE, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TIME FOR THE GAME.
A'S AND RANGERS, ENJOY.
>> HERE IS THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES IT DEEP.
>> WHAT A PLAY.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM AT GLOBE
LIFE FIELD.
TEXAS RANGERS HOSTING GAME TWO
AGAINST THE ATHLETICS.
THE RANGERS HAD BEEN SEARCHING
FOR A WIN AND CAME INTO PICK UP
A BIG ONE YESTERDAY.
WE WILL SEE HOW THEY FARE TODAY
AS THEY ULTIMATELY HAVE A
BULLPEN GAME IN FRONT OF THEM.
WELCOME, EVERYBODY.
MELANIE NEWMAN, YONDER ALONSO,
BUCK SHOWALTER.
I HAVE TO SAY I HAVE LOVED THE
ENERGY.
THERE IS RIVALRY AND ADMIRATION
BUT IT HAS BEEN A GOOD ONE.
YONDER: WE ARE ROCKING.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR TONIGHT.
FOR THE A'S IT IS GOING TO COME
DOWN TO, CAN THEY HAVE, CAN THEY
SCORE WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION?
THEY LEFT 17 GUYS ON BASE
YESTERDAY.
CAN TONIGHT HE THE DAY WHEN THEY
GET THEM ALL IN?
MELANIE: CAN'T OVERLOOK MATT
OLSON WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WHO
WILL DRIVE RUNNERS IN.
HE HAS BEEN ON FIRE LATELY
ESPECIALLY AGAINST FASTBALLS
WHICH I THINK YOU WILL SEE MORE
OF.
YONDER: FOR MAT OLSEN, COMING
INTO 2019, HE WAS A BREAKING
BALL GUY TYPE OF HITTER.
COMING INTO THIS 2021 SEASON, HE
MADE SOME ADJUSTMENTS WITH THE
FASTBALL.
HE IS HITTING IT FOR AVERAGE AND
IF YOU LOOK DOWN THERE, THE
STRIKEOUT RATE HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED.
WHEN WE LOOK AT A GUY LIKE THAT,
WE ARE LOOKING AT A GUY TO
POTENTIALLY BE AN M.V.P. TYPE
GUY.
HE HAS BEEN SCORCHING IN JUNE
WITH 20 R.B.I.'S.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THIS
GUY TONIGHT BECAUSE I THINK WHEN
YOU HAVE A GUY HITTING THIRD
AGAINST A LEFT-HANDER, YOU KNOW
HE IS A GOOD PLAYER.
BUCK MENTIONED THAT BEFORE WE
CAME ON.
HE IS AN INCREDIBLE HITTER,
INCREDIBLE DEFENDER.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WATCHING HIM
IN JULY AND THE ALL-STAR GAME.
IT ALSO TO BE POTENTIALLY AN
M.V.P. GUY.
MELANIE: YOU MENTIONED BUCK
SHOWALTER.
SPEAKING OF GOOD DEFENDERS,
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN A GOOD
HITTER BUT MORE OF A SURPRISE,
WHO YOU GOT FOR US?
HE HAS BEEN A BIG NAME IN TEXAS.
BUCK: ADOLIS GARCIA, FUN TO
WATCH.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PATH HE HAS
FOLLOWED, YOU PULL FOR HIM.
THE THING THAT JUMPED OUT TO ME
WAS A NELSON CRUZ, THINK OF A
LOT OF PEOPLE SAY YOU CAN'T DO
IT AND HE PROVED THEM WRONG.
HE WAS DESIGNATED FOR ASSIGNMENT
BY THE CARDINALS.
DESIGNATED FOR ASSIGNMENT BY THE
RANGERS.
DIDN'T THINK ANYBODY WOULD PICK
HIM UP.
THEY SLOWED DOWN HIS GAME, LET
HIM PLAY TO HIS TALENT.
HE IS A PLUS DEFENDER.
I LIKE CARING WHAT A GOOD
TEAMMATE HE IS.
HE PLAYS THE GAME RIGHT AND IS
TAKING THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
RUNNING WITH IT.
THEY HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
SLOWING HIS GAME DOWN AND
LETTING HIM PLAY WITHIN HIMSELF
AND HE HAS COVERED A LOT OF
BASES FOR THEM, RUNNING THE
BASES, PLAYING CENTER FIELD.
THREE YEARS AGO, NOBODY WOULD
HAVE TOUCHED HIM.
MELANIE: I THINK EVERYONE IS
INTERESTING MATCHUP, GAME TWO,
TEXAS RANGERS AND OAKLAND
ATHLETICS.
COMING UP, LINEUPS AND FIRST
PITCH RIGHT HERE ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> THE PITCH, LINE DRIVE, BASE
HIT FOR OLSON.
GOOD EXIT I WOULD IMAGINE.
-- EXIT VELOCITY I WOULD
IMAGINE.
LINE DRIVE AND IT IS A HIT.
THE DRIVE TO RIGHT AND THAT IS A
BASE HIT.
CANHA DIGGING AROUND SECOND TO
THIRD.
BIG INNING CONTINUES.
IT IS EIGHT-NUMERAL FOUR.
OLSON HAS THREE HITS.
>> THAT ONE IS LINED RIGHT FIELD
DOWN THE LINE AND THAT BABY IS
GONE.
MATT OLSON, NUMBER 19.
A'S LEAD 1-0.
>> OLSON, BASE HIT LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
THAT WILL BRING HOME A PAIR.
KEMP GOES TO THIRD ED IT IS 4-1
-- AND IT IS 4-1.
>> OLSON DRIVES ONE TO CENTER.
JUDGE BACK, JUDGE AT THE WALL,
THAT BABY IS GONE.
NUMBER 20 FOR MATT OLSON.
>> HERE IT IS.
HIT INTO LEFT FIELD, BASE HIT.
MATT OLSON, 2-THREE, CAME IN
HITTING .301 ON THE YEAR.
♪
MELANIE: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
MELANIE NEWMAN, YONDER ALONSO,
BUCK SHOWALTER AND BRETT DOLAN.
YOUTUBE IS EXPLODING THE ABILITY
FOR EVERYONE TO SEE MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
IT HAS BEEN A BLAST TO TAKE IN
AND LOOK AT.
WHAT A FUN TIME WE WILL HAVE,
BRINGING IT TO EVERYONE.
GAME TWO OF A FOUR-GAME SERIES
AND IT IS THE GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
SOME THINGS TO KNOW, THIS IS A
LIVE GLOBAL BROADCAST ON THE
YOUTUBE CHANNEL FOR FREE.
THERE ARE 3 MILLION FANS
SUBSCRIBING TO THE MLB YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
THE NUMBER IS GROWING EVERY DAY.
TURN ON NOTIFICATIONS PRIOR AND
YOU WILL FIND OUT ABOUT UP
COMING GAMES AND YOUTUBE TV
CUSTOMERS, GAMES STREAM LIVE IN
AN MLB POP UP WITHIN YOUR
CHANNEL GUIDE.
PLENTY OF ACCESS TO THE MOST
ENTERTAINING BASEBALL.
LET'S LOOK AT THE A'S STARTING
LINEUP.
MARK CANHA, HIS FIRST NIGHT OFF
FROM THE LEADOFF SPOT WAS LAST
NIGHT AND HE IS BACK AT THE TOP.
MATT OLSON IN THIRD BEHIND MATT
CHAPMAN.
OLSON WITH A 20 GAME ON BASE
STREET.
HE IS TORCHING THINGS.
RAMON LAUREANO CLEANING UP.
CHAD PINDER IN RIGHT BATTING
FIFTH, FOLLOWED BY JED LOWRIE.
CATCHER SEAN MURPHY BEHIND THE
PLATE, BATTING SEVENTH.
ELVIS ANDRUS CONTINUES HIS
REUNION WITH TEXAS.
THE SHORTSTOP BATS A.
-- BATS EIGHTH.
ROUNDING THINGS OUT, THE ROOKIE
SKYE BOLT.
TAYLOR HEARN WAS NOT THE
ORIGINAL STARTER FOR TODAY'S
CONTEST.
HE WILL BE A SPOT STARTER.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE JORDAN
LYLES TO START OFF BUT THE
MANAGER OPTED TO GO TO THE
BULLPEN INSTEAD.
HIS SECOND CAREER START.
HE HAD SOME START TIME IN THE
MINORS, AS WELL.
WHEN YOU ARE LOOKING AT TAYLOR
HEARN, 22 GAMES ON THE SEASON, A
DECENT MAY.
HE HAS BEEN A LITTLE ROUGHED UP
IN JUNE.
HE HAS A LIMITED PITCH COUNT
TONIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
BUCK: I EXPECT AN AMBUSH.
PITCHERS LIKE THIS TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND RUN WITH IT.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS, YOU
WANT TO WALK IN THE LOCKER ROOM
AND GO, YOU ARE STARTING TODAY.
DON'T OVERTHINK IT.
AS A RELIEF PITCHER, HE IS ABLE
TO SHOW HIS WHOLE REPERTOIRE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO MAKE SURE HE
GETS ONE OR TWO HITTERS OUT.
THE THREE HITTER RULE, HE HAS
MORE THAN THAT.
HE CAN GO SIX OR SEVEN.
MELANIE: SOME BIG PROPOSITIONS
FOR TAYLOR HEARN.
THE ODDS, THE BOOKMAKERS PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE PITCHING CHANGE
.
ODDS OVER OR UNDER NINE RUNS
HERE IN GAME TWO, BOB MELVIN,
THE ATHLETICS MANAGER, LOOKING
FOR A BOUNCE BACK FROM HIS CLUB.
HE SAID FRANKIE MONTAS HAD A
PRETTY GOOD NIGHT, EXCEEDING THE
FIVE INNINGS AFTER HE GOT
ROUGHED UP, FIVE RUNS IN THE
FIRST FOR THE RANGERS, WHICH SET
THE TABLE.
TAYLOR HEARN IS READY.
THE FIRST PITCH MISSES OUTSIDE
WITH A FASTBALL, BALL ONE AND
AWAY WE GO.
7:08 BACK IN TEXAS.
MARK CANHA AT THE PLATE, 1-5 IN
YESTERDAY'S GAME.
HEARN COMES INSIDE.
TWO BALL COUNT.
YONDER: MARK CANHA IS LEADING
OFF OF THE 70TH TIME IN 75 GAMES
FOR THE A'S, A GUY WHO CAN SEE A
LOT OF PITCHES.
HE IS PROBABLY ON A STREAK WHERE
HE IS LEADING THE LEAGUE IN
SEEING PITCHES.
MELANIE: ANOTHER PITCH DOWN LOW
FOR HEARN.
THIS WAS SOMETHING INTERESTING
WE DISCUSSED, HE HAS REALLY GOOD
READS RIGHT NOW.
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN HEARN BUT THE
BALANCE IS THAT HEARN DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF LIFE IN HIM
TONIGHT.
YONDER: I THINK THEY KNOW THAT.
FOR HEARN BEING 3-0 AND WALKING
MARK CANHA, THAT IS A BIG
PROBLEM.
MELANIE: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
TONIGHT'S KEYS TO THE GAME
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
A BIT OF A BREAKDOWN FOR YOU,
BUCK, WHAT ARE THE KEYS FOR THE
RANGERS?
BUCK: THE WORD IS EARLY.
SPOT STARTER, YOU CAN'T IMPLODE
EARLY.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE YOUR BULLPEN A
CHANCE.
YOU WANT TO BRING ENERGY EARLY,
TALK ABOUT WINNING THE FIRST
INNING.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN SCORING RUNS.
WHEN THEY FACE OAKLAND'S
PITCHING, YOU HAVE TO HIT EARLY
IN THE COUNT BECAUSE HE WILL GET
AHEAD AND STAY AHEAD.
NOT PLUS STUFF BUT HE CAN
COMMAND THE BALL.
YOU HAVE TO BE READY TO HIT HIM
EARLY.
MELANIE: A LEADOFF WALK FOR
TAYLOR HEARN AND IT DOESN'T GET
ANY EASIER.
MATT CHAPMAN, A NINE GAME STREAK
RIGHT NOW.
EIGHT HOME RUNS, 52 R.B.I.
HEARN REALLY NOT EFFECTIVE
AROUND THE ZONE RIGHT NOW.
YOU WILL SEE THIS I THINK
ESPECIALLY OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
DAYS STILL AS PITCHERS ADJUST TO
THESE NEW RULES.
HE IS GOING PRETTY FASTBALL
EXCLUSIVE.
YONDER: I THINK FOR CHAPMAN,
THIS IS A GOOD TIME TO POSSIBLY
AMBUSH.
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO WIN THESE
1-1 COUNTS.
FOR A HITTER WHEN YOU WIN A 1-1
COUNT, THAT PUTS YOU AT A HUGE
ADVANTAGE TO SUCCEED AT THE
PLATE.
MELANIE: LET'S SEE WHAT HE CAN
DO WITH THE 1-1.
HEARN IS READY.
BUCK: WHEN YOU SAY AMBUSH, WHAT
ARE YOU SAYING AS A HITTER?
YONDER: I WANT TO GET SOMETHING
UP IN THE ZONE, WHETHER IT IS,
I'M THINKING FASTBALLS UP IN THE
ZONE.
I WANT TO COVER THE TOP HALF OF
THE STRIKE ZONE BUT I'M ALWAYS
READY FOR THE BREAKING BALL AS
WELL, STARTING UP IN THE ZONE,
READY TO HIT TO LEFT CENTER.
MELANIE: HE GETS A HOLD OF ONE,
THOUSAND OFF.
A 1-2 COUNT.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE DISCUSSED,
YOU WANT TO FORCE HIM TO PUT
THAT IN YOUR ZONE BUT HOW DO YOU
NOT LET THAT BLEED OVER INTO
GUESSING AND GUESSING WRONG ON
THE PITCHER?
YONDER: DISCIPLINE.
FOR MATT CHAPMAN, HE IS
OBVIOUSLY STRIKING OUT MORE THAN
HE WOULD LIKE BUT HE IS A FREE
SWINGER, HE IS A SLUGGER BY
NATURE.
WE SAW A PITCH 1-1, HEATER UP IN
THE ZONE.
HE JUST MISSED.
MELANIE: HEARN WITH THE 1-2 AND
AGAIN, HIGH AND AGAIN, HIGH-END
AWAY.
JOSÉ TREVINO BEHIND THE DISH.
IT IS A 2-2 COUNT.
EXPECTING 40-50 PITCHES FOR
TAYLOR HEARN.
THAT IS HIS MAXIMUM.
HE THREW 50 IN KANSAS CITY.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT TAYLOR HEARN IS ABLE TO
BRING TO THE PLATE.
STATCAST, A FOUR SEAM SLIDER,
CHANGEUP AND OCCASIONALLY IN
WITH THE SINKER.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF THE HIGH
HEAT TONIGHT.
HEARN, TYPICALLY A GUY WHO CAN
MANIPULATE BREAKING PITCHES.
HE LIKES TO WORK IN. CHAPMAN
SWINGS AND TEASE THIS OFF TO
DEEP CENTER FIELD.
GARCIA LEAPS AT THE WALL.
TAKE A LONG LOOK AT THAT ONE.
MATT CHAPMAN GETS IT STARTED
WITH A TWO RUN BLAST.
YONDER: JUST AN ABSOLUTE
GORGEOUS AT BAT.
USING HIS LEVERAGE, USING HIS
LEGS, EXTENSION, HE WAS HUNTING
FASTBALLS.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT WITH THE 1-1
COUNT HOW HE MISSED THAT
FASTBALL.
HE PUT A GOOD SWING ON A
FASTBALL MORE DOWN IN THE ZONE
TO TAKE THAT BALL STRAIGHT DEAD
AWAY CENTER.
MELANIE: THAT IS NOT A SMALL
PARK.
BUCK: HE IS NOT EVER ABLE TO
ESTABLISH ANYTHING OFFSPEED.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN FASTBALL.
WE KNOW WHAT MAJOR LEAGUE
HITTERS WILL DO WITHOUT.
MELANIE: THEY PUNISHED HEARN FOR
IT.
422 FEET.
YONDER: FOR A HITTER, YOU ALWAYS
WANT TO ATTACK THE FASTBALL.
CHAPMAN HAS BEEN A LITTLE COLD.
HE IS HITTING .19 NINE
FASTBALLS.
I GUARANTEE YOU, THE HITTING
COACH, DARREN BUSH E, HE WAS
TELLING HIM YOU HAVE TO HUNT THE
FASTBALL ESPECIALLY WITH A GUY
OUT OF THE PEN.
HE WILL USE HIS FASTBALL, HE HAS
A GOOD FASTBALL AT 96, 97.
STAY ON THE FASTBALL.
WHEN CHAPMAN HITS THE FASTBALL,
IT IS LIGHTS OUT.
MELANIE: HEARN 13 PITCHES IN AND
HE HAS FINALLY THROWN HIS FIRST
BREAKING BALL.
HE COMES HOME AGAIN, GOES BACK
TO BACK TO GET MATT OLSON AND
HEARN FINALLY FINDS THE FIRST
OUT.
BUCK: YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT A
DIFFERENT FEELING IT IS FOR GUYS
IN THE BULLPEN TONIGHT, WHEN YOU
KNOW THE STARTING PITCHER IS
GOING TO THROW X NUMBER OF
PITCHES.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE ALL HANDS ON
DECK.
WE SAW A LITTLE MOVEMENT IN THE
BULLPEN AFTER THE SECOND HITTER
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T LET YOUR CLUB
GET TOO FAR DOWN BUT IT IS A
DIFFERENT FEELING IN THE BULLPEN
TONIGHT.
EVERYONE KNOWS THEY MAY PITCH.
BUCK: --
MELANIE: TAYLOR HEARN HAS ONLY
HAD ONE FIRST PITCH STRIKE.
INCOMES LUMBER RAMON LAUREANO.
DISH -- INCOMES RAMON LAUREANO.
YONDER: HE MAY NOT COME INTO A
GAME TO FACE THREE RIGHT-HANDERS
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
BUCK: THERE IS DIFFERENT BODY
LANGUAGE THERE.
MELANIE: HEARN JUST 26 YEARS
OLD.
2-1, LAUREANO SWINGS AND THIS
ONE DRIVES UP THE MIDDLE, IN FOR
A BASE HIT.
THE A'S LOOKING FOR A LITTLE
REDEMPTION AFTER LAST NIGHT.
THEY HAD FALLEN BEHIND AND IT
WAS TOO MUCH GROUND MAKEUP, --
TO MAKE UP, TOO SOON.
YONDER: THERE IS NOTHING BETTER
THAN A 2-1 COUNT.
NOT TRYING TO DO TOO MUCH.
MOST TITTER -- MOST HITTERS TEND
TO HAVE AN EGO.
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU CAN GET A GOOD
FASTBALL, TAKE ADVANTAGE.
FOR LAUREANO, TAKING WHATEVER
THE PITCHER GIVES HIM, THAT IS
THE BEAUTY OF THE SWING.
MELANIE: HEARN WITH A STRIKE TO
PINDER.
PINDER ON A SMALL SKID, 0-8,
TRYING TO GET BACK INTO THE
SWING OF THINGS.
YONDER: CHAD PINDER NEEDS A
LEFT-HANDER.
HE HAS BEEN KNOWN TO CRUSH
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
HE IS HITTING .300 WITH A .874
O.P.S. AGAINST LEFTIES.
THIS GUY CANNOT ONLY PLAY
SHORTSTOP, CENTER FIELD, RIGHT
FIELD, I THINK HE CAN CATCH.
HE IS A KILLER WHEN IT COMES TO
LEFT-HANDED PITCHING.
WITH A LEFT-HANDER ON THE MOUND,
HE IS IN THE LINEUP AND HE KNOWS
IT.
MELANIE: TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SPLITS, .3 00 VERSUS .19 ZERO
AGAINST RIGHTIES.
HE TAKES ON A FASTBALL.
HEARN AHEAD 0-2.
BUCK: WE TALK ABOUT THE GRIP
WITH THE PICTURES -- WITH THE
PITCHERS.
HITTERS CAN GO BACK TO THE
ON-DECK CIRCLE AND GET SOMETHING
TO GRIP THE BAT BETTER.
HOW FAIR IS THAT?
GO AHEAD, I'M SORRY.
MELANIE: THAT WAS A BIG
DISCUSSION, AS WELL AS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN PITCHERS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO PICK UP A BAT AND
HIT.
WILL THEY WALK AWAY WITH THE
GRIP WHEN THEY RETURN TO THE
MOUND?
BUCK: WHEN JOSH DONALDSON WAS
COMPLAINING, I WOULD LIKE FOR
HIM TO HIT WITHOUT BATTING
GLOVES AND PINE TAR.
YOU ARE TRYING TO GRIP A TOOL
YOU PLAY WITH.
I KNOW MLB WILL DO SOME THINGS
IN THE FUTURE TO HELP PITCHERS
MORE UNIVERSALLY WITH THE
BASEBALL, BUT HITTERS HAVE
PADDING.
THEY HAVE ALL TYPES OF STUFF.
PITCHERS BASICALLY HAVE THEIR
FINGERS AND THEIR ARM.
WE COULD GET INTO THIS DEEPER,
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
THOUGHTS, BUT HITTERS ARE ALWAYS
DOING THINGS TO GRIP THE BAT
BETTER.
WE ARE MAKING IT, I THINK IN THE
FUTURE WE WILL LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD A LITTLE.
THE ROSIN BAG JUST GOES SO FAR,
ESPECIALLY ON COLD NIGHTS.
YONDER: AS A HITTER, I USED TO
HAVE ALL TYPES OF THINGS.
I HAD GRIP SPRAY FOR THE BATTING
GLOVES.
I WOULD PUT MY BATTING GLOVES ON
WHERE IT WAS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
TO TAKE THE BATTING GLOVES OFF
MY HAND, BUT IT FELT LIKE I
NEEDED THAT GRIP TO DO WHAT I
WANTED TO DO WITH MY SWING.
LIZARD SKIN CAME AROUND AND WE
WERE ABLE TO MANIPULATE THE BAT
AND THE HANDLE THE LITTLE TO
HAVE BETTER GRIP.
FOR THE PITCHERS THEY NEED TO
MAKE AN ADJUSTMENT.
THE LEAGUE DOES, TO CREATE A BIT
MORE OF A SAFER NATURED FOR
THESE PITCHERS TO CONTROL
PITCHES.
BUCK: LIZARD SKIN?
YOU HAVE TO HELP ME OUT.
LIZARD SKIN?
YONDER: LIZARD SKIN IS LIKE A
TAPE THAT YOU PUT, I THINK JED
LOWRIE HAS IT RIGHT NOW, WHERE
YOU PUT IT ON AND IT IS LIKE A
GUMMY FEEL TO THE BAT.
IT GIVES YOU A SENSE OF A BETTER
GRIP ON THE HANDLE.
YOU PUT THE LIZARD SKIN BEFORE
THE GAME, YOU PUT A BIT OF PINE
TAR, YOU PUT A BIT OF ROSIN AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOU HAVE A BAT
THAT YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU
WANT WITH.
BUCK: THAT'S MY POINT.
HOW FAIR IS IT FOR THE PITCHERS?
I UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM, THE
BASEBALL IS HARD TO GRIP.
THE BAT IS NOT BECAUSE YOU CAN
USE A LOT OF THINGS TO GRIP IT.
OK, I'M DONE.
JUST DOESN'T SEEM FAIR
SOMETIMES.
MELANIE: DID ANYBODY EVER TELL
YOU LIFE'S NOT FAIR?
BUCK: EXACTLY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF WE SENT ALL
THE HITTERS, FROM NOW ON YOU
WANT -- WILL ONLY BE ABLE TO USE
YOUR HANDS ON THE WOOD OF THE
BAT?
YOU CAN'T USE BATTING GLOVES.
HOW ABOUT THE PAD FIRST SO YOU
DON'T HURT YOUR FINGERS SLIDING?
YONDER: THERE IS NO WAY -- IF
SOMEBODY TOLD ME THAT I WOULD,
IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE TO HIT.
I HAD BATTING GLOVES SINCE I WAS
10 YEARS OLD.
FOR ME, I FELT LIKE WHEN YOU
WERE 10 YEARS OLD, PITCHERS WERE
JUST THROWING THE BALL.
I THINK FOR A HITTER, IT IS A
LITTLE BIT INTRIGUING TO SAY THE
LEAST, ON WHAT YOU CAN HAVE.
IF YOU TELL ME TO TAKE MY
BATTING GLOVES OUT -- OFF AND
TRY TO HIT, THAT IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE.
LOTS OF PEOPLE WILL GET HURT AND
A LOT OF BATS WILL FLY ALL OVER
THE PLACE WITH THE AMOUNT OF
SPEED GOING ON IN THE GAME
TODAY.
BUCK: DO YOU THINK IT IS FAIR
FOR A HITTER TO HAVE A SHINGUARD
TO KEEP HIM FROM FOULING THE
BALL OFF THAT THE PITCHER WANTS
TO THROW INSIDE?
I'M TRYING TO GIVE THE OTHER
SIDE OF A PITCHER'S PLAY.
YONDER: I FELT LIKE IF I KNEW
WHAT WAS COMING I WOULDN'T NEED
A CHIN GUARD.
I WOULDN'T NEED ANYTHING.
THE PITCHERS KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO THROW.
IT IS A SURPRISE FOR THE HITTER.
JED LOWRIE, P HITTER.
WHEN WE WERE TEAMMATES I USED TO
SIT WITH HIM, OR STAND NEXT TO
HIM FOR THE ANTHEM AND ASK HIM,
WHAT IS YOUR APPROACH?
IT GOT TO A THING WHERE IT WAS
MORE LIKE ROUTINE FOR US.
WE WOULD STAND NEXT TO EACH
OTHER ON THE ANTHEM AND HE WOULD
WAIT FOR ME TO ASK AND I WOULD
ASK, WHAT IS YOUR APPROACH
AGAINST THIS GUY?
HE WOULD SAY SEE THAT BALL, HIT
THE BALL, HIT THE LINE DRIVE THE
MIDDLE.
IT HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR 200
YEARS.
MELANIE: A VERY CRASH
DAVIS-ESQUE APPROACH.
YONDER: WHAT IS THE APPROACH?
LINE DRIVE UP THE MIDDLE?
HE SAYS, THEY HAVEN'T DONE
ANYTHING ABOUT THE SHIFT YET.
A LINE DRIVE UP THE MIDDLE IS
STILL AVAILABLE.
MELANIE: ONE OF THE BIG THINGS
THAT HAS MADE HIM SUCCESSFUL IN
WHAT YOU COULD CALL A COMEBACK
THIS SEASON.
HEARN IS WORKING AND IT MAY BE
POSSIBLE THAT ON HIS 27TH PITCH,
HE MAY NOT MAKE IT OUT OF NOW
THE SECOND INNING.
HE IS STILL IN THE FIRST.
13 BALLS, 14 STRIKES AND A
LIMITED PITCH COUNT AS HE IS A
SPOT STARTER FOR TEXAS.
TREVINO SAYS HE LIKES THE
CONFIDENCE HE HAS HAD, HE HAS
PICKED IT UP WITH THE FASTBALL.
A MISS INSIDE.
BUCK: WHAT IS TOUGH HERE IS, IN
THE MINOR LEAGUES, YOU AS A
MANAGER, YOU DON'T LET GUYS FILL
MORE THAN 30 -- THROW MORE THAN
30 OR 35 PITCHES IN AN INNING.
IT IS SOMETHING FARM DIRECTORS
TALK TO THE MANAGERS BEFORE THEY
START.
HERE IS WHERE WE WILL CUT GUYS
OFF, STARTER OR RELIEVER.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT 29, 28
PITCHES IN THE FIRST INNING.
WHEN THEY GET UP TO THE BIG
LEAGUES YOU MIGHT THE -- LET
THEM GO FURTHER.
YOU TRY TO PROTECT THEM IN THE
MINORS.
THAT IS ONE OF THE KEYS THAT
FARM DIRECTORS GO OFF OF, TRYING
TO KEEP PEOPLE HEALTHY.
MELANIE: DOUG MATHIS OUT TO TALK
TO TAYLOR HEARN, ALONGSIDE
TREVINO.
SEAN MURPHY COMING UP AND LAST
NIGHT, HE WAS THE POWER FOR THE
A'S.
A BEAUTIFUL READ AND JUST
ABSOLUTELY DESTROYED THE BALL.
MURPHY 1-3 LAST NIGHT, THE HOME
RUN AND R.B.I., HIS NINTH OF THE
SEASON.
TWO DOWN, TWO ON.
TAYLOR HEARN TRYING TO GET TEXAS
OUT OF THIS ONE.
IF YOU ARE MATHIS, WHAT IS THE
CONVERSATION?
BUCK: BASICALLY YOU ARE TRYING
TO START SOMETHING OVER A
LITTLE, RESTART SO TO SPEAK.
HE HAS TO GET AN OUT TO GIVE
THEM TWO INNINGS.
THEY ARE CLOSE TO HAVING TO GET
SOMEBODY UP IN THE BULLPEN.
MORE THAN ANYTHING IT IS ACE --
A CHANGE IN SCENERY.
IT WILL GIVE HIM A FRESH START.
MELANIE: TAKE A LOOK AT HEARN
PLUS NUMBERS WITH -- HIS NUMBERS
WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION.
THE .21 ONE OPPONENT AVERAGE, HE
RESPONSE TO PRESSURE.
-- RESPONDS TO PRESSURE.
THREE STRAIGHT MISSES FOR SEAN
MURPHY.
HEARN STARTING TO MIX IN A FEW
MORE CHANGEUPS AND SLIDERS.
YONDER: I'M SEEING THE BODY
LANGUAGE, WHERE YOU CAN TELL HE
IS HAVING A HARD TIME COMMANDING
THE BALL.
IT MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT OF NOT
HAVING THAT GRIP, OR NOT FEELING
LIKE HE HAS THROWN 30 PITCHES IN
A LONG TIME.
FOR A GUY LIKE MURPHY RIGHT NOW,
THIS IS THE ONE PITCH WHERE YOU
HAVE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE.
YOU ARE MOST LIKELY GOING TO GET
A FASTBALL.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU DON'T
GET FOOLED.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT THAT, I DON'T
WANT TO HIT A GROUND BALL TO
SECOND.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I DRIVE THE
BALL OR BASEBALL IS NOT GOING TO
ROCKET SOMEWHERE ON THE FIELD.
MELANIE: 3-1, BATTLING BACK IN.
HERE COMES HEARN.
THIS WAS NOT THE SITUATION THEY
WANTED TO SEE HERE.
THEY WERE HOPING TO GET AT LEAST
TWO INNINGS FROM HEARN BUT
AGAIN, LIMITED PITCH COUNT.
BUCK: I WOULD BE SURPRISED HE
STARTS THE NEXT DAY AFTER
THROWING ALMOST 35 PITCHES.
MELANIE: THERE IS 34.
HEARN LOSES MURPHY.
BASES-LOADED FOR THE A'S.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE THE LINE
FOR TAYLOR HEARN THIS EVENING.
CHRIS WOODWARD IS OUT.
HE WILL HAVE TO GO TO THE
BULLPEN IN THE FIRST.
A'S TRAILING 2-0.
WE WILL BE BACK MORE.
BROUGHT TO GUS -- BRETT DEGEUS.
>> HOW GREAT WAS IT?
I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG I'M GOING
TO LIVE, BUT I HAVE KNOWN HIM
SIX OR SEVEN YEARS BECAUSE HE
WAS A CLOSER.
HE WOULD GO 10 PITCHES AND THREE
OUTS AND HE IS SHAKING HANDS.
>> GOT HIM AND THE GAME IS OVER
THAT QUICKLY.
>> THE WAY HE STARED WITH ONE
EYE, I COULDN'T REMEMBER SEEING
A PITCHER BE ABLE TO THROW
STRIKES WHENEVER HE WANTED.
>> LOOK AT THAT LOCATION.
>> HE WAS LIKE A MUSKETEER DOING
IT, AND MARKSMAN.
>> HE IS ALWAYS AHEAD AND THE
COUNT.
HE IS AMAZING.
>> LOOKS LIKE A DEMON, PAINTS
LIKE AN ANGEL.
>> HE IS LIKE ZORRO WITH THE
MUSTACHE AND HAIR.
HE IS POINTING AT GUYS, SHOOTING
THEM DOWN.
THERE WERE HARD FEELINGS AND HE
DIDN'T CARE.
IT'S LIKE, TOO BAD, GET A HIT
NEXT TIME.
>> I TRIED TO HAVE A PRESENCE ON
THE MOUND BECAUSE I THINK
HITTERS CAN SENSE A PITCHER WHEN
HE IS NOT CONFIDENT.
I TRY TO PLAY THE PART.
>> YOU HAD TO PLAY THE PART.
I PLAYED THIS CONFIDENT GUY.
DEEP INSIDE, THAT WASN'T ME AT
ALL.
♪
MELANIE: TAYLOR HEARN ON HIS WAY
OUT FROM HIS START.
A REMINDER, THE CHECK ON FOREIGN
SUBSTANCES BEGAN YESTERDAY.
STARTING PITCHERS HAVE MORE THAN
ONE MANDATORY CHECK PER GAME
WHILE THEY MAKE THEIR WAY TO THE
DUGOUT.
RELIEF PITCHERS CHECKED AT THE
CONCLUSION OF EVERY INNING.
KLUBER SERVERS -- CLOSERS ARE
CHECKED BEFORE THEY GO OUT.
ROSIN BAGS CAN BE USED.
CHRIS SAID IT SEEMED NONCHALANT
THE WAY THEY WENT THROUGH
EVERYTHING.
THIS IS PAR FOR THE COURSE.
YOU HAVE THE CREW CHIEF AND
OCCASIONALLY THE HOME PLATE,
THERE ARE ALWAYS TWO UMPIRES
THAT WILL TANDEM THIS.
HOLD THE GLOVE, TAKE A LOOK,
FLIP OF THE CAP AND CHECK THE
BELT.
DE GEUS, HIS 19TH APPEARANCE ON
THE SEASON, JUST 23 YEARS OLD.
SINK OR, CURVE, CUTTER AND
FASTBALL.
STARTS WITH ELVIS ANDRUS.
BUCK: CAN YOU IMAGINE BEING
HEARN?
YOU HAD AN INNING YOU WANT TO BE
FORGETTING ABOUT AND THEY COME
OUT AND CHECK YOU?
I KNOW HE WOULD LOVE TO SAY
OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT USING
ANYTHING, GUYS.
YONDER: HE MUST HAVE BEEN LIKE,
GUYS.
REALLY?
30 PLUS PITCHES, I WAS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
DO YOU THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
FIND SOMETHING?
MOVE ON.
HE FELT LIKE THEY HAVE TO MAKE
AN ADJUSTMENT ON THAT.
MELANIE: BASE HIT.
ELVIS ANDRUS, HIS FIRST SINCE
RETURNING BACK TO TEXAS.
THE A'S KEEP PILING IT ON.
YONDER: JUST THE TYPICAL ELVIS
ANDRUS AT BAT.
GETTING WHAT THE PITCHER, HE
EXECUTED ON THE PITCH BUT ANDRUS
, A BETTER HITTER, WINNING THE
1-1 COUNT, TAKING IT RIGHT UP
THE MIDDLE.
A BEAUTIFUL SWING FOR ELVIS
ANDRUS.
MELANIE: HIS FIRST HIT AND IT IS
A TWO RUN SINGLE.
THE A'S TALLYING THEM UP, 4-0 IN
THE FIRST, TRYING TO FIND THE
FINAL OUT.
HE WAS EMOTIONAL YESTERDAY.
HE DIDN'T EXPECT TO GET THE
STANDING OVATION HE DID.
BUT FANS HAVE BEEN POURING IN
FOR THE LAST TWO DAYS, JUST
DYING TO SEE A GUY WHO IS SO
PERSONABLE AND SUCH A HUGE
CHARACTER.
YONDER: YOU KNOW WHY THAT HIT
WAS IMPORTANT?
YOU SAW SEAN MURPHY GO FIRST TO
THIRD WITH TWO OUTS, THE
LEFT-HANDER IN SKYE BOLT COMING
UP TO BAT, A PITCHER WHO HAS A
CUTTER INTO TWO-SEAMER HE RELIES
ON, HE COULD TURN THIS INTO
ANOTHER BASE AT R.B.I..
THOSE ARE WINNING PLAYS BY A
FIRST-PLACE TEAM.
BUCK: CAN YOU NAME ANOTHER
CATCHER WHO WOULD GO FIRST TO
THIRD IN THAT SITUATION?
I CAME OUT OF MY CHAIR AND WENT,
THE CATCHER WENT FIRST TO THIRD.
YONDER: A GUIDE -- GUY LIKE
REALMUTO, CONTRERAS FOR THE CUBS
, THOSE GUYS WOULD DO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
NOAH DAYS WE SEE MORE CATCHERS
WITH MORE ATHLETIC BUILD THAN
EVER.
BACK 12, 14 YEARS AGO, YOU WOULD
SEE CATCHERS WHO WERE JUST A
BASE TO BASE TYPE GUY.
NOWADAYS WE SEE THESE GUYS ALL
OVER THE FIELD, LIKE OHTANI
HITTING HOME RUNS AND THROWING
98 OFF THE MOUND.
WE WILL BE SEEING MORE OF THAT
AS THE YEARS GO ON.
BUCK: WE HAVE A SITUATION HERE.
AT FIRST AND THIRD.
THE THIRD BASEMEN IS SO FAR AWAY
FROM THE RUNNER AT THIRD, HE HAS
TO GET SUCH A BIG PRIMARY LEAD.
IF YOU THROW TO SECOND AND THE
RUNNER STOPS, THE GUY AT THIRD
WILL WALK HOME.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WITH THE
THICK -- WITH THE SHIFT.
IF YOU THROW THIS BALL TO THE
MIDDLE OF THE DIAMOND, HE WILL
WALK HOME.
YONDER: FOR THE THIRD BASE
RUNNER YOU WANT TO GET THE LEAD
AS FAR AS THE THIRD BASEMEN IS.
IF THE THIRD BASEMEN IS ABOUT 20
FEET, GO AHEAD AND GET A 20 FOOT
LEAD.
IT IS A RACE TO THE BAG.
YOU COULD TAKE A 17 FOOT LEAD,
YOU HAVE THE THIRD BASE COACH
HELPING YOU OUT.
IF THAT GUY SNEAKS BEHIND, THE
THIRD-BASE COACHES ALL OVER IT.
YOU WANT TO GET AS FAR AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU SEE HIM CHECKING THE THIRD
BASEMEN.
HE CAN GET A WALK AND IF THERE
IS A BALL IN THE DIRT HE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO SCORE.
BUCK: THAT TELLS ME THAT THEY
ARE NOT THROWING THROUGH.
MELANIE: A TOUGH BREAK FOR THE
RANGERS.
THEY FINALLY END THE TOP OF THE
FIRST, ALL NINE A'S COME TO THE
PLATE AND IN THE BIGGEST WAY
POSSIBLE FOR MATT CHAPMAN,
DROPPING ONE DEAD CENTER.
♪
>> THIS ONE HIT HARD.
THAT IS INTO THE ALLEY IN RIGHT
FIELD.
THAT MIGHT BE ENOUGH TROUBLE TO
GET GARCIA ALL THE WAY IN FROM
FIRST.
THEY WAVE HIM AROUND THIRD.
THE THROW FROM CORREA, NOT IN
TIME.
ADOLIS SCORES FROM FIRST.
>> GORDON LEADING IT OFF FOR
MINNESOTA.
LINES IT RIGHT AND A SLIDING
GRAB BY JOEY GALLO.
GOOD DEFENSE.
>> GALLO HITS THIS ONE, BROKEN
BAT FLARE INTO CENTER FIELD FOR
A HIT.
IT SCORES LOWE. 7-5 GAME.
THE TYING RUN GETS TO THE PLATE.
>> 3-2.
THAT BALL, ABSOLUTELY HAMMERED.
WHERE WILL IT LAND?
WHAT A SHOT BY GALLO.
HOLY SMOKES, THAT THING WAS
BLASTED.
IT IS A 4-2 BALLGAME.
GOODNESS GRACIOUS.
>> SO BIG, THE MUSIC STARTED
PLAYING WHEN THE BALL WAS STILL
IN THE AIR.
EVERYBODY KNEW THIS WAS GONE
INCLUDING JOEY GALLO.
MELANIE: ATHLETICS WITH A 4-0
LEAD.
KINER-FALEFA, 129 CONSECUTIVE
GAMES PLAYED.
THE SHORTSTOP LEADS THINGS OFF.
HE WILL BE FOLLOWED BY ELI
WHITE.
ADOLIS GARCIA HAS BEEN ON FIRE,
BATTING THIRD.
JOEY GALLO THE DESIGNATED HITTER
CLINT -- CLEANS THINGS UP.
IBANEZ THAT'S -- BATS NEXT.
WILLIE CALHOUN'S SEVENTH.
THEY FOLLOWED THAT UP WITH JOSÉ
TREVINO AND CHARLIE CULBERSON.
COLE IRVIN FOR THE ATHLETICS ON
THE MOUND.
MAKING HIS 15TH START.
YONDER: I THINK FOR COLE IRVIN
TODAY HE NEEDS TO RELY ON
KEEPING THE BALL DOWN WITH HIS
TWO-SEAMER.
LOVES TO THROW HIS CHANGEUP, HE
CAN THROW IT IN ANY COUNT AT ANY
MOMENT.
ANY TIME HE GETS IN TROUBLE, HE
IS UP IN THE ZONE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THAT BLAZING
FASTBALL AT 96, 97.
HE WILL BE AROUND 89, 92 BUT HE
RELIES ON COMMAND AND HIS
CHANGEUP.
MELANIE: LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
YOU WERE MENTIONING IRVIN, THE
KEYS TO THE GAME ON THE FLIP
SIDE OF THINGS FOR THE
ATHLETICS.
BOB MELVIN MIGHT BE HAPPY WITH
HOW QUICKLY HE HAS GOTTEN SOME
KEYS ROLLING.
YONDER: FOR THE MIDDLE OF THE
ORDER DOMINANCE, WE SIDE IN THE
TOP OF THE FIRST WITH CHAPMAN
AND THE HOMER BUT FOR ME, IT
COMES DOWN TO WINNING THE
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION
BATTLE.
LAST NIGHT THEY LEFT 17 ON BASE.
TODAY THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
EXECUTE.
A KEY FOR ME IS WINNING THOSE
1-1 COUNTS.
FOR A GUY LIKE IRVIN, 1-1 COUNTS
ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE LEAGUE
AVERAGE, HITTERS ARE HITTING
.342 OFF IT.
THE A'S ARE HITTING, ON DEFENSE,
.322.
THE STARTING PITCHING HAS DONE
AN EXCELLENT JOB WITH THE 1-1
COUNTS.
ON THE OFFENSIVE SIDE, 1-1
COUNTS, THE A'S ARE HITTING .367
AVERAGE.
YOU WONDER WHY THEY ARE IN
FIRST?
THAT IS A BIG REASON.
MELANIE: WITH HOUSTON HEATING
UP, BOB MELVIN SAYS HE WON'T PAY
ATTENTION UNTIL LATER IN THE
SEASON BUT YOU KNOW THE BIGGER
OF A GAP YOU HAVE COME OF THE
MORE THAT WILL COME BACK ON
PAYOFF.
YONDER: IT IS FUNNY HE SAID
THAT.
FOR A PLAYER, YOU WANT TO KNOW
WITH EVERYBODY IN THE DIVISION
IS DOING, WHAT YOUR BOYS ARE
DOING AND WHAT EVERY TEAM IS
DOING AROUND THE LEAGUE.
FOR THE A'S, YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU TAKE CARE OF BUSINESS
FIRST.
AFTER THE GAME IS OVER, YOU
CHECK THE BOX SCORE AND MAKE
SURE IF HOUSTON HAS A LOSS, YOU
KNOW ABOUT IT.
MELANIE: YOU HAD PLENTY OF TEXT
MESSAGES I'M SURE THAT WERE SO
UPLIFTING TO YOUR BUDDIES ON
OTHER TEAMS THAT YOU WERE
DUELING WITH.
YONDER: DEPENDS ON THE
SITUATION.
IF I HAD A BIG NIGHT AND WE GOT
THE WIN, IF THEY WON OR HAD A
BIG NIGHT, THEY WOULD LET ME
KNOW.
IT CAME BACK AND FORTH ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT.
MELANIE: ALL IS FAIR IN WINNING,
LOSING, LOVE AND BASEBALL.
YONDER: AT ALL TIMES.
MELANIE: ADOLIS GARCIA.
BUCK: IRVIN, THAT IS IT -- THE
FIRST BALL OF THE GAME FOR HIM.
YONDER: THAT IS WHO HE IS.
HE IS A GUY THAT, HE IS NOT
GOING TO WOW YOU WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE BOX.
HE WILL NOT HAVE 15 STRIKEOUTS
LIKE DEGROM, BUT THIS IS A GUY
WHO, AS A HITTER, IT IS
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE
FIRST AT-BAT, YOU MAY GRIND OUT
AND HIT A BASE HIT AND SAY I'M
IN FOR A GOOD NIGHT.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
THREE PUNCH-OUTS.
MELANIE: A SHARP GROUND OUT TO
THE THIRD BASEMEN TO END IT FOR
A DULLES GARCIA.
1-2-3 INNING FOR FIND AN ANSWERT
OAKLAND.
THE A'S HAVE COME OUT HOT COME
UP 4-0 AFTER THE FIRST.
♪
>> THEY ARE JUMPING ALL OVER HIM
RIGHT NOW.
>> BOTTOM OF THE FIRST,
KINER-FALEFA, SINGLE, DOUBLE,
WALK, DOUBLE.
>> IBANEZ HAS A HOT BAT.
HE HAMMERS THAT BALL.
DEEP OUT TO LEFT, IT IS GONE.
THE FIRST BIG-LEAGUE HIT AND THE
FIRST HOME RUN FOR IBANEZ.
>> 5-0 TEXAS.
>> A HARD-HIT BALL TO LEFT.
THIS ONE IS GOING TO SAIL OVER
WHITE'S HEAD AND IT IS OUT OF
THE PARK.
FIRST HIT FOR THE A'S IS A HOME
RUN.
>> MURPHY THE LINE DRIVE HOME
RUN TO LEFT GETS THE A'S ON THE
BOARD AND THE FIFTH.
>> A COUPLE BASERUNNERS FOR
TREVINO.
HE HITS THIS BALL DEEP TO CENTER
FIELD.
LAUREANO ON THE RUN, LOOKS UP,
IT IS GONE.
A THREE RUN SHOT BY TREVINO AND
THOSE ARE SOME HUGE INSURANCE
RUNS FOR THE RANGERS.
>> NINTH INNING.
IAN KENNEDY COMES IN.
>> THE CHOPPER OVER THE MOUND.
THEY BOBBLE IT AT SECOND BUT
RECOVER AND THE BALLGAME IS
OVER.
♪
MELANIE: OAKLAND WITH A BIG 4-0
LEAD OVER THE RANGERS.
JAMES KAPRIELIAN, HIS DAD IS IN
THE STANDS AT FENWAY PARK, WHICH
IS A HISTORICAL ENOUGH PLACE TO
MAKE A HUGE START.
TALK ABOUT FIRED UP DAD.
THESE ARE THOSE MOMENTS YOU LIVE
FOR, SEEING GUYS WHO ARE
BREAKING INTO THE BIG LEAGUES.
HE HAS BEEN A WELL TALKED ABOUT
MEMBER OF THE ATHLETICS AS HE
MADE HIS WAY UP TO FINALLY START
CONTRIBUTING TO THE BIG-LEAGUE
CLUB.
WELCOME IN JAMES KAPRIELIAN.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, AS WE BRING
THIS TO YOU WITH STATE FARM, I
WANTED TO GO THROUGH SOMETHING.
YOU HAVE HAD QUITE A JOURNEY IN
YOUR HOME LIFE AS WELL TO BE IN
THIS MOMENT.
YOUR DAD IS SO PROUD OF YOU.
YOU TAKEN THE SILENCE.
WHAT IS YOUR PROCESS?
JAMES: FOR ME, HANG ON -- ONE
SECOND.
ATTA BOY.
FOR ME, TALENT IS GOING TO ONLY
GET ME SO FAR.
FOR ME IT IS MORE ABOUT THE WORK
AND ENJOYING THE PROCESS OF WORK
AND BEING ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THE SMALL THINGS, THE MENTALITY
AND FINDING WAYS TO PUT MYSELF
IN A SITUATION TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AND COMFORTABLE.
I AM MOST COMFORTABLE ON THE
MOUND AND I FEEL LIKE I CAN BE
MYSELF AND DOMINATE AND GIVE
MYSELF A CHANCE TO WIN.
THAT IS THE NAME OF THE GAME,
WINNING.
MELANIE: DOING A GOOD JOB OF IT.
MARK CANHA STARTING THE SECOND
OFF WITH A TRIPLE.
YOU HAD TO GIVE HIM A LITTLE
ENCOURAGEMENT.
JAMES: GOT TO SHOW LOVE TO THE
BOYS ALWAYS.
THEY ARE OFF TO A GOOD START
RIGHT NOW.
THE BATS ARE ALIVE RIGHT NOW.
BUCK: HOW DO YOU LIKE THIS
BALLPARK?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
FIRST TIME SEEING IT?
JAMES: THIS IS MY SECOND TIME
HERE.
I CAME HERE LAST YEAR.
I WAS ON THE TAXI SQUAD LAST
YEAR.
A BEAUTIFUL BALLPARK.
THEY DID A GREAT JOB.
GOOD TO SEE THE FANS BACK IN THE
STADIUM.
IT WAS QUIET LAST YEAR WITH A
LOT OF ECHO.
THEY DID A GOOD JOB.
I HAVE BEEN ASKING THE GUYS WHAT
IT IS LIKE THROWING ON THIS
MOUND.
IT IS A BEAUTIFUL BALLPARK.
I THOUGHT THEY DID A GREAT JOB.
YONDER: YONDER ALONSO HERE.
I REMEMBER MY DAD WHEN I WAS IN
MY FIRST BIG-LEAGUE GAME, HE SAW
ME BEFORE THE GAME AND I WAS
DRESSED UP IN MY CINCINNATI REDS
UNIFORM.
I WILL NEVER FORGET SEEING HIM
AND LOOKING AT HIS EYES AND
HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF WATERY
EYES.
I GOT WATERY, MYSELF.
IN BOSTON WHEN YOU SAW YOUR DAD,
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE, MAN?
WARMING UP, STRETCHING OUT --
WHAT WAS THAT WHOLE DAY LIKE?
JAMES: IT WAS EMOTIONAL, TO BE
HONEST.
LIKE YOU SAID, THERE IS SO MUCH
EMOTION.
FOR ME, RECOGNIZING THE MOMENTS,
THE HARD TIMES AND GOOD TIMES I
WENT THROUGH TO GET TO THIS
POINT.
MY DAD PERSONALLY, SEEING THE
STRUGGLES, THE DISAPPOINTMENT I
HAVE HAD NOT MAKING THE TEAM OUT
OF CAMP OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE,
THEN FOR ALL OF IT TO COME TO
FRUITION, IT WAS EMOTIONAL.
OBVIOUSLY I WAS THE FIRST ONE
WARMING UP ON THE TRACK AT
FENWAY, AND THE FIRST PERSON I
SAW WAS MY DAD AND HE GAVE ME
THE THUMBS UP AND TOLD ME, GET
AFTER THEM AND GET TO WORK AND
HAVE FUN.
ENABLE TO PITCH, COLLECT A WIN,
GIVING MY TEAM A CHANCE TO WIN
AND LOOKING UP IN THE STANDS AND
SEEING THE RELIEF, OBVIOUSLY
GOING TO GIVE MY DAD A BIG HUG
AFTER THE GAME, I KNOW HOW PROUD
HE WAS.
IT WAS AN EMOTIONAL MOMENT FOR
ME AND HIM AND THE REST OF MY
FAMILY.
EVERYONE WHO SUPPORTED ME ALONG
THE WAY.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
INDESCRIBABLE.
YOU KIND OF IMAGINE WHAT THAT
FEELS LIKE, BUT IT IS HARD TO
EXPLAIN.
IT IS SO EMOTIONAL, SUCH A
SPECIAL MOMENT FOR ALL OF US.
MELANIE: CLUBS TEND TO GO ONE OF
TWO WAYS WITH A DEBUT.
THEY WILL JOKE OR THEY TELL YOU
HONESTLY, HOW DID YOU FIND OUT?
WHO WAS THE FIRST PERSON YOU
TOLD?
JAMES: MY DAD WAS THE FIRST
PERSON I TOLD.
I WAS IN LAS VEGAS AND TRIPLE-A,
SPENT UNDER A WEEK THERE.
THE COACHING STAFF CALLED MEEHAN
AND I FIGURED THEY WANTED TO
TALK TO ME ABOUT A GAME PLAN,
AND THEY SAID HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT HAVING YOUR NEXT START AT
FENWAY?
I WAS LIKE, ABSOLUTELY, READY TO
GO.
SO I WALKED DOWN THE HALLWAY,
CALLED MY DAD RIGHT AWAY.
HE WAS THRILLED.
HE WAS SHOCKED.
HE ASKED HOW I WAS FEELING.
FROM THEN ON, IT WAS, LET'S
BEGIN THE PREPARATION AND DO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO BE READY.
AND WE WENT TO WORK.
THAT IS WHAT WE DO.
BUCK: YOU GUYS MADE ME LOOK
SMART EARLY ON.
YOU WERE STRUGGLING AND THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT, I SAID I
THINK THEY WILL BE RIGHT THERE
TO WIN THE DIVISION.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT BOB
MELVIN.
WHEN YOU GO THROUGH TOUGH TIMES
EARLY IN THE SEASON, THE WAY HE
PRESENTS, THE ATMOSPHERE HE
CREATES.
JAMES: HE JUST HAS A VERY CALM,
COOL, COLLECTED KIND OF SWAGGER
TO HIM.
I THINK THE REST OF THE TEAM
FEEDS OFF THAT.
HE DOES A GREAT JOB LEADING US.
AS A MANAGER, HE REALLY DOES A
GOOD JOB OF PUTTING US AS
PLAYERS IN THE BEST POSITION TO
HAVE SUCCESS.
FOR US, IT IS JUST ABOUT GOING
OUT AND DOING OUR JOB AND I
THINK THIS TEAM IS SO TALENTED,
THEY ARE NOT REALLY GOING TO
FLINCH.
EVERYONE WANTS TO DO THEIR BEST
AND DO WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO.
HI.
MELANIE: ANDRUS, YOU HAVE TO
GIVE HIM TIME.
WHO IS HE GETTING YOUR ATTENTION
FOR?
JAMES: THE STARTING PITCHERS.
EVERYONE IS ALL OVER EACH OTHER.
ELVIS WANTS THE ATTENTION.
BUCK: HE WANTS THE HEADSET.
JAMES: HE DOES WANTED.
HE DESERVES IT.
HE IS A LEGEND.
BUCK: I LOVE IT, MAN.
IT IS FUNNY ON JULY 31 WHEN YOU
GOT TRADED FROM THE YANKEES COME
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS
BUT I WAS A PART OF THAT TRADE.
TWO NIGHTS BEFORE.
WE WERE GOING TO GET TRADED FOR
EACH OTHER, YOU GOT TRADED FOR
SONNY GRAY.
GOING BACK TO THE BRONX, HOW DID
THAT FEEL?
I SAW A CLIP OF YOU, HOW EXCITED
YOU WERE.
YOU NAILED IT, MAN.
JAMES: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT WAS, YOU KNOW -- LET'S GO.
IT WAS A SPECIAL MOMENT, MAN.
I DON'T HAVE ANY HARD FEELINGS
TOWARDS THE YANKEES OR ANYTHING.
I UNDERSTAND HOW THE BUSINESS
WORKS.
AT A CERTAIN PARADE -- POINT ALL
OF US UNDERSTAND HOW THE GAME
GOES.
WE ARE FORTUNATE TO BE PART OF
IT.
THE GAME DOESN'T NEED US, WE
NEED THE GAME.
I REALIZED THAT EARLY.
WHEN I GOT TRADED TO THE A'S, I
WAS ALL OAKLAND A'S AND WANTED
TO DO MY BEST FOR THIS
ORGANIZATION AND MAKE THEM
PROUD.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I DID
TAKE THINGS PERSONAL THAT THEY
WANTED TO PICK UP SONNY GRAY.
I UNDERSTAND, HE IS A GREAT
PITCHER AND DID A GREAT JOB.
AT THE SAME TIME, I WANT TO GO
BACK AND SHOW THOSE GUYS WHO I
AM AND WHAT I'M ABOUT.
TO PITCH THEIR AGAINST MY OLD
TEAMMATES, SEE THE STAFF MEMBERS
WHO TOOK CARE OF ME ON MY WAY UP
THROUGH THAT SYSTEM, IT WAS
SPECIAL.
TO COLLECT STRIKEOUTS AGAINST
THE GUYS WHO I CAME UP WITH, IT
IS A GOOD FEELING.
MELANIE: A GOOD TASTE IN YOUR
MOUTH, A 7-0 LEAD.
A HOME RUN IN EACH INNING.
RAMON LIOTTA -- RAMON LAUREANO
WITH A BLAST AND IT IS A 7-0
LEAD.
THIS IS BRETT DEGEUS'27TH PITCH
AND HE FINALLY PICKS UP A
STRIKEOUT AFTER TAYLOR HEARN
DIDN'T MAKE IT OUT OF THE FIRST.
BUCK: ARE YOU WORKING WITH THE
HITTERS TODAY, JAMES?
JAMES: I'M NOT WORKING WITH THE
HEADERS.
I TOOK B.P. IN COLORADO.
I THOUGHT I TOOK SOME PRETTY
B.P., BUT THESE GUYS ARE SO GOOD
AT THIS LEVEL.
I CAN'T EVEN KEEP UP WITH ALL
THE STUFF THESE GUYS DO IN THE
BOX.
THEY MAKE IT LOOK EASY.
YONDER: TALK TO ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE UCLA DAYS.
I KNOW YOU WERE A FIRST ROUNDER
IN 2015.
YOU ARE A FORMER PROSPECT.
UCLA HAS HAD SOME PRETTY GOOD
PITCHERS COME OUT OF THAT
BRUINS, THEY ALL-BRUINS.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE ON THAT?
DO YOU FEEL LIKE -- I THINK YOU
COULD BE PART OF THAT LEGACY,
WITH ALL THE TALENTED PITCHERS
COMING OUT OF THEIR.
JAMES: THE COACH DOES AN
UNBELIEVABLE JOB RECRUITING.
OBVIOUSLY IT HAS BECOME ONE OF
THOSE PLACES WHERE GUYS WANT TO
GO AND POLISH THEIR GAME AND
BECOME A FRONTLINE STARTER.
FOR ME, WHEN I WAS DECIDING, I
KNEW I WANTED TO GO TO COLLEGE.
I WASN'T READY FOR PROFESSIONAL
BASEBALL.
I WANTED TO GO TO COLLEGE AND
COACH SAVAGE CAME IN WITH A PLAN
AND PRESENTED IT TO ME AND MY
FAMILY AND ME BEING A U.S.C.
GUY, IT WAS HARD FOR ME TO
REALIZE THIS IS THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME.
I REMEMBER BEING IN TOUCH WITH
GERRIT COLE, HE GREW UP IN THE
SAME COMMUNITY HAS ME SO I
ACTUALLY GAVE HIM A SHOUT AND
GOT HIS OPINION ON SOME THINGS.
THERE WAS A PECKING ORDER IN THE
LINE THAT I WANTED TO FALL INTO.
WHEN I PLAYED FOR COACH SAVAGE,
NEXT THING YOU KNOW GERRIT COLE
IS IN THE BIG LEAGUES DOING HIS
THING AND I MET UCLA COMPETING
FOR A CHAMPIONSHIP.
AND LEARNING A TON.
FOR ME, IT WAS JUST FOLLOWING
THE PLAN AND TRYING TO LEARN AND
BECOME THE BEST BASEBALL PLAYER
I COULD BE.
I'M FORTUNATE IT HAS GOTTEN ME
TO THIS POINT.
I HAVE HIGH GOALS.
I WOULD LOVE TO DO WHAT GERRIT
AND TREVOR AND THESE OTHER UCLA
GUYS HAVE DONE.
THEY HAVE CREATED -- YOU KNOW, A
DOMINANT PITCHER STATUS AND I
KIND OF WANT TO BE THAT GUY WHO
TEAMS FEEL COMFORTABLE HANDING
THE BALL TO IN BIG GAMES.
AND YOU WANT TO TRUST THAT GUY
TO GET A WIN.
YONDER: ARE YOU A TROJAN OR
BRUIN IN THE FALL WITH FOOTBALL
SEASON?
JAMES: I AM A BRUIN BUT IT IS
TOUGH.
IT IS TOUGH FOR ME.
I LOVE THE TROJANS.
I GREW UP GOING TO USC FOOTBALL
GAMES MY WHOLE LIFE.
IT IS TOUGH FOR ME.
MELANIE: JAMES KAPRIELIAN,
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
MIGHT BE TOUGH IN THE FALL.
THE A'S UPTWO INNINGS.
THE RANGERS COMING TO BAT,
LOOKING FOR AN ANSWER, WHEN WE
COME BACK.
♪
>> 2-2.
LINED TO LEFT, CAREER BASE HIT
NUMBER 1000.
MITCH MORELAND, GET HIM THE
BASEBALL.
A MILESTONE FOR MITCH.
>> HIT WELL.
CANHA REACHING UP, HE MAKES A
PHENOMENAL CATCH.
SCRATCHES UP AGAINST THE WALL.
FIRES BACK INTO THE INFIELD AND
THE RUNNERS GET BACK.
>> KEMP RIGHT FIELD AND THAT
BABY IS GONE.
TONY KEMP, A THREE RUN HOMER.
DAYS LEAD 5-3 -- THE A'S LEAD
5-3.
>> TONY KEMP COMES THROUGH.
>> LINED TO RIGHT CENTER AND
SKYE BOLT, DIVING AND HE MAKES A
PHENOMENAL CATCH.
WHAT A PLAY BY SKYE BOLT ON A
WICKED SHOT HIT BY JARED WONG.
>> THE OP WONG -- THE 0-1.
LAUREANO NEAR THE WALL, JUMPS AT
THE WALL.
RAMON LAUREANO IS BACK IN THE
HOUSE.
A GREAT CATCH BY RAMON, LIKE HE
NEVER LEFT AND IT IS A 1-2-3
INNING FOR THE ATHLETICS.
♪
MELANIE: THE ATHLETICS ARE
TAKING THINGS OUT OF CONTROL.
TAKE A LOOK AT SUNDAY'S
PERFORMANCE ACROSS MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
THE YANKEES ARE TRYING TO MAKE
HISTORY AND SEE HOW MANY TRIPLE
PLAYS THEY CAN TURN IN A SEASON.
HOW ABOUT THIS ONE?
WALKOFF GRAND SLAM, WHY NOT?
THE SEATTLE MARINERS HAD A LOSS
TO START THE SEASON BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN FINDING THEIR WAY.
THAT BRINGS UP OUR YOUTUBE FAN
PAUL.
IT IS A MORE EXCITING WAY TO END
A BASEBALL GAME, TRIPLE PLAY OR
WALKOFF GRAND SLAM?
WEIGH IN ON THIS ONE, BECAUSE WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE OF THOSE.
YOU CAN'T GET MUCH MORE HEIGHT.
-- MUCH MORE HYPE.
YONDER: AS A HITTER, WALKOFF
GRAND SLAM ALL DAY.
MELANIE: I THINK YOU ARE BIASED.
BUT I AGREE, THE ENERGY IS MORE
JUICED ON A GRAND SLAM.
YONDER: 100%.
I THINK WHEN THERE IS BASES
LOADED, EVERYBODY IS THINKING WE
ARE GETTING FOUR IN.
WE ARE HITTING THE TOTAL BASES
IN.
YOU NEVER EXPECT A TRIPLE PLAY.
LIKE YOU DON'T EXPECT A
NO-HITTER.
IN THE SEVENTH INNING, YOU ARE
LIKE, WE HAVE A NO-HITTER.
A TRIPLE PLAY IS LIKE, MY GOSH,
WE HAVE A TRIPLE PLAY.
WHEN THERE IS BASES-LOADED, YOU
ARE THINKING ABOUT ONE THING.
IT IS A POSSIBLE GRAND SLAM
ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
MELANIE: GOING TO GO HUNT SOME
MEATBALLS ON THAT ONE.
THE A'S HAVE BEEN TEEING OFF
AGAINST TEXAS, UP 7-0 AND TEXAS
HAS ONLY BROUGHT THREE MEN TO
THE PLATE SO FAR.
MEANWHILE, FOR OAKLAND, THEY
HAVE THREE GUYS LEFT STILL
WAITING FOR THEIR SECOND TIME
ALREADY.
14 PITCHERS FOR COLE IRVIN.
HE WAS EFFECTIVE IN THE FIRST.
HE GETS GALLO TO CHASE A
BREAKING BALL.
THAT IS HIS THIRD STRIKE IN FOUR
BATTERS.
-- STRIKEOUT IN FOUR BATTERS.
BUCK: I HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
POLL QUESTION.
I ALWAYS BIG ABOUT THE ANXIETY
OF FIRST AND SECOND, NOBODY OUT
WITH A ONE RUN LEAD.
THERE IS A LOT LESS STRESS ON A
MANAGER FOR THE GRAND SLAM.
BUT I THINK ABOUT HAVING TO GET
TO THAT SITUATION, THAT IS
PAINFUL.
MELANIE: IBANEZ, THE ROOKIE WITH
THE FIRST HIT FOR THE RANGERS.
LET'S SEND IT OUT TO BRETT.
WE HAVE LEFT YOU HANGING A
LITTLE BUT YOU SEEM TO HAVE A
GOOD INSIGHT ON THE SKIP.
BRETT: IT WAS A LITTLE OVER 10
YEARS AGO THIS MONTH THAT BOB
MELVIN WAS NAMED AS INTERIM
MANAGER OF THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS.
FAST FORWARD 10 YEARS, HE IS THE
LONGEST TENURED MANAGER WITH HIS
CURRENT TEAM, HAS WON OVER 1300
CAREER GAMES, HAS TAKEN OAKLAND
TO THE POSTSEASON THREE STRAIGHT
YEARS.
HIS TEAM STARTED 0-6, THEY WOUND
UP FINISHING APRIL IN FIRST
PLACE.
AS MUCH AS THINGS CHANGE YEAR TO
YEAR OVER THE COURSE OF BASEBALL
OR EVEN WITH THIS FRANCHISE, THE
ONE CONSTANT HAS BEEN THE
LEADERSHIP, THE CONSISTENCY OF
BOB MELVIN.
MELANIE: BEFORE YOU CAN SING HIS
PRAISES, HE MAY BE SAYING ABOUT
THE DEFENSE AS WELL.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT MELVIN AND
HIS UP 7-0.
ANOTHER SUBSTANCE CHECK.
GAME CONTINUES WHEN WE COME
BACK.
♪
>> THE 1-0, A LITTLE TAPPER UP
THE THIRD-BASE LINE.
TREVINO SPINS AND HE GOT IT.
GREAT PLAY, MAKING THE THROW AS
HE MADE THE P ROW WET JUST
INSIDE THE -- THE PIROUETTE
INSIDE THE THIRD-BASE LINE.
>> IT IS CARRYING WELL, IT IS
GONE.
ELI WHITE GOES THE OTHER WAY.
THIS BALL HIT WELL, DEEP OUT TO
RIGHT.
THAT ONE IS GONE.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
ELI WHITE GETS HIS FIRST
BIG-LEAGUE HOME RUN TONIGHT, AND
WASTES NO TIME IN GETTING HIS
SECOND.
>> GORDON LEAVING IT OFF FOR
MINNESOTA.
GOES AFTER THE FIRST PITCH.
SLIDING GRAB OUT THERE BY JOEY
GALLO.
A LITTLE BIT OF DEFENSE IN THE
SECOND INNING.
>> HE HITS THIS ONE IN THE AIR.
DEEP TO RIGHT.
IT'S GONE.
THEY HAVE TIED IT UP IN THE
SEVENTH WITH HIS 17TH HOME RUN
OF THE YEAR.
>> GALLO HAS BEEN ON TWICE
TODAY.
>> THERE IS A BALL HIT WAY OUT
OF THIS BALLPARK.
HOW FALL -- FAR WILL IT GO?
HOW ABOUT THE FAÇADE OF THE
SECOND LEVEL AND RIGHT FIELD?
-- IN RIGHT FIELD?
MELANIE: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK, LIVE ON
YOUTUBE, PRESENTED BY STATE
FARM.
BRETT DOLAN WAS JUST MENTIONING
THIS WITH BOB MELVIN, 11 SEASONS
AS OF THE AT -- AS THE ATHLETICS
MANAGER, AND DID THEY EVER LIKE
HIM AND DID IT EVER PAY OFF?
SECOND WINNINGEST MANAGER IN
FRANCHISE HISTORY, THE GREAT
CONNIE MACK, AND THAT IS A
RECORD THAT WILL BE SO HARD FOR
ANYONE ACROSS THE SPORT TO CHASE
AND THE ATHLETICS DID ANNOUNCE
THEY ARE GOING TO EXERCISE THE
OPTION TO PICK UP 2022 -- THE
PLAYERS LOVE PLAYING BEHIND HIM.
OTHER MANAGERS REVERE HIM AROUND
THE LEAGUE.
HE HAS A LEGEND AROUND HIM AND
MAYBE EVEN BIGGER AS A PERSON
THAN AS A PROFESSIONAL.
A NEW PITCHER FOR THE TEXAS
RANGERS.
YOUR DENIALS, WHO WAS ORIGINALLY
TODAY'S STARTER, IS COMING IN
RELIEF.
JUST 1.3 INNINGS OF WORK AND THE
ATHLETICS GETTING RIGHT BACK TO
IT.
THEY DON'T CARE WHO IS COMING UP
ON THE MOUND RIGHT NOW.
IT IS ANOTHER HIT LEADOFF FOR
SEAN MURPHY.
>> SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE, THE
RANGERS WILL HAVE TO GET SOME
LENGTH OUT OF SOMEBODY.
HE IS EQUIPPED TO DO IT
PHYSICALLY.
SOMETIMES, YOU LIVE TO FIGHT
ANOTHER DAY.
LONG WAY FROM BEING OVER.
AT SOME POINT, SOMEONE HAS TO
PITCH THE INNINGS HERE.
MELANIE: WE HEARD THEY WERE
SENDING YOU DOWN TO SUIT UP.
BUCK: YOU KNOW, I PITCHED TWICE
IN THE MINOR LEAGUES.
WHEN EVERYBODY GOT HAMMERED, I
GOT A KNUCKLEBALL.
I WOULDN'T RELEASE IT AND START
MOVING BACK SO THEY COULD NOT
HIT ME.
CHECK OUT THE NUMBERS HAD I HAD
A COUPLE OUTINGS.
YONDER: GOT TO CHECK.
MELANIE: SEAN MANAEA IS MIKED UP
RIGHT NOW AND WE HEARD HOW
EXCITED JAMES WAS AS HE WAS
WATCHING HIS GUYS BE IT I WONDER
WHAT HE HAD TO SAY AS HE WAS
WATCHING EVERYTHING GOING ON.
>> GET OFF ME.
>> GO.
GO.
YOU GOT TO GET GONE.
YES.
MELANIE: OK, SO I HAVE TO SAY
SOMETHING HERE.
MANAEA WATCHES THE GAME IN THE
DUGOUT THE WAY I'M REALLY GLAD
THAT I'M IN THE THIRD BOOTH FOR
SIDELINES BECAUSE THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT I DO WITH PRETTY
MUCH ANY GAME I AM IN.
HOW DO YOU NOT GET EMOTIONAL?
>> HERE IS THE PROBLEM WITH SEAN
MANAEA.
WHAT WE JUST WITNESSED RIGHT
THERE IN THE DUGOUT, THAT IS
EXACTLY HOW HE IS IN THE
CLUBHOUSE.
THAT IS EXACTLY HOW HE IS IN THE
HOTEL OR ON THE BUS.
THIS IS A GUY WHO ENJOYS LIFE,
WHO ENJOYS THE GAME, AND WHO
JUST HAS A LOT OF FUN WITH BOYS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A BOYS CLUB
IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL, THIS
IS WHAT -- A GUY LIKE SEAN
MANAEA.
MELANIE: WE GOT TO TALK TO BOB
MELVIN BEFORE THE GAME AND HE
WAS LOOKING FOR SOMEONE TO BE A
VOICE IN THE DUGOUT AND HE SAID
THAT WAS ELVIS ANDRUS, BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE THE PIPES OF SEAN
MANAEA SITTING THERE, I MEAN,
I'M SURE THEY ARE HERE AND THAT
IN THE THIRD DECK RIGHT NOW.
>> IN OAKLAND, I WOULD HAVE A
THING WITH SEAN MANAEA.
LOOKING FOR THE FIRST PITCH.
HE WOULD JUST WAVE AT ME.
THIS IS WHO HE IS.
HE HAS A LOT OF FUN.
ANYTIME YOU SEE HIM WHEN HE IS
QUIET AND NOT SCREAMING OVER THE
TOP OF HIS LUNGS IS WHERE HE IS
STARTING FOR THE MOST PART.
HE IS LOOSE AND HE HAS A LOT OF
FUN.
MELANIE: JORDAN LYLES IS TRYING
TO COME ON IN RELIEF AND HAS NOT
FOUND THE ANSWER YET.
R.B.I. SINGLE FOR MARK CANHA AND
THE A'S ARE JUST POURING IT ON
RIGHT NOW.
TWO RUNS COME HOME ON THAT.
IT IS 9-0 OAKLAND IN THE THIRD
AND TACTLESS -- TEXAS IS TRYING
TO GO NORTH TO SOUTH RIGHT NOW.
>> RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
YOU WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES.
IN THE ZONE, ABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF IT, NOT TRYING TO DO TOO
MUCH.
THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT EXIT
VELOCITY AND LAUNCH ANGLE.
FOR HIM, IT'S ABOUT BEING A PURE
HITTER, HITTING THE LINE DRIVE
UP THE MIDDLE.
>> I GOT TO ASK YOU GUYS, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE HIM MIKED UP IN
THE DUGOUT, VERY LOUD.
WHAT WORD DID HE ACTUALLY SAY
OTHER THAN -- WHAT WAS THE WORD
THAT HE ACTUALLY SAID?
BOY, HE WAS REALLY EXCITED.
IMPRESSIVE.
THAT IS IMPRESSIVE HE
COMMUNICATED VERY WELL WITHOUT
SAYING A WHOLE LOT.
YONDER: EVERYONE KNEW EXACTLY
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN OAKLAND.
THE MORE SMALLER CLUBHOUSE.
YOU GET TO ENJOY THE LINGO OF
EACH PLAYER, GET TO ENJOY THE
CHARACTERS OF EACH PLAYER IN
THEIR LANGUAGE YOU GET TO ENJOY
AS WELL AND LEARN FROM WHEN YOU
ARE AROUND THESE GUYS 24/7.
MELANIE: ISIAH KINER-FALEFA FOR
THE RANGERS IS MIKED UP AND HIS
CONFIDENCE HAS BEEN BOOMING
LATELY BUT LET TAKE A LIVE LOOK
IN AT WHAT HE HAD BEEN FEELING,
PLAYING DEFENSE WITH THIS CLUB.
>> OH NO.
COME ON.
OH, MAN.
>> I THINK I WILL HAVE TO RETIRE
THE MIC.
7-0, SECOND INNING.
YEP.
AIN'T NO GOOD CONTENT HERE.
MELANIE: AT SHORTSTOP, HIS OWN
CONTENT CREATION MANAGER
P WATCHING A COUPLE HOME RUNS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE BEAUTY
OF BEING A CORNER POSITION
PLAYER, WHEN GAMES LIKE THIS ARE
HAPPENING, YOU START TALKING TO
THE FIRST BASE COACH, THE
UMPIRE, THE FANS, EVERYBODY THAT
YOU CAN, JUST TRYING TO PASS THE
INNING ALONG ON DEFENSE BECAUSE
MORE THAN NOT, YOU ARE WATCHING
BALLS FLY ALL OVER THE PLACE.
MELANIE: CAN THE FANS HEAR YOU
WHEN YOU ARE A MIDDLE INFIELDER?
YONDER: I THINK FOR THE MIDDLE
INFIELDER, IT IS HARDER.
FOR THE CORNER GUYS, YOU ARE
LOOKING AROUND, TRYING TO SEE
PEOPLE EATING HOT DOGS AND
POPCORN.
TALKING TO UMPIRES ABOUT
STORYTELLING AND IT CAN GET A
LITTLE CONFUSING OUT THERE WHEN
IT IS A SITUATION LIKE THAT.
MELANIE: JORDAN LYLES WORKING
HERE.
THE INTERESTING THING WAS THAT
THIS WAS NOT REALLY A SECRET
THAT HE WOULD PROBABLY PITCH
TODAY.
CHRIS WOODWARD SAID HE WAS ON
THE TABLE.
NOBODY IS OFF THE TABLE AS AS A
WHOLE IS TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO
BRIDGE THIS EXTRA 900 INNINGS
FROM LAST SEASON BUT MELVIN EVEN
SAID WE HAVE GOT A GAME PLAN AND
THAT IS WHY MY LINEUP IS THE WAY
IT IS.
PLAYING BACK FOR CHARLIE
CULBERSON.
TEXAS FINALLY FINDS THE SECOND
OUT.
WHAT A ROLE REVERSAL IT IS
TONIGHT AFTER THE RANGERS JUMPED
ON EARLY IN THE FIRST INNING OF
A FIVE-RUN FRAME, ATTACKING
FRANKIE.
CHRIS WOODWARD HAS HAD HIS WORK
CUT OUT FOR HIM WITH THE CLUB
REBUILDING AND YOU ARE SEEING A
COUPLE ACROSS THE LEAGUE IN
MILLER POSITIONS BUT HE SAID IT
IS TOUGH AND HE WANTS TO BE
TRANSPARENT NOT ONLY WITH HIS
FANS BUT FANS ACROSS THE SPORT.
YONDER: WHAT IS THE MINDSET WHEN
YOU ARE HAVING A GAME LIKE THIS,
WHEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION OF A
YEAR WHERE YOU ARE TRYING TO
REBUILD, TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS GOING ON, AND EVALUATE
AT THE SAME TIME?
YOU OBVIOUSLY WANT TO WIN EVERY
SINGLE GAME AND HAVE A CHANCE TO
WIN EVERY SINGLE GAME, BUT FROM
A MANAGER'S STANDPOINT, WHAT
GOES THROUGH THE HEAD OF CHRIS
WOODWARD?
BUCK: IN A GAME LIKE THIS, WE
ARE TRYING TO LIVE TO FIGHT
ANOTHER DAY, QUITE FRANKLY.
THIS GAME IS EARLY STILL, BUT
YOU ARE TRYING TO PUT YOURSELF
IN POSITION.
YOU WANT TO KEEP EVERYBODY
HEALTHY.
I GUARANTEE THEY ARE ALREADY
TALKING ABOUT HOWARD GOING TO
GET THROUGH THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU HAVE TO PITCH
ONLINE INNINGS AND YOU WANT TO
PUT YOURSELF IN A POSITION TO
WIN THE GAME TOMORROW AND THE
NEXT DAY WITHOUT HAVING TO MAKE
A LOT OF CHANGES IN YOUR ROSTER.
TRYING TO KEEP EVERYBODY
HEALTHY.
I GUARANTEE THEY ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT WHO MIGHT BE IN POSITION
PLAYER PITCHING IF THEY GET
THERE.
CHRIS WOODWARD IS A GOOD
MANAGER.
I AM VERY IMPRESSED WITH HIM.
HE IS VERY CONSISTENT AND
SOMETIMES, CLUBS ARE STRUGGLING.
EVERYBODY THINKS THIS GUY CANNOT
DO THIS, CANNOT DO THAT.
HE IS A GOOD MANAGER AND CAPABLE
OF LEADING THE CLUB TO GREAT
THINGS, HOW HE HANDLES HIMSELF
ON AND OFF THE FIELD.
I LOVE THE PATH HE HAS TAKEN TO
GET HERE.
WHETHER IT BE MINOR LEAGUE, AS A
COACH, HE HAS CHECKED THE BOXES.
VERY CONSISTENT AND UPBEAT, AN
D HE ALSO HAS A STERN SIDE TO
HIM.
I AM IMPRESSED WITH HIM.
MELANIE: ON THE POP UP HERE, THE
RANGERS TRYING TO TALK THIS ONE
AWAY, LITTLE MISCOMMUNICATION
THERE.
RANGERS FINALLY RETIRE THE TOP
WE WILL SEE THE BOTTOM HALF OF
THE RANGERS WHEN WE COME BACK
WITH WILLIE CALHOUN.
>> THIS IS A STORY OF BIG JOE,
WHO BECAME ONE OF THE BIGGEST,
BADDEST TEXAS RANGERS OF THEM
ALL.
JOE WAS BORN IN NEVADA UNDER THE
BRIGHT, SHIMMERING STAR.
I WAS A SIGN HE WAS DESTINED FOR
BIG THINGS.
TOUGH ENOUGH TO BEAR HUNT, HE
TURNED INTO A MOUNTAIN OF A MAN
CALLED BIGGIO.
-- BIG JOE.
ONE SUMMER EVENING, HE SPOTTED
THAT SAME LONE STAR CALLING HIM
EAST UNTIL HE MADE IT TO GOD'S
COUNTRY, TEXAS.
WAIT UNTIL YOU HEAR ABOUT HIS
BACK.
HE YANKS A LIVE OAK OUT OF THE
GROUND AND STARTED SWINGING.
WHEN HE MAKES CONTACT, IT SOUNDS
LIKE A TEXAS THUNDERSTORM.
FOLKS STILL TALK ABOUT THE GAME
THAT MADE HIM A LEGEND.
A CRAFTY OLD SO-AND-SO WHO IS
GOING TO REMAIN NAMELESS.
HE DELIVERED A HEATER NO MATTER
ON EARTH CAN -- BATTER ON EARTH
CAN HANDLE EXCEPT BIG JOE.
HE PUT SUCH A CHARGE ON THE
BALL, IT BOASTED CLEAN THROUGH
THE ATMOSPHERE.
WHERE DID IT LAND?
IF YOU LOOK REAL CLOSE, YOU
MIGHT FIND YOUR ANSWER ON THAT
SAME RIGHT SHIMMERING LONE STAR.
MELANIE: FANS, TAKE A LOOK AT
KYLE GIBSON.
YOU CAN WATCH EXCLUSIVE RANGERS
CONTENT, GO BEHIND THE SCENES,
AND LEARN MORE ABOUT YOUR
FAVORITE PLAYERS AT
YOUTUBE.COM/RANGERS.
SUBSCRIBE TO FOLLOW THEM.
KYLE GIBSON HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
STANDOUT FOR TEXAS THIS YEAR.
13 START THIS SEASON, A PERFECT
5-0 RECORD.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THAT RECORD,
AND HE HELD THE LINE YESTERDAY.
GIBSON HAVING TO TAKE IN A BIT
OF A TOUGHER MATCHUP THIS
EVENING AS THE ATHLETICS HAVE
FOUND A WAY TO GET INTO THIS
BULLPEN GAME.
STATE FARM IN GAME INTERVIEW AND
KYLE, FIRST OF ALL, REALLY
AWESOME TO SEE YOUR CAREER
CONTINUE TO CLIMB.
AT ONE POINT, YOU WERE DEALING
WITH CONSISTENT HAND, TRYING TO
FIND A WAY TO MANAGE THAT.
AND DOWN TO BARDA.
IS THAT STILL SOMETHING THAT IS
PART OF YOUR ROUTINE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT IS PART OF MY EVERYDAY
ROUTINE.
IT IS A GREAT THING FOR ME TO
USE TO ACTIVATE AND GET THE
SHOULDER LOOSE AND GOING.
IT IS A GREAT TOTAL BODY AND IT
GETS MY BRAIN FIRING AND GETS MY
HAND IN THE RIGHT POSITION,
READY TO THROW EVERY DAY.
>> HOW DO YOU LIKE THE BALLPARK
HERE?
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
PITCHING HERE?
KYLE: I DON'T KNOW.
I LOVE THE BALLPARK, FIRST OFF.
CHALLENGES PITCHING HERE?
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MANY.
FIRST 1.5 YEARS OR SO, IT WAS
SHOWN TO BE A PRETTY GOOD
PITCHER'S BALLPARK.
I DON'T HATE THAT, OBVIOUSLY.
IT IS SO AWESOME TO HAVE FANS IN
HERE.
YOU COULD TELL HOW EMPTY IT
FELT, WHICH MOST STADIUMS
PROBABLY DID, BUT SEEING HOW IT
LOOKED IN THE PLAYOFFS AND HOW
IT FEELS AND LOOKS THIS YEAR,
WITH FULL CAPACITY IN SOME
GAMES, AND REALLY HAVING 30,000
EVERY GAME, IT HAS BEEN A LOT OF
FUN TO PLAY IN FRONT OF FANS AND
IT GETS LOUD AND GREAT.
YONDER: YONDER ALONSO HERE.
I FACED YOU IN THE PAST AND I
REMEMBER FACING YOU AND I WOULD
ALWAYS TRY TO GET THE FASTBALL.
REALLY GOOD CHANGEUP.
AS OF LATE, I NOTICED THAT YOU
DEVELOPED THAT CUTTER AND I
THINK THAT CUTTER FOR THE
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS HAS BEEN
JUST A GREAT WEAPON FOR YOU AND
I WANT YOU TO TALK TO ME A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT HAS LED TO
THAT, RIGHT, FROM THE BEGINNINGS
OF MAYBE THREE OR FOUR YEARS
AGO, NOT THROWING THE CUTTER AS
MUCH.
HOW MUCH HAS THAT HELP YOU HAVE
SUCH A GOOD YEAR, NOT ONLY THIS
YEAR, BUT LATER ON IN THE YEAR
GOING FORWARD, HOW YOU CAN
UTILIZE THAT PITCH?
KYLE: YONDER, I MEAN, THE
LEFTIES -- MY FAILURES AGAINST
LEFTIES -- THAT WAS A GOOD
SWING.
MY FAILURES AGAINST LEFTIES, YOU
KNOW, THE LAST COUPLE YEARS,
JUST KIND OF LED ME TO FIND
SOMETHING ELSE I COULD USE
AGAINST THEM AND THAT IS REALLY
WHO I IMAGINE THE CUTTER BEING
MAY BE MOST EFFECTIVE AGAINST,
SOMETHING GOING INTO THEM.
THAT FOUR-SEAMER AT THE TOP OF
THE ZONE, YOU KNOW, IT'S WILL
RUNS A LITTLE BIT SO HAVING
SOMETHING TO GO INTO THEM, I
FELT IT WOULD REALLY MIX WELL
WITH THE FRONT HIP SINKER I
THROW AND MIX THAT IN.
JUST KIND OF PLAYING WITH IT A
LITTLE BIT AS WELL, I FEEL LIKE
IT PLAYS OFF OF MY SLIDER PRETTY
WELL AND THEN I DID NOT HAVE
GOOD COMMAND YESTERDAY BUT WHEN
I AM ABLE TO COMMAND NICE INCUR
AN CUTTER, GLOVE SIDE, IT ALLOWS
ME TO GET THE OUTSIDE CORNER A
LITTLE BIT AND IT HAS OPENED UP
A FEW THINGS FOR ME, BUT THE
CUTTER HAS BEEN SOMETHING I AM
STILL PLAYING WITH, TRYING TO
FIND THE RIGHT KIND OF MOVEMENT
AND COMMAND TO IT THAT IT HAS
BEEN A LOT OF FUN SO FAR.
BUCK: WHAT IS YOUR CRYSTAL BALL
ON WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL
IT?"
WHAT HAS CHRIS BEEN TELLING YOU
GUYS AND HOW DO YOU THINK IT'S
GOING TO AFFECT THE GAME?
KYLE: I MEAN, I THINK HOW IT IS
GOING TO AFFECT THE GAME IS TO
BE SEEN A LITTLE BIT.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
PITCHERS PROBABLY MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS RIGHT NOW AND
WHATEVER PEOPLE WANT TO SAY, IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE SEASON,
HOWEVER MLB WANTS TO DEAL WITH
IT, IT IS A RULE THAT HAS BEEN
ON THE BOOKS AND THEY DECIDED TO
GO AHEAD AND MAKE IT MORE
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT IT THIS
YEAR.
FOR ME, I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A
RAWSON AND SWEAT GUY.
NORMALLY HAVING TO WASH THAT OFF
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
YOU SAW TREVOR BAUER AND HIS
SWEAT AND RAWSON, HOW STICKY IT
IS FEARED I DO SWEAT A LOT SO I
HAVE TO USE ROSIN ON THAT RIGHT
ARM.
I WILL SEE HOW IT IMPACTS THE
GAME FOR PITCHERS AND HITTERS
BUT I THINK MLB IS LISTENING TO
WHAT THE POSITION PLAYERS ARE
SAYING AND SOME OF THE DATA THEY
PICKED UP AND SAID IT IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO LOOK AT AND
TRY TO GET IT UNDER WRAPS AND
SEE WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THAT.
MELANIE: KYLE, YOU JUST
MENTIONED WITH THE DISCUSSION,
AND WE WILL MAKE THIS ONE CLICK,
ARGUE IN FAVOR OF SEEING
COMMUNICATIONS OPENING UP AS YOU
MOVE OVER IT WITH THE LEAGUE?
KYLE: IF THE LEAD THINGS IT'S
SOMETHING -- LEAGUE THINKS IT IS
SOMETHING TO WORK ON, WE WILL
SEE HOW WE CAN MAKE IT BETTER
FOR PLAYERS AND TEAMS.
MELANIE: KYLE GIBSON, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE.
WE ARE GOING TO HEAD TO THE
FOURTH INNING AS THE RANGERS
TRAILED THE ATHLETICS 9-0, GAME,
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> AND THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
AND THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
OH MY!
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
[CHATTER]
MELANIE: ATHLETICS, A BIG 9-0
LEAD OVER THE RANGERS AND CHRIS
WOODWARD IS TRYING TO MANAGE
THIS BALLGAME AS ST CAN.
THIS IS ALREADY THE THIRD
PITCHER.
JORDAN LYLES WAS SCHEDULED TO
START TODAY.
HE GOT HIM TO.
THEY BROUGHT IN AN OPENER MORE
OR LESS.
THE RANGERS HAVE DEPLOYED AN
OPENER OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS.
HAVE GOTTEN AWAY FROM IT IN WENT
TO 21 BUT WE ARE HOPING IT WILL
BRIDGE A LITTLE BIT OF A GAP.
CHAD PINDER LOOKING FOR HIS
FIRST HIT OF THE DAY AND HE WILL
NOT FIND IT HERE.
JUST BARELY GET BEAT OUT.
WE ASKED FANS EARLIER.
TRIPLE PLAY OR A WALKOFF SLAM?
IT IS NOT EVEN CLOSE.
GOING FOR THE GRAND SALAMI.
75% OF YOU ALMOST AGREED WITH
THAT.
YONDER WILL AGREE WITH YOU.
BUCK, WE KNOW YOU SAID IT TAKES
A LITTLE LESS STRESS WHEN THAT
IS HOW IT ENDS FOR A MANAGER SO
CAN WE PUT YOU IN THE GRAND SLAM
COLUMN AS WELL?
BUCK: I THINK SO.
I WILL GO ALONG WITH IT.
[LAUGHTER]
YONDER: I JUST LOVE THAT.
I LOVE THAT ANSWER.
BUCK, CAN YOU TALK TO ME ABOUT
CHRIS'S CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW FOR
THE REMAINDER OF THIS GAME?
FOR BEING A MANAGER, THIS COULD
BE A VERY HARD-FOUGHT AND A
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT CAN LEAD
FOR DECISIONS FOR THE UPCOMING
DAYS, CORRECT?
BUCK: YUP, THIS IS WHERE YOU
EARN YOUR KEEP.
YOU DON'T GIVE IN.
THE DECISIONS YOU MAKE HERE GET
YOUR CLUB THROUGH THIS GAME.
KNOWING WHEN TO GET CERTAIN GUYS
OFF THE FIELD POTENTIALLY DOWN
THE ROAD FROM MAPPING OUT YOUR
PITCHING, WHERE YOU CAN LIVE TO
FIGHT ANOTHER DAY, AND YOU KNOW,
BELIEVE ME, THE ODDS ARE ON HIM.
THIS IS WHERE YOU WILL EARN YOUR
CACHET WITH SOME OF YOUR
PLAYERS, WHERE YOU DON'T BECOME
SOMEBODY COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
JUST BECAUSE YOUR TEAM IS
STRUGGLING THAT DAY.
IT'S VERY EASY TO BE ALL FRONT
AND CENTER WHEN THINGS ARE GOING
YOUR WAY BUT YOU REALLY EARN
YOUR KEEP AND SHOW YOUR TRUE
COLORS IN A GAME LIKE THIS.
CHRIS WILL HANDLE HIMSELF WELL
AREA IT IS A CHALLENGE TO MAN
THESE GAMES AND IT IS A CHANCE
TO SEPARATE YOURSELF TO SHOW WHY
YOU ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
YONDER: I ALWAYS FELT LIKE WHEN
I WAS A PLAYER AND THERE WAS A
GAME LIKE THIS, BEING THE TEAM
THAT WAS GETTING BEAT, I ALWAYS
WATCHED THE MANAGERS DECISION ON
WHO HE WAS TAKING CARE OF AND
WHO HE WAS TAKING OUT OF THE
GAME.
I ALWAYS GOT MY RESPECT WITH
MANAGERS WHEN THEY WOULD TAKE
GUYS THAT WERE BANGED UP,
SPENDING LOTS OF TIME IN THE
TRAINING ROOM, PLAYING, I ALWAYS
FELT LIKE WHEN A GUY AND A
MANAGER WOULD TAKE THAT CERTAIN
PLAYER OFF, ESPECIALLY IN AN
EARLIER PART OF THE GAME,
SEVENTH INNING OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, I ALWAYS HAD A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR THAT AND I FELT LIKE
HE WAS TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF
HIS GUY, GIVE HIM A BREATHER,
AND HAVE HIM FOR THE LONG HAUL
RATHER THAN THE INJURED LIST.
BUCK: IF EVERYBODY WAS HEALTHY,
THEY HAD SERVICE TIME.
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THE SERVICES ARE?
GUY'S EARNED THAT RESPECT.
MELANIE: FIRST PITCH SWINGING.
SEAN MURPHY BACK IN FRONT OF THE
TRACK.
THEY KEEP THIS ONE IN THE PARK.
GARCIA COMES UP WITH IT.
IT IS A INNING FOR THE
FIRST TIME FOR THE ATHLETICS BUT
THEY HAVE A BIG 9-0 LEAD WITH
THE BOTTOM OF THE FRAME AFTER
THIS.
>> THIS IS MATT OLSON.
>> IT HAS GIVEN ME PERSPECTIVE I
THINK IS THE BIGGEST THING.
>> THIS IS REESE BLANKENSHIP,
ONE OF OLSON'S BEST FRIENDS.
>> NICE.
>> HE HAS NONVERBAL AUTISM AND
USES A KEYBOARD TO COMMUNICATE.
>> REESE IS INCREDIBLY
INTELLIGENT, ARTICULATE.
YOU SEE THE WORDS THAT HE SAYS,
HE'S LIKE SHAKESPEARE A LITTLE
BIT.
>> THEY MET WHEN THEY WERE
TEENAGERS AND BECAME FAST
FRIENDS.
MORE THAN A DECADE LATER, OLSON
IS A TWO-TIME GOLD GLOVE WINNING
SLUGGER, AND BLANKENSHIP?
HE IS THE FOUNDER AND IDEA MAN
BEHIND AN ATLANTA FACILITY
DESIGNED TO EMPOWER PEOPLE WITH
AUTISM AND THEIR FAMILIES.
>> REESE'S MAIN IDEA BEHIND THIS
WAS TO JUST WORK WITH PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT ONLY AN AUTISM THING
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO ACCEPT
PEOPLE NO MATTER WHAT THE
SOCIETY, THE COMMUNITY, AND THAT
IS THE MESSAGE THAT REESE WANTS
TO GET OUT.
MELANIE: A'S UP WITH A 9-0
LEAD.
ISIAH KINER-FALEFA IS AT THE TOP
OF THAT LIST.
15 STOLEN BASES.
LOOK OUT WHEN HE REACHES --
ADOLIS GARCIA GETTING ALL OF THE
ALL-STAR LOVE FOR THE RANGERS
YOU CANNOT OVERLOOK MATT OLSON.
SOMEHOW, PEOPLE ARE STILL DOING
IT.
.997 O.P.S., AND AGAIN, THE 20
GAME ON-BASE STREAK HE EXTENDED
TODAY, AND THAT LEADS US TO THE
NEXT U2 FAN POLE.
WHICH OF THESE A.L. PLAYERS HAS
HAD THE MOST SURPRISING START?
IS IT MATT OLSON, GARCIA, OR
MARCUS SEMIEN?
GO AHEAD AND SEND IN YOUR PICKS.
WHO GETS TO BE THE QUICK ONE
TODAY?
YONDER: MARCUS SEMIEN.
MELANIE: YOU WOULD NOT BE BIASED
TOWARDS THAT AT ALL.
YONDER: OAKLAND A'S, MAN.
WHAT ELSE AM I GOING TO SAY?
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE: COLE IRVIN HAS BEEN
DEALING, ALLOWED JUST TWO HITS
THROUGH THE BALLGAME SO FAR AND
A DOUBLE PLAY HAS REALLY KEPT
HIM IN ONE FRAME HE DID NOT SEE
THE BARE MINIMUM.
HE COMES HOME TO ELI WHITE AND
ROLLS UP A SINGLE BUT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND SEND IT DOWN TO BRETT
DOLAN BECAUSE ADOLIS GARCIA IS A
GUY YOU CAN EXPECT AT SOME POINT
TONIGHT, HE WILL BE LINING UP AT
THE PLATE.
BRETT: HE MIGHT BE THE BEST
STORY IN BASEBALL.
HE SPENT FIVE YEARS PLAYING IN
CUBA.
HE WAS GOING TO COME BACK BUT HE
DID NOT MAKE IT AND ENDED UP
GOING TO THE ST. LOUIS CARDINALS
ORGANIZATION AFTER THREE YEARS
ONCE DESIGNATED.
THEY DESIGNATED HIM THIS PAST
FEBRUARY.
CHRIS WOODWARD SAID IT WAS
RISKY.
ALL THEY DID WAS PUT UP 16 HOME
RUNS IN THE FIRST 41 GAMES.
HE MET HIS HERO THE OTHER NIGHT
AT THE BALLPARK.
HE JOKED THAT WHEN HE CAME
UP FOR THE FIRST TIME, HE WAS
HITTING BALLS IN THE GAP, BUT
THE OTHER WAS HITTING BALLS OVER
THE FENCE.
WHAT I WAS INTRIGUED WITH, WOODY
SAID ADOLIS HAS AN ELITE
MINDSET HERE IS SO YOUNG TO THE
MAJOR LEAGUES.
IT INTRIGUES ME, AS DOES HIS
ALREADY.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT AN ELITE
MINDSET, IT STARTS WHERE YOU ARE
FROM.
A GUY WHO HAS HAD A VERY TOUGH
LIVING COMING FROM CUBA.
I KNOW THAT MYSELF, BEING A
CUBAN AS WELL, IT IS A LONG ROAD
AHEAD.
FOR HIM, YOU BUILD THAT MINDSET
WHEN YOU ARE NINE OR 10 YEARS
OLD, TRYING TO HAVE FOOD ON THE
TABLE EVERY SINGLE NIGHT AND I
THINK THAT FOR ITSELF BECOMES --
IT MAKES YOU A STRONGER PERSON,
A MENTALLY STRONGER PERSON.
FOR HIM RIGHT NOW, PLAYING WITH
HOUSE MONEY, AND IT IS A
SITUATION WHERE YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU ARE IN THE BIG STAGE OF
TRYING TO DO WELL AND PLAY FOR
YOUR TEAM AND PUT UP NUMBERS,
BUT THERE IS NOTHING HARDER THAN
TRYING TO HAVE FOOD ON YOUR
TABLE EVERY SINGLE NIGHT WHERE
YOU ARE FROM IN CUBA AND FOR
HIM, WE HAVE ALL ENJOYED -- AS A
CUBAN GUY MYSELF, WE ALL ENJOYED
THE SUCCESS HE HAS HAD AND WE
WISH NOTHING BUT HEALTH AND
CONTINUED SUCCESS THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER.
MELANIE: IT REALLY SAYS
SOMETHING AND YOU DROVE IT HOME
PERFECTLY.
WHEN YOU ARE FIGHTING PRETTY
MUCH FOR YOUR OWN LIFE IN THAT
SITUATION, IT TAKES THE GAZE OF
THE THIRD DECK OF THE BIG-LEAGUE
STADIUM AWAY AND YOU TEND TO SEE
THAT.
THE GUYS WHO HAVE HAD PATHS
THAT WERE NOT EASY, THOSE ARE
THE ONES WHO KNOW HOW TO GRIND
BUT WHO CAN ALSO HANDLE WHEN
LIFE GETS A LITTLE BIGGER THAN
WHAT THEY HAD FORESEEN FOR
THEMSELVES.
YONDER: FOR EVERY BIG LEAGUER
THAT GETS TO THIS BIG STAGE,
THERE IS A STORY TO BE SAID AND
A STORY WE NEED TO ALL TALK
ABOUT WHEN IT COMES TO A BIG
LEAGUER BECAUSE YOU ARE 1%.
BUT THEN THERE ARE OTHER STORIES
THAT YOU MUST TALK ABOUT LIKE A
GUY LIKE GARCIA WHERE YOU JUST
DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE GOING TO
SURVIVE THE NEXT DAY.
YOU LEAVE YOUR COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW -- YOU DON'T KNOW IF
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE YOUR
PARENTS, SISTERS, BROTHERS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT TOMORROW
HOLDS.
FOR A GUY LIKE THAT, YOU HAVE
ALL THE RESPECT IN THE WORLD
BECAUSE HE IS JUST HAPPY TO BE
ALIVE, HAPPY TO HAVE AC IN HIS
HOUSE.
FOR HIM, THAT IS A DREAM COME
TRUE, NOT ONLY FOR HIM, BUT FOR
ALL OF HIS CUBAN FAMILY AND
EVERYBODY WATCHING BACK HOME IN
CUBA.
MELANIE: I THINK YOU SAID IT
PERFECTLY.
THAT IS THE THING.
YOU EVEN SAID IT.
YOU ARE ONE OF VERY FEW PEOPLE
AND YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND -- NOBODY FULLY
UNDERSTANDS EVERYBODY ELSE'S
JOURNEY, BUT JUST TO HAVE THAT,
AND SO FEW PEOPLE CAN SAY THAT
WITH SUCCESS -- IT IS A BIG
SACRIFICE THAT I THINK IS
FINALLY STARTING TO COME TO
LIGHT, ESPECIALLY HERE IN THE
STATES, WITH WHAT IT TAKES FOR
DEFECTORS TO MAKE IT IN THE GAME
AND TO BE AROUND.
YONDER: IT IS VERY DIFFICULT.
I PLAYED WITH MANY CUBANS
BEFORE.
ONE OF THE GUYS THAT STANDS TO
ME IS JOSE ABREU AND JOSE ABREU,
YOU HAVE A BAD GAME, YOU HAVE A
GOOD GAME, HE WAS HAPPY.
ONE TIME, I TALKED TO HIM ON THE
PLANE AND HE SAID WE ARE HAPPY
TO PLAY A KIDS GAME, HAPPY TO BE
HERE, HAPPY TO ENJOY THIS WORK
THAT WE DO, WHICH IS A KIDS
GAME, AND WE ARE REALLY LUCKY.
MELANIE: ELVIS ANDRUS KEEPING IT
A KIDS GAME FOR THE A'S.
THEY HAVE A 9-0 LEAD AFTER FOUR
INNINGS.
HE IS BACK AT THE PLATE, WHEN WE
COME BACK.
>> I WAS SELECTED FOR THE
ALL-STAR GAME.
>> AFTER OUR LAST BALLGAME
BEFORE THE ALL-STAR BREAK, I
SAID TO REGGIE, WHATEVER YOU DO,
DO NOT EMBARRASS US AND STRIKE
OUT.
>> I WENT TO PINCH-HIT AND I
LOOKED AROUND AND I SAID, MAN,
THEY NEED TO SAVE ME FOR THE
EIGHTH AND THE NINTH.
GET ME OUT OF THE WAY EARLY.
>> THE HIGH FAST ONE AND FOULS
IT BACK.
TWO STRIKES.
>> NO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES, AND
I GOT OUT OF THE BATTER'S BOX
AND HE WAS IN MY EAR.
I SAID, MAN, LET ME NOT STRIKE.
>> NOT ONE IS GONE.
IT IS OFF THE ROOF.
THAT HIT THE TRANSFORMER UP
THERE.
>> HIT THE BALL INTO THE LIGHT
TOWER, INTO THE TRANSFORMER.
ONE OF THE LONGEST HOME RUNS
EVER HIT.
>> THAT BALL WENT OUT OF
YELLOWSTONE PARK.
HE HIT THAT TRANSFORMER IN RIGHT
FIELD.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN A BALL HIT
LIKE THAT BEFORE.
>> HE THROWS THE BAT DOWN AND
ADMIRES IT.
THE TAPE MEASURE DROPPED.
>> EVERYONE HAS GOT THAT JERSEY
ON TODAY.
THEY ARE GIVING THEM OUT.
>> THAT IS WHAT I SAID.
I ALREADY SAID IT.
>> GET HIM A FREE ONE.
THAT IS AWESOME.
THAT IS SO SICK.
MELANIE: ISIAH KINER-FALEFA, MIC
CED UP AND TALKING ABOUT ELVIS
ANDRUS.
HE WAS A SHORTSTOP FOR THE
RANGERS BEFORE BEING DEALT TO
OAKLAND.
THIS IS HIS FIRST TIME IN FRONT
OF FANS.
THEY HAD A BOBBLE FOR HIM LAST
NIGHT AND THEY HAVE THE ELVIS
ANDRUS JERSEY FOR HIM AT THE
PARK AND WHAT A SPECIAL DAY IT
HAS BEEN FOR HIM AS HE TAKES A
HACK HERE.
JORDAN LYLES CONTINUING TO WORK
FOR THE RANGERS BUT HE EVEN SAID
IT.
KYLE GIBSON TOOK A MOMENT, HE
STEPPED AWAY AND ALLOWED THE
FANS TO COME TO THEIR FEET,
GIVING THEM AN OVATION AT HOME
PLATE, AND HE SAID THE EMOTION
TOOK HIM BACK.
HE KNEW IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
COULD HAVE GIVEN HIM THE
COUNTDOWN AND IT WOULD NOT HAVE
MADE HIM READY FOR THAT MOMENT
IN PARTICULAR.
ISIAH KINER-FALEFA WITH LITTLE
BIT OF AN EDGE BECAUSE WHEN
THESE TWO WERE BOTH IN THE
RANGERS A SYSTEM TOGETHER,
KINER-FALEFA HAD NOT PLAYED
SHORT UP YET.
HE MOVED AROUND A COUPLE TIMES
BASED ON WHERE TEXAS NEEDED HIM
AND HE CAME OUT IN THAT BUDDING
CONFIDENCE AND SAID, I AM THE
BEST SHORTSTOP YOU HAVE ON THE
ROSTER.
THAT IS IT.
THEY ENDED UP HAVING HIM COME IN
AND HE WAS THE PREDECESSOR TO
ELVIS ANDRUS.
ELVIS ANDRUS SWINGS.
HE GETS IT DOWN.
3-3 DAY.
ELVIS ANDRUS, THE LEADOFF
SINGLE.
MAN, HAS HE LEFT THE BUILDING
FOR THE RANGERS HERE.
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS 12 SEASONS
PLAYING FOR TEXAS.
AGAIN CAME OVER WITH THE BRAVES.
TWO TIME ALL-STAR SELECTION,
RUNNER-UP ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
FIRST IN STEALS, SECOND IN TOTAL
GAMES MADE, AND THOSE ARE GOING
TO BE TOUGH NUMBERS TO CHASE.
893 RUNS.
>> YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW GOOD
ELVIS ANDRUS IS?
HE GOT SPREAD LAST NIGHT FOR
BOTH TEAMS TO THANK HIM FOR THE
NIGHT HE HAD.
MELANIE: THAT SOUNDS PRETTY ON
PAR WITH ELVIS ANDRUS.
YONDER: THAT IS WHO HE IS AS A
PERSON, AS A TEAMMATE.
WE HEARD BOB MELVIN TALK ABOUT
HIM EARLIER TODAY AND HE WAS
JUST RAVING ABOUT ELVIS ANDRUS
AND JUST, THE CHATTER THAT YOU
HEAR FROM HIM ON AN EVERYDAY
BASIS, THE WAY HE GOES ABOUT HIS
BUSINESS, I REMEMBER PLAYING
FIRST BASE AND COMING TO TEXAS
AND I CAN ALWAYS HEAR SOMEBODY
JUST SCREAMING IN THAT DUGOUT.
NEVER KNEW WHO HE WAS.
HERE WE ARE, ELVIS ANDRUS.
BOB MELVIN TOLD US HE IS THE GUY
THAT CHIRPS ALL DAY LONG.
MELANIE: WE HEARD MANAEA WITH
HIS OPERA-ESQUE VOCALS.
HE WANTED SOMEBODY WHO WOULD BE
CONSISTENTLY VOCAL AND HE KNEW
THE MINUTE THEY WERE IN SPRING
TRAINING, HE HAD HIS AFTER THE
DUGOUT BUT HE COULD HEAR THEM
JAWING ALREADY.
HAVE ELVIS IN OUR DUGOUT.
REHAB IN THE MINOR LEAGUES -- HE
REHABBED IN THE MINOR LEAGUE.
YOU GET TO THIS POINT AND IT IS
OUR JOB TO SERVICE THEM.
WE GIVE THEIR VOICE A PLATFORM
HERE YOU DON'T EXPECT THEM TO
REMEMBER YOU.
IT'S NOT THEIR JOB TO REMEMBER
US.
HE CAME UP AND NOT ONLY DID HE
TAKE THE TIME TO EXPLAIN THE
REHAB AND WHAT HE WAS GOING
THROUGH, BUT SET I TOOK SOME
TIME TO READ ABOUT YOU AS WELL
AND WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN DOING IS
REALLY COOL.
IT LEFT ME WITHOUT WORDS TO EVEN
SAY BACK TO HIM THE FIRST MOMENT
OF HAVING THAT RECOGNITION OF
SOMEBODY BEING ON THE SAME LEVEL
AS THEM, AND THE TIME HE TAKES
IS FANTASTIC AND IT IS TOP TO
BOTTOM.
YONDER: THERE WAS A POINT THERE
THAT YOU WOULD COME INTO PLAY
THE RANGERS AND IT WAS ADRIAN
BELTRE AND ELVIS ANDRUS.
THEY WERE THE FACE OF THAT
FRANCHISE FOR A WILD.
I KNOW THAT AT TIMES, ELVIS GOT
A LITTLE BIT OF CRITICISM,
WHETHER IT WAS HIS DEFENSE OR
HITTING.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS GUY IN THE
CLUBHOUSE, TALK TO OTHER PLAYERS
ABOUT ELVIS ANDRUS, HE IS A
COMPLETE PACKAGE, A LEADER, AND
A WINNER.
MELANIE: THE WINNING TEAM RIGHT
NOW.
9-0, OAKLAND.
STILL TRYING TO GROW INTO HIS
WORK ISSUES.
HE TAKES A SWING.
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE LINEUP.
NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK,
FOR THE 22 AND ONE SEASON, THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME --
2021 SEASON, THE YOUTUBE PLAYER
OF THE GAME.
YOU CAN VOTE FOR WHICH PLAYER
WILL RECEIVE THE TROPHY DURING
THE POSTGAME SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR LATER ON IN THE
SHOW.
SHOHEI OHTANI, HE MAY BE GETTING
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE YEAR
WITH THE WAY THAT HE IS FORMING
SO FAR.
SINGLE, TRIPLE, WALK TWO R.B.I.
FOR MARK CANHA.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO ADD HIM TO
YOUR BALLOT FOR TODAY'S GAME.
GETS THE INSIDE CALL ON A
STRIKE, WORKING AHEAD.
>> DO YOU THINK THE STRIKE ZONE
IS GOING TO CHANGE A LITTLE BIT
GOING ON AFTER THIS FIFTH
INNING?
BUCK: YOU ARE SAYING THAT
BECAUSE THAT WAS A BALL.
ONE OF THE GOOD THINGS ABOUT THE
STRIKE ZONE EVALUATION OF THE
UMPIRE IS THAT THEY CANNOT OPEN
IT UP IN THIS SITUATION.
YONDER: I ALWAYS FELT LIKE THE
VETERAN UMPIRES, WHICH WE SEE
ONE HERE TODAY WITH ANDY
FLETCHER BEHIND HOME PLATE, OPEN
UP THE STRIKE ZONE WHEN THE GAME
WAS OUT OF REACH LIKE THIS AND I
THINK AS A PLAYER, YOU WERE OK
WITH THAT.
YOU WERE OK WITH OPENING UP A
LITTLE BIT AND GETTING THE
RHYTHM OF A GAME FLOW GOING A
LITTLE BIT FASTER THAN WHAT YOU
WOULD MORE LIKELY SEE ON AN
EVERY NIGHT BASIS.
BUCK: I AM FROM THE SCHOOL OF
BALTIMORE AND STRIKE TO STRIKE.
JUST BECAUSE YOUR TEAM IS NOT
VERY GOOD TONIGHT DOESN'T MEAN
WE GIVE YOU SOMETHING SPECIAL.
PLAY BETTER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THAT.
I THINK THAT'S KIND OF BECAUSE
OF THE EVALUATIONS THEY ARE
DOING ON STRIKE ZONE'S EVERY
NIGHT, THE UMPIRES REALLY CANNOT
BRING THEIR PERSONAL FEELINGS
INTO HOW A GAME SHOULD OR SHOULD
NOT BE CALLED BECAUSE OF THE
SCORE OF THE GAME.
THEY ARE HERE TO CALL BALLS AND
STRIKES AND I LIKE IT.
I THINK IT IS BETTER FOR
STATISTICS.
IF YOU PITCH WITH A BIGGER
STRIKE ZONE, AND A CERTAIN PART
OF THE GAME, YOUR STATISTICS AND
PAYCHECK MIGHT BE DIFFERENT.
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT IS WHAT
UMPIRES ARE THERE FOR.
I THINK THEY ARE THERE TO CALL
BALLS BALLS, STRIKES STRIKES,
AND THE BASES AS ACCURATELY AS
THEY CAN.
MELANIE: 0-1 IN TO MATT CHAPMAN,
AND MAN, IS HE HAVING A GAME
HIMSELF.
TAKE A LOOK AT STATCAST, POWERED
BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
THAT FIRST INNING, AND WHAT A
WAY TO OPEN IT UP HERE AT 422
FOOT LONG BALL OUT TO CENTER
FIELD.
ADOLIS GARCIA IS TRYING TO GO
AFTER BOTH THAT BULLPEN HAS HIT
TODAY.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH VERTICAL TO
TRACK DOWN EITHER.
BUCK: I WAS LOOKING AT THAT
PITCH HE HIT OUT.
THAT IS A BALL.
IT IS A STRIKE COVERING THE
PLATE BUT IT IS A BALL LOW.
THE EXTENSION ON THE ARMS,
PEOPLE SAY HE HAS TO HIT
STRIKES.
THAT WAS A BALL.
SOMETIMES, YOU GOT TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT THAT.
MELANIE: IT IS A COMEBACK INNING
FOR JORDAN LYLES.
NICK SOLAK DUE UP WHEN WE COME
BACK HERE THEY TRAIL 9 -- BACK.
THEY TRAIL 9-0.
>> WE GO TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
SECOND.
NO SCORE.
MARINERS AND THE BRAVES.
THAT ONE IS CRUSHED TO RIGHT.
WAY BACK IN THAT ONE OFF THE
POLE.
A HOME RUN.
TOWERING HOME RUN DOWN THE
RIGHT-FIELD LINE, NUMBER 11, HAS
GIVEN THE BRAVES A 1-0 LEAD.
THAT BALL IS DRILLED RIGHT
FIELD.
THIS ONE IS WELL HIT.
SUZUKI BACK, AND IT IS GONE.
HIS SECOND HOMER OF THE DAY.
THE BRAVES LEAD IT 2-0.
TEXAS FEELING GOOD.
MARK TEIXEIRA RIPPED TOWARDS THE
CORNER.
GONE.
AND THE BRAVES LEAD IT 8-0.
HAVE A DAY, MARK TEIXEIRA.
BUCK: HE CUTS EVERYTHING OFF
OVER THERE AND THE SHORTSTOP CAN
PLAY FURTHER OVER.
IT MIGHT BE INTERESTING FOR
FANS.
HE PLAYS DEEPER.
MELANIE: EACH WEEK THIS SEASON
ON OUR BROADCAST -- FEATURED IN
OUR LIVE GAME COMMENTARY SECTION
TODAY, OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT
SHINES ON SCOTT MORGAN.
YOU CAN WATCH LIVE STREAMS OF
GAMEPLAY AND OPENINGS.
TAKE A LOOK AT EVERYTHING HE HAS
HAD GOING ON.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO JUDGE HIM ON
THIS ONE.
FAVORITE MOMENT, THAT 2020 NLCS
GAME SEVEN.
HOW DOES ANYBODY FORGET WHAT
BELLINGER WAS ABLE TO DO AND
REALLY INTERESTING, I THINK YOU
GOT TO TALK TO BELLINGER'S DAD
RECENTLY, DIDN'T YOU?
YONDER: WE TALKED ABOUT HOW HE
WAS FEELING, THE HEALTH OF
DODGER.
WOULD HE BE ABLE TO THROW TO
BELLINGER IF HE HAD A CHANCE TO
BE IN THE HOME RUN DERBY?
YESTERDAY, MY DAD THROWING
BATTING PRACTICE TO ME AND JUST
REALIZING HOW MUCH FUN IT WAS
AND AS YOU GET OLDER, HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY BE IN THE BIG
LEAGUES, AND THE ALL-STAR GAME,
AND HAVE YOUR DAD BE PART OF IT,
THROWING BATTING PRACTICE YOU IN
THE HOME RUN DERBY.
MELANIE: IT IS THAT LAID-BACK --
THERE IS NOTHING ON THE TABLE.
SOMETHING ON THE TABLE EVERY
OTHER TIME YOU ARE USUALLY IN
THAT SITUATION.
SIT BACK AND SEE WHAT YOU CAN
DO.
SHOHEI OHTANI HAS ANNOUNCED
QUITE DRAMATICALLY THAT HE IS
GOING TO BE IN IT.
SOLAK GETS PLUNKED.
ERVIN COMES INSIDE.
A LITTLE BIT OF A MESS.
STARTS THE INNING FOR THE
RANGERS.
RAFAEL DEVERS SAID HE IS NOT
GOING TO BE PARTICIPATING IN
REPRESENTING THE BOSTON RED SOX.
AARON JUDGE SAY HE IS NOT GOING
TO BE PLAYING UNTIL IT IS BACK
AT HOME WITH NEW YORK.
CURIOUS TO SEE WHO DOES OPT IN
HERE.
SOLAK AND BUCK, YOU MIGHT HAVE A
THING AGAIN SOME OF THE GUYS BUT
FOR NICK SOLAK TAKING ONE OFF
THE ELBOW, I'M PRETTY SURE HE
FELT THAT ONE EVEN WITH THE
GUARD OUT IN FRONT.
BUCK: THE ONLY THING IS THAT'S
PART OF THEIR IDEA AND THEIR
ADVANTAGE, THE BASEBALL.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT HELPED A
WHOLE LOT.
HOW DOES THAT FEEL?
YONDER: YOU KNOW WHAT?
DURING THAT TIME, ALL YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT IS THAT IT HURTS
FOR EIGHT SECONDS, 10 SECONDS,
AND THEN YOU ARE KIND OF OVER
IT, BUT MAN, I HAVE BEEN HIT IN
SOME SPOTS THAT HURT FOR WAY
LONGER THAN THAT, IT HURT FOR
WEEKS, AND YOU KNOW, IT IS NEVER
FUN TO GET HIT BY A PITCH AND
YOU JUST HOPE THAT THERE WAS
TIMES WHERE YOU GET HIT BY A
PITCH IN CERTAIN AREAS AND YOU
WERE KIND OF OK WITH IT,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAD TO
STRIKES, BUT AT TIMES, WHEN YOU
WOULD GET HIT, YOU JUST FELT
TERRIBLE.
YOU JUST FELT AWFUL.
THE AMOUNT OF PAIN YOU WERE
GOING THROUGH, AND NEXT THING
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE CHECKING FOR
YOURSELF, REALIZING, AM I GOING
TO BE ABLE TO FINISH THIS GAME
OFF?
BUCK: I TELL PEOPLE A LOT OF
TIMES, YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT IT
FEELS LIKE TO HIT A BALL OFF
YOUR SHIN?
TAKE A SLEDGEHAMMER AND HIT YOUR
SHIN AND THEN TRY TO GO TO FIRST
BASE.
YONDER: JUST IMAGINE THE FUNNY
BONE YOUR ELBOW WHEN YOU GET HIT
TIMES 10 WHEREVER THAT SPOT IS
WHERE YOU GET HIT.
MELANIE: IT IS A RIP FOR WILLIE
CALHOUN AND THE RANGERS MAY
FINALLY BE GETTING ON THE BOARD
HERE.
COMING AROUND TO SCORE AND LOOK
AT THIS.
TEXAS WITH AN ANSWER.
NICK SOLAK REACHED ON THE HIT BY
PITCH.
WILLIE CALHOUN FROM THE LEFT
SIDE WITH AN R.B.I. DOUBLE.
THEY BREAK ON THE BOARD.
IT IS A 9-1 BALLGAME IN THE
FIFTH INNING.
THE FIRST THAT COLE IRVIN HAS
GIVEN UP TODAY.
BUCK: GREAT PIECE OF HITTING,
BLOCK IT OVER TO LEFT FIELD.
THEY GOT SOME INTERESTING
DIMENSIONS OVER HERE.
YOU SEE HOW THE PADDING IS ON
THE INSIDE?
SURPRISED THAT THE NETTING IS
NOT ON THE RELEASE.
THEY GOT A DIFFERENT ISSUE DOWN
THE RIGHT-FIELD LINE, BUT IT'S
JUST A DIFFERENT NUANCE.
YOU NEED TO TELL YOUR FIELDERS,
THE SHORTSTOP AND SECOND BASEMAN
HAVE TO GO AFTER THOSE BALLS
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT GO DOWN LIKE
BALLS NORMALLY DO.
THEY HIT AND STICK IS A LOT OF
TIMES, THE PADDING IS ON THE
FIELD SIDE.
YONDER: WE TALK ABOUT SHIFT
NOWADAYS AND I GUARANTEE YOU
THAT RUNNER DOES NOT SCORE IF
THERE IS NOT A SHIFT.
SIDE ELVIS ANDRUS ON TOP OF THE
BALL BUT HE PROBABLY WAS SHIFTED
AND YOU KNOW, I WANTED TO ASK
YOU ABOUT THE SHIFT AND WITH
REGARDS TO A BALL LIKE THAT
WHERE A HITTER IS BLOCKING THE
PITCH AND THERE IS A HUGE HOLE
RIGHT THERE, WHAT DO YOU GOT ON
THAT ON A GAME 9-0?
DO YOU CONSIDER IT TO CONTINUE
SHIFTING?
BUCK: WHAT YOU LOOK FOR WHEN YOU
SHIFT A GUY IS IF THEIR BAT
ANGLE DOES NOT CHANGE.
IF A GUY THAT ANGLE NEVER
CHANGES WHEN THE BARREL ENTERS,
THAT IS A GUY YOU CONTINUE TO
SHIFT ON, GUYS WHO MAY CHANGE
THE BAT ANGLE.
SEE HOW THIS BALL STICKS BECAUSE
THE PADDING IS ON THE OUTSIDE.
NORMALLY, THE PADDING IS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE NETTING.
IF YOU DID THAT, IT WOULD HAVE
RELEASED INTO LEFT FIELD.
IF YOU CHECK THE BAT ANGLE WITH
TWO STRIKE, THOSE ARE THE GUYS
YOU GOT TO THINK ABOUT DRAINING
UP ON.
THERE IS SO MUCH TIME SPENT
LOOKING AT HITTERS AND YOU KNOW
GOING INTO A GAME WILL HAVE TWO
STRIKES, FOR INSTANCE, BRING THE
BARREL IN A DIFFERENT ANGLE TO
BLOCK A BALL LIKE THAT.
SOME GUYS, IT DOES NOT MATTER
WHAT THE COUNT IS.
WHEN THEY MAKE CONTACT, THERE
BAT ANGLE WILL BE ON THE PULL
SIDE.
YONDER: TALKING TO MARK EARLIER
TODAY, I ASKED HIM ABOUT THE
DIMENSIONS ON THE FIELD AND HOW
QUIRKY IT WAS AND HE MENTIONED
TO ME HOW IT IS ONE OF THE MORE
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS WHEN YOU GO
TO A BALLPARK, YOU REALLY HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND THE ANGLES HERE,
NOT ONLY ON THE LINES BUT ALSO
IN RIGHT CENTER AND LEFT CENTER.
THERE'S A LOT OF SHIFTED ANGLES
AND FOR AN OUTFIELDER, IT CAN
ONLY GET TRICKIER WHERE YOU HAVE
TO COVER NOT ONLY THE FOUL
LINES, BUT THE GAPS.
BUCK: THIS BALLPARK IS A COPY
WITH EXCEPTION OF THE HEIGHT OF
THE FENCE OF THE OLD BALLPARK.
AND THEY HAVE TRIED TO KEEP THE
NUANCES.
I THINK IT IS FAIR FOR HITTERS
AND PITCHERS.
MELANIE: AGAIN, AS YOU SAID, IT
WAS A GREAT READ ON THE SHIFT
FOR WILLIE CALHOUN.
NICK SOLAK IS THE A'S MARK
CANHA.
HE IS GOING TO MAKE THAT ONE
COUNT, SCORING FROM FIRST IN AN
ALL-OUT RUN.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE SEEN A LOT
OF FORM.
WITH THAT, THEY HAVE MET THE MGM
AUNTS FOR THE GAME, OVER/UNDER
NINE RUNS.
YONDER: YOU KNOW WHAT I ALWAYS
LIKED ABOUT GUYS RUNNING BASES?
I HAD A RULE.
RUN THE SAME WAY YOU WANT THEM
TO BE RUN FOR YOU.
SO IF YOU ARE THE HITTER, AND
YOU GET THAT DOUBLE, YOU WANT
BACK -- THAT GUY THE SAME WAY
YOU WOULD WANT TO RUN IT I WAS
BUSTING BECAUSE I ALWAYS FELT
LIKE IF I AM GIVING IT
EVERYTHING I HAVE, WHEN I DO HIT
THAT DOUBLE I WANT MY GUY THAT
IS ON BASE TO DO IT THE SAME
WAY.
I LOVE SCORING BECAUSE I WOULD
ALWAYS SCREAM.
I ALWAYS SCORED FOR MY FRIENDS.
THAT IS THE FULL, TO SCORE RUNS.
MELANIE: PLAYING THE CORNERS IN
THIS ONE.
CHARLIE CULBERSON UP THE RIGHT
SIDE THIS TIME, AND THE RANGERS
HAVE TWO IN THE INNING.
WILLIE CALHOUN COMES HOME AND IT
IS A CHARLIE CULBERSON DOUBLE
AREA TWO EXTRA BASES GIVEN UP IN
THE FIFTH.
BUCK: THAT IS A BEAUTIFUL THING.
YOU EVER HAD ONE OF THOSE?
YONDER: EIGHT NOTHING BETTER
THAN THAT RIGHT THERE.
BUCK: THAT IS A DOUBLE IN THE
PAPER TOMORROW.
YONDER: THAT'S RIGHT.
I ALWAYS LIKE THOSE AND I ALWAYS
LIKE THE BUNT SINGLES, THE
SWINGING SINGLES FOR A BUNT
WHERE YOU QUEUE IT OFF THE END
OF THE BAT.
BUT FOR CHARLIE CULBERSON RIGHT
THERE, A JOURNEYMAN WHO CAME IN
WITH THE DODGERS AND SPENT SOME
BIG YEARS WITH THE BRACE, I LOVE
THAT HE IS GETTING A CHANCE WITH
THE TEXAS RANGERS.
HE HAS BEEN PLAYING SOME THIRD
BASE, A LITTLE BIT OF SECOND
BASE, A GUY WHO CAN ABSOLUTELY
KILL LEFTIES HIS WHOLE CAREER
BASICALLY, AND THIS YEAR, EVEN
MORE, HITTING OVER .330 OFF OF
THEM.
I LOVE WHEN HE'S GETTING THAT
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE TEXAS
RANGERS.
MELANIE: HE HAD A CHANCE AND
PLAYED FOR THE HOMETOWN AND GREW
UP IN GEORGIA, THEY'D FOR THE
BRAVES A LITTLE BIT.
HE HAS HAD FIVE PITCHING
APPEARANCES IN HIS CAREER BUT WE
HAVE GOT THE RESULTS TO THE
YOUTUBE FAN POLE.
WHICH OF THESE A.L. PLAYERS HAS
THE MOST SURPRISING HOT START?
WE HATE TO TELL HIM HE DID NOT
TAKE IT AWAY.
BUT HE HAS STILL GOT A CHANCE TO
PROVE IT HERE AS HE TAKES A
HEALTHY HACK.
IT FALLS INTO CENTER FIELD.
SCOOPING THE OUTCOME ADVANCING
INTO THIRD ON THE PLAY GOES
CHARLIE CULBERSON.
SO IN OUT BUT HE STILL MOVE THE
RUNNER 90 FEET FROM HOME.
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK HERE.
MATT OLSON JUST BARELY EDGED OUT
BY GARCIA.
IT HAS BEEN AMAZING TO WATCH
BECAUSE AS MUCH AS THE RANGERS
HAVE SCUFFLED THIS SEASON, I
FEEL LIKE YOU CANNOT KEEP
GARCIA'S NAME OUT OF THE
HEADLINES AND IT IS A BASE --
THE BASE OF THAT IS THE STORY,
JUST WHAT HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO
THIS YEAR WITH THIS TEAM.
YONDER: IT IS A LITTLE
SURPRISING THAT MATT OLSON GOT
SO MANY GOALS ON THAT.
THIS IS A GUY WHO HAS BEEN KNOWN
TO HAVE REALLY GOOD NUMBERS.
FOR A GUY LIKE ADOLIS GARCIA,
THE STORYLINE, THE ABILITY TO
HIT, THE ABILITY TO JUST BE WHAT
WE CALL A BASEBALL PLAYER IN OUR
WORLD, THAT IS A SPECIAL THING.
I ROOT FOR THIS GUY A LOT.
HE HAS TREMENDOUS BAT SPEED.
HE HAS A GREAT MINDSET AND THE
WORK ETHIC REALLY SHOWS.
I HOPE I SEE HIM IN THE ALL-STAR
GAME.
MELANIE: I HAVE A FEELING THAT
WE WILL.
COLE IRVIN IS TRYING TO PUT THIS
ONE AWAY.
A RUNNER AT THIRD.
THE RANGERS SHUT OUT, NO MORE.
DOUBLE IS FROM CHARLIE CULBERSON
AND WILLIE CALHOUN.
THEY HAVE A TOUCHDOWN TO MAKE UP
FOR HERE BUT ELI WHITE ALREADY
AHEAD AND THE COUNT, TWO BALLS
AND NO STRIKES.
A YOUNG PIECE.
STILL TRYING TO FIND HIMSELF.
THE BIG FOCUS IS BRINGING OUT
HIS ATHLETICISM AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU ARE APPEARING
MORE IN THE GAME, THE OVERALL
ATHLETE.
THIS ONE DROPPED IN FOR A BASE
HIT.
CULBERSON WALKS HOME.
HE WILL HOLD UP AT SECOND BASE.
THREE DOUBLES IN THE INNING.
ELI WHITE FINDS IT HERE.
HE HAS GONE BACK TO BACK NOW IN
PLATE APPEARANCES.
9-3, A'S STILL WITH A PRETTY BIG
LEAD.
YONDER: JUST A BAD JUDGMENT
CALL.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND, IT IS
EITHER AN ALL-OUT OR JUST
NOTHING AT ALL AND CONTINUE TO
GET THAT HIT AND KEEP THE RUNNER
AT BAY AT FIRST BASE.
FOR ME, MARK CANHA, A BAD
DECISION, ESPECIALLY WITH THAT
NOT BEING HIS HOME FIELD.
JUST DON'T KNOW HOW IT'S GOING
TO KICK BACK.
BUCK: THAT IS VERY IMPRESSIVE
THAT THE CENTER FIELD IS THERE.
HE IS PLAYING IN RIGHT CENTER.
I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MANY GUYS
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN THERE AND
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A TRIPLE.
THAT IS IT FOR HIM TO GET ALL
THE WAY OVER AND BACK TO HIS
TEAMMATE.
MELANIE: HE HAS BEEN KNOWN FOR
HIS ATHLETICISM, FOR HIS SPEED.
KNOWN FOR THE NAME AS WELL.
MOM WAS A BEAUTY QUEEN, DAD WAS
AN ATHLETE.
WE HAVE A KID.
HIS NAME HAS TO BE STELLAR.
I THINK THEY NAILED IT.
SWING HERE AND IT IS A HIT
PARADE OFF OF IRVINE HERE IN THE
FIFTH INNING.
HERE COMES ELI WHITE AND THE
RANGERS ARE FINDING THEIR GROOVE
HERE AGAINST COLE IRVIN.
ADOLIS GARCIA, HIS FIRST HIT OF
THE BALLGAME.
IT GOES FOR AN R.B.I..
IT IS 9-4.
YONDER: THIS IS THE EXACT INNING
OF A CHIP AWAY.
JUST MAKING SURE, ONE RUN AT A
TIME, THAT THERE'S TIME FOR YOU
TO MAKE A RUN AT THIS.
IN THIS FIFTH INNING, IT'S THEIR
WINDOW.
THEY ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
URBAN'S PITCHES UP IN THE ZONE
-- COLE IRVIN'S PITCHES UP IN
THE ZONE.
MELANIE: STILL WITH TWO OUTS,
BUT COLE IRVIN IS SCUFFLING IN
THE FIFTH.
A SPATTER OF THE INNING WITH
JOEY.
HE IS 0-2 ON THE DAY AND THE
DISCUSSION, GALLO IS GOING TO BE
THE GUY WHO REALLY BENEFITS IF
PITCHES START TO FLATTEN OUT A
LITTLE BIT.
A TRADITIONAL FASTBALL HUNTER.
THE POWER DOWN A LITTLE BIT,
REACHING MORE.
A LOT OF WALKS WAS WHAT HE
WAS ABLE TO DO LAST NIGHT.
IT IS NOT THE TYPICAL JOEY GALLO
WE HAVE BEEN USED TO HEARINGS
OVER THE YEARS WITH THESE BOMB
OUT OF THE PARK BECAUSE.
YONDER: HE IS A HITTER WHO LIKES
TO GET OUT IN FRONT OF BASS.
HE LIKES TO EXTEND HIS HANDS,
BUT WHAT I LIKED ABOUT HIM, HE
IS STILL GETTING ON BASE,
GETTING HIS WALK AS MUCH AS HE
IS GETTING HIS STRIKEOUTS.
THIS IS WHO HE IS AND THIS IS
THE TYPE OF EARTH AND HE IS,
WHERE HE WOULD RATHER TAKE YOU
DEEP THEN HIT A GROUND BALL TO
SHORTSTOP.
THAT IS WHO THE PLAYER IS AND
THAT IS WHAT I LIKE ABOUT HIM.
WHAT I REALLY HAVE ADMIRED FROM
HIM IS THE ABILITY TO WALK AS
WELL.
HE HAS A VERY HIGH ON-BASE
PERCENTAGE, WHICH YOU DON'T WITH
A GUY WHO IS A SLUGGER AT TIMES.
YOU TEND TO NOT HAVE THAT WALK
RIGHT THERE, BUT FROM JOEY
GALLO, HE HAS GOT TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A GOOD PITCH SELECTION AND
BE ABLE TO JUST BE CONSISTENT
WITH HIS SWING.
MELANIE: HE HAS WORKED INTO THE
2-2 COUNT.
BUCK: WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE FIFTH
INNING?
YOU HAVE TO GET FIVE TO GET A W.
IT'S FUNNY.
THROUGH THE YEARS, THIS HAS BEEN
THE INNING THAT A LOT OF
PITCHERS HAVE AN ISSUE WITH.
MELANIE: WE THOUGHT YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO TELL US WHAT IS UP WITH
THE FIFTH INNING.
YOU HAVE THE PLAYBOOK HERE.
BUCK: IF I DID, I WOULD NOT BE
SITTING UP HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
YONDER: YOU KNOW, WE TALK ABOUT
1-1 COUNTS.
FOR A MANAGER, THE FIFTH INNING
IS THAT 1-1 COUNT, AND YOU WANT
TO BE ABLE TO WIN THESE INNINGS
AND THERE'S NOTHING MORE
STRESSFUL THAN A FIVE RUN LEAD
RIGHT NOW, TWO OUTS, AND THERE
IS A HUGE RALLY GOING ON RIGHT
NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS GAME
WITH SIX PITCHES.
MELANIE: HE LOSES THEM HERE.
TEXAS RANGERS LOOKING TO GET
BACK AND EVEN THINGS OUT.
THEY STILL HAVE SOME THINGS TO
BE DONE BUT AGAIN, GALLO WITH A
WALK.
BUCK: THAT IS PROBABLY STRIKE
THREE.
MELANIE: FOUR SEAM JUST ON THE
OUTSIDE THERE.
YONDER: MORE THAN NOT, IT IS A
STRIKE.
BUCK: YUP.
MELANIE: 67 PITCHES FOR COLE
IRVIN.
BOB MELVIN HAS BEEN PACING.
THE RIGHT-HANDER IS IN THE
A'S BULLPEN.
IRVIN HAS TWO MEN ON, TWO OUT.
NINTH MAN, ANDY IBANEZ.
HE DID LOSE A LOT OF MAY WITH A
STRAIN AS HE WAS SWINGING
THROUGH A PITCH, BUT THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR A WAY TO REVITALIZE
THIS TEAM, BRING SOME LIFE INTO
THE LINEUP, AND DID HE EVER DO
THAT YESTERDAY WITH HIS FIRST
CAREER HOME RUN?
HE SWINGS, AND THIS ONE GETS
GOBBLED UP BY THE A'S IN FIELD
AND THEY FINALLY BRING IT TO A
CLOSE.
THE 4-3 PUT OUT BUT ONLINE COME
9-4.
MATT OLSON LEADS OFF WHEN WE
COME BACK WITH THE SIXTH INNING
GAME TWO.
OAKLAND IN TEXAS.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
♪
>> HIT WELL TO RIGHT CENTER.
LAUREANO IS AT THE WALL.
LAUREANO LEAPS AND HE CAUGHT IT.
HE IS BACK, FOLKS.
SO LAUREANO GOES TO RIGHT
CENTER.
YOU ALMOST FEEL LIKE HE HAD IT
ALL THE WAY.
>> FIRST PITCH IS DRIVEN TOWARDS
THE CENTER AND DEEP.
LAUREANO LEAPS AND HE CAUGHT IT.
HE CAUGHT IT.
A GAME SAVIOR BY LAUREANO AS HE
TAKES A TWO RUN HOMER AWAY FROM
ANTHONY RENDON.
>> HE IS THE HUMAN HIGHLIGHT
FILM, FOLKS.
>> LAUREANO HAS GOT TO GET BACK.
STILL GOING BACK NEAR THE WALL,
AND HE CAUGHT IT.
HE CANNOT BELIEVE IT.
>> WE CAN BELIEVE IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE SEEN IT BEFORE FROM RAMON
LAUREANO.
♪
MELANIE: YOU CAN PUSH YOUR
FAVORITE PLAYERS TO THE TOP THIS
SUMMER WITH THE 2021 GOOGLE, BE
ALL-STAR BALLOT.
NOTE DAILY AT MLB.COM/VOTE AND
ON GOOGLE BY SEARCHING MLB
ALL-STAR VOTE TO SEND THEM TO
COLORADO.
ISIAH KINER-FALEFA, THE
SHORTSTOP FOR THE RANGERS, WAS
REALLY PUSHING HARD TO GET THAT
VOTE.
HERE IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> I AM AN OLD-SCHOOL
BALLPLAYER, I DO THINGS THE
RIGHT WAY, AND I THINK THAT GOES
ALONG WAY.
YOU LOOK AT GUYS LIKE DEREK
JETER, OZZIE SMITH, ALL THE
GREATS, I MEAN, WHICH ONE OF
THOSE HAD 1000 O.P.S.?
THE GAME IS CHANGING.
GUYS ARE HITTING MORE HOMERS,
BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN IF YOU
ARE A WELL-ROUNDED PLAYER, YOU
SHOULD GET KNOBBED.
MELANIE: ISIAH KINER-FALEFA IS
SOMEBODY WE JUST KEPT TEARING
HIS CHARACTER, CONFIDENCE, AND
HOW HE SHAPED HIMSELF AS A MAJOR
LEAGUE BALLPLAYER, HAS CONTINUED
TO SHIFT AS HE FINDS HIS WAY,
AND I DON'T THINK HE HAS ANY
MINCED WORDS ABOUT HOW HE FEELS
ABOUT BEING TOWARDS THE BOTTOM
END OF THE VOTING, BUT THIS HAS
ALSO BEEN A DISCUSSION FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS ABOUT THE
FAN VOTE VERSUS THE CREDENTIALS
VOTE.
YONDER: I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
THE FAN VOTE SHOULD BE A LITTLE
BIT LESS.
I THINK IT SHOULD BE MORE OF A
PLAYERS VOTE OR EVEN A MEDIA
TYPE OF VOTE SITUATION.
I ALWAYS ADMIRED WHEN GUYS IN
THE ALL-STAR GAME WOULD GET
VOTED IN BY THE PLAYERS.
I REMEMBER IN 2017, I GOT VOTED
IN BY THE PLAYERS AND I FELT SO
HONORED THAT THE PLAYERS WOULD
VOTE A PLAYER IN, AND WHEN YOU
HAVE THAT LUXURY TIME TO STAND,
AS A PLAYER IN DEPTH, WHEN A GUY
CAN BE AN ALL-STAR, DOES NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE A GUIDE
TO HIT 30 MERS.
IT CAN BE A GUY LIKE HIM.
I THINK FOR ME, HE IS WELL
DESERVING OF BEING AN ALL-STAR.
HE IS ON TOP.
HE IS AT THE LEADERBOARD OF WAR
WHEN IT COMES TO KINER-FALEFA.
MELANIE: HE TOOK TO TWITTER AS
LONG.
WHAT A JOKE THE TOP 10 IN
ALL-STAR VOTES.
AND EVEN HIS MANAGER BACKED HIM
UP.
THIS IS THE GUY I WANT IN ALL
NINE POSITIONS BECAUSE I AM AN
OLD-SCHOOL PLAYER.
BUT HE IS SO WELL ADJUSTED TO
THE WAY THAT THE GAME IS NOW AND
THOSE LITTLE IDIOCY THESE THAT
COME IN WITH IT, AND I THE THING
IS, MIKE TROUT IS A TOP THAT
LIST, INJURED.
BYRON BUXTON HAS MISSED
SIGNIFICANT TIME AND YET THESE
GUYS ARE STILL AT THE TOP OF
THOSE BALLOTS.
>> I WISH IN THE ALL-STAR GAME
THAT THEY HAD ONE PLAYER THAT
WAS A UTILITY GUY.
I THINK THOSE GUYS ARE ALSO
OVERLOOKED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A GUY LIKE KRIS
BRYANT, FOR EXAMPLE, HE IS
GETTING VOTED IN AS A THIRD
BASEMAN, BUT HE CAN ALSO PLAY
FIRST, CENTER, LEFT, WITH ISIAH
KINER-FALEFA RIGHT HERE AT
SHORTSTOP.
HE HAS PLAYED A LOT OF GAMES AT
HE IS A SECOND BASEMAN.
HE CAN PLAY THE OUTFIELD.
THIS IS A GUY YOU NEED ON YOUR
TEAM TO BE A WINNING TYPE OF
TEAM.
AND FOR HIM, I THINK HE IS WELL
DESERVING OF BEING A SHORTSTOP,
REPRESENTING THE TEXAS RANGERS
IN DENVER.
MELANIE: AND HE HAS MADE THE
LAST TWO OUTS HERE FOR THE
RANGERS.
LET'S GO TO BRETT DOLAN.
YOU HAVE MORE ON KINER-FALEFA'S
JOURNEY AND HIS FIGHT RIGHT NOW
TO SEND HIMSELF TO DENVER.
BRETT: IT'S INTERESTING THE WAY
HE HAS CARED SO MUCH ABOUT IT,
TALKING ABOUT IT BEING A JOKE.
CHRIS WOODWARD SAID HE WAS
INSULTED FOR HIM, BUT THE WAY HE
PLAYS WITH HIS SUPREME
CONFIDENCE, YOU ALMOST FEEL LIKE
THIS SLIGHT ONLY MOTIVATES HIM
MORE.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU ARE LABELED A
SAVAGE COMPETITOR, A GUY WHO CAN
AFFECT THE GAME IN EVERY WAY,
THAT IS PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
OLD-SCHOOL, NEW SCHOOL, DOESN'T
MATTER.
THAT IS IMPRESSIVE.
MELANIE: TEXAS IS TIDYING THINGS
UP BEHIND THE HEATED
KINER-FALEFA.
IT IS ANOTHER INNING FOR
THESE RENTERS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGHT BACK,
SEE IF THEY CAN HAVE IT EVEN
BIGGER.
NICK SOLAK COMES BACK IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE SIXTH.
>> HANG ON.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> HERE IT COMES.
THAT BALL WELL STRUCK.
HIGH IN THE AIR.
DEEP CENTER FIELD.
GONE.
GARCIA AGAIN.
THE RANGERS IN FRONT IN THE
EIGHTH INNING.
>> YOU THINK HE KNEW THAT WAS A
HOMER?
[LAUGHTER]
>> WOW.
>> A DULLES GARCIA, THE BATTER
-- AND GARCIA, THE BATTER.
>> GONE.
>> TIE GAME AND THE EIGHTH
INNING.
HE HAS DONE IT AT HOME.
>> WAITING FOR HIS MOMENT HERE.
>> THAT IS IN THE AIR OUT TO
RIGHT FIELD.
BACK TO THE WALL.
GONE.
THE RANGERS WALK IT OFF IN THE
10TH INNING.
HE COMES THROUGH AGAIN.
MELANIE: THE SEARCH FOR THE BEST
CONTINUES HERE.
OF COURSE, MOOKIE BETTS HAS BEEN
HEADLINING OUTFIELDERS FOR QUITE
SOME TIME NOW.
HE HAS JUST HAD SOME EPIC
CLIMES.
HE IS NOT OUT TO BE OUTDONE BY
SEVERAL OTHER GUYS ACROSS THE
LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
DIVING, FLYING, AND ALL OVER THE
PLACE, RAMON LAUREANO HAS HAD A
COUPLE OF ABSOLUTE DEALS FROM
PEOPLE THIS YEAR.
BREAKING HEARTS, ROBBING HOME
RUNS.
OUTFIELDERS HAVE BEEN ON THE UP
AND UP.
WHO IS THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
DEFENSIVE OUTFIELDER RIGHT NOW?
GO AHEAD AND PLACE THOSE
VOTES ON THE YOUTUBE FAN POLE
AND WE WILL FIND OUT WHO YOU
THINK DESERVES THE TOP SPOT.
BYRON BUXTON IS DOWN AGAIN.
HE HAS HAD A PRETTY EMBATTLED
2020 ONE SEASON, TRYING TO STAY
HEALTHY.
THE INJURY BUG HAS BIT HIM ONCE
MORE.
YONDER: YOU KNOW WHAT I LOVE
MOST ABOUT RAMON LAUREANO?
HE WAS A TWO-WAY PLAYER AND I
JUST LOVE HIS ARM.
HE HAS THROWN SOME BALLS -- THEY
CLOCKED AT OVER 100 MILES PER
HOUR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT GUYS, THAT IS
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT ATHLETES ON THE
FIELD.
THIS IS A GUY WHO NOT ONLY CAN
GO GET IT, HE HAS ONE OF THE
BEST JUMPS IN ALL OF BASEBALL
WHEN IT COMES TO GOING IN
GETTING BALLS IN THE GAPS.
MAN, WHEN HE LETS GO OF THOSE
BALLS, THEY ARE GOING OVER 100
MILES PER HOUR.
YOU HAVE NO CHANCE TO TAKE EXTRA
BASES ON LAUREANO.
MELANIE: YOU REALLY DON'T.
WE WATCHED SOME HEARTBREAKERS.
SURELY A BALL IS GOING TO FALL
OR GET OUT AND SPIDER-MAN COMES
IN TO CHANGE THE SITUATION.
BURCH SMITH IS A RELIEVER IN FOR
OAKLAND.
HE WAS REALLY STRUGGLING IN THE
FIFTH INNING.
FOUR RUNS TO THE RANGERS AS THEY
FOUND THEIR WAY MERELY CUTTING
THE LEAD IN HALF, BUT AGAIN, A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RUN SUPPORT
FOR ERVIN -- IRVIN TONIGHT.
HE HAS BEEN TRYING TO FIND HIS
WAY.
HE IS STILL A YOUNG GUY.
HE DOES NOT EXPECT HIM TO COME
IN AND BE PERFECT RIGHT AWAY.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE THOSE
GROWING MOMENTS BUT HE STARTED
THAT ROCKY FIFTH INNING WITH THE
MAN AT THE PLATE, NICK SOLAK.
A HIT BY PITCH TO THE OUTER
ELBOW AND MAN, DID HE COME
AROUND FROM FIRST TO SCORE THAT
FIRST RUN.
YONDER: WHEN WE TALK ABOUT BURCH
SMITH, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
GUY WITH A HEAVY SPIN RATE.
HE RELIES HEAVILY ON HIS
FOUR-SEAMERS UP IN THE ZONE.
I PLAYED WITH BURCH SMITH IN THE
EARLY DAYS SINCE THE SAN DIEGO
PADRES AND HE WAS KNOWN TO HAVE
A BLAZING FASTBALL AT 98 MILES
PER HOUR AND HE HAS LEARNED HOW
TO UTILIZE THAT FASTBALL AND
THAT PITCH AND THAT COMMAND WITH
THE OAKLAND A'S.
MELANIE: HE TAKES OVER WITH
STILL A FIVE-RUN HEALTHY LEAD.
A MISS OUTSIDE TO SOLAK.
YONDER: I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT HOW MUCH IN THIS GAME NOW,
WE ARE SEEING GUYS THROWING 96
TO 98 MILES PER HOUR, JUST
DEPENDENT SO HEAVILY ON SLIDERS,
WHERE WE THE A GUY LIKE SMITH,
TELLING YOU HERE IT IS.
THIS IS WHAT I GOT.
HE IS USING HIS FOUR-SEAMER OVER
75% OF THE TIME.
13 OF HIS 17 STRIKEOUTS HAVE
COME VIA THE FOUR SEAM, SO IS
THERE SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE
ABLE TO COME BACK INTO THE GAME
NOW WITH ALL THE STICKY STUFF
GOING ON?
BRETT: I WILL ANSWER THAT --
YONDER: I WILL ANSWER THAT IN
JUST A SECOND.
JUMP IN THERE.
MELANIE: THIS COPYRIGHTED
TELECAST IS PRESENTED BY
AUTHORITY OF THE OFFICE OF THE
COMMISSIONER OF BASEBALL AND MAY
NOT BE REPRODUCED OR
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM.
AND THE ACCOUNTS AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF THIS GAME MAY
NOT BE DISSEMINATED WITHOUT THE
EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT OF THE
-- CONSENT.
BUCK: WOW.
HERE IS A GUY, 31 YEARS OLD, AND
TO ME, IT IS A LOT LIKE, I DON'T
KNOW, GARCIA IN CENTER FIELD FOR
TEXAS.
IN TODAY'S GAME WHEN A GUY IS 28
YEARS OLD, AND HE IS WILLING TO
GO WORK ON THE THINGS -- USED TO
BE 26 YEARS OLD.
IF YOU HAVE NOT FIGURED IT OUT
-- SEEING SO MANY OF THESE GUYS
FIGURE IT OUT AT A LATER STAGE
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY THINGS
AT THEIR DISPOSAL TO IMPROVE ON
AND THEY CAN EVALUATE THEMSELVES
MORE HONESTLY.
FINDING OUT WHO YOU ARE.
URGE SMITH HAS FIGURED OUT WHO
HE IS.
-- BURCH SMITH HAS FIGURED OUT
WHO HE IS.
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY IF YOU CONTINUE TO
APPLY YOUR TRADE AND WORK AT IT
AND TRY AND APPROVE.
THERE'S PLENTY OF WAYS FOR THEM
TO HELP NOWADAYS.
YOU GOT TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
TURNING THE PAGE ON THESE GUYS
WHO HAVE A LOT AT THAT
28-YEAR-OLD RANGE, IF THEY STILL
HAVE THAT "WANT TO," BE CAREFUL
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT MAKE A MISTAKE
ON LETTING THEM GO.
YONDER: THAT IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT POINT.
ANALYTICS DOES NOT SAY THAT.
ANALYTICS DOES NOT HAVE THE
ANSWER FOR THE HEART.
AS A BASEBALL PLAYER, THIS WILL
FOREVER BE A HEART AND FEEL TYPE
OF GAME, REGARDLESS OF THE
ANALYTICS, REGARDLESS OF ALL
THIS INFORMATION YOU HAVE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A GUY LIKE
GARCIA FOR THE RANGERS, THERE IS
A "WANT" IN THERE AND A BIG
HEART.
IT TAKES A WHILE.
BASEBALL IS NOT LIKE BASKETBALL,
YOU COME IN AT 19 YEARS OLD AND
YOU ARE READY TO BURCH SMITH DEE
ODDS.
RANGERS TRAIL THE A'S 9-4.
JED LOWRIE LEADING OFF WHEN WE
COME BACK IN THE SEVENTH.
♪
>> THAT SHOULD DO IT.
THE A'S WITH THEIR FIRST WIN OF
THE 2021 SEASON.
>> A LINE DRIVE HOME RUN TO LEFT
CENTER BY MURPHY.
>> OFF THE WALL, CANNOT GET IT.
LASER TO THIRD.
HE IS IN THERE WITH A TRIPLE.
>> SWUNG ON AND HIT.
PAST THE THIRD BASEMAN.
NOT IN TIME, AND THEY HAVE WON
IT.
>> THEIR EIGHTH CONSECUTIVE WIN.
>> YOU BETTER PICK IT UP.
>> THAT BABY IS GONE.
>> DOWN THE RIGHT-FIELD LINE.
>> GRAND SLAM HIT THE FOUL BALL.
>> ON THE TARP AND HE PULLS IT
BACK.
UNBELIEVABLE PLAY BY MATT
CHAPMAN.
>> HE CAUGHT IT.
>> MIXED UP, POUND TOWN.
>> AND HE CAUGHT IT.
THAT IS THE BALLGAME.
♪
MELANIE: FANS, YOU CAN STEP UP
TO THE PLATE, COMPETE ONLINE,
AND CRUSH DINGERS.
DOWNLOAD FOR FREE TODAY.
MLB ORIGINALS SEASON TWO IS ON
YOUTUBE WITH NEW EPISODES EVERY
WEEK.
YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS AND LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU LOVE ON
YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
AND WELCOME BACK IN, EVERYBODY.
MELANIE NEWMAN, YONDER ALONSO,
BUCK, AND BRETT.
ATHLETICS, 9-4 LEAD OVER THE
RANGERS.
JORDAN LYLES WAS SUPPOSED TO
START.
MAYBE YOU ARE THINKING IT COULD
HAVE STARTED.
HE HAS GONE A LONGER DISTANCE
AFTER CHRIS WOODWARD WAS FORCED
TO RETIRE TAYLOR HEARN.
HE IS WORKING HERE INTO THE
SEVENTH.
HE HAD A CLEAN 1-2-3 AGAINST THE
A'S IN THE SIXTH.
IT IS STILL A'S ON TOP 9-4 IN
THIS GAME TWO OF A FOUR-GAME
SERIES.
WORKING IN THROUGH FOUR INNINGS,
TWO RUNS, FOUR HIT.
A'S EXPLODED IN THE FIRST.
ALL NINE CAME TO THE PLATE.
HOME RUNS IN THE FIRST AND
SECOND INNINGS.
YONDER: TALK ABOUT A CHANGE OF
EVENTS, HUH?
LOOKING AT A SECOND INNING,
THIRD INNING, AND WOODWARD FOR
THE RANGERS WAS JUST INKING
ABOUT HE MIGHT PITCH AS A
POSITION PLAYER IN THE NINTH
INNING, AND HERE HE IS WITH A
CHANCE TO MAKE ANOTHER RUN AT
THIS GAME AND MAYBE TIE IT UP.
THIS IS JUST HOW QUICKLY IT CAN
HAPPEN IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
MELANIE: I THINK IF YOU ARE
HAVING A POSITION PLAYER PITCH
AGAIN, IT HAS TO BE CULBERSON.
HE HAS HAD FIVE APPEARANCES ON
THE MOUND AND IT SOUNDS LIKE HE
CAN HOLD THINGS TOGETHER.
IT IS A DEEP FLY.
MANAGEABLE TO LEFT CENTER FOR
GARCIA.
RETIRED.
FANS, YOU CAN WATCH EXCLUSIVE
RANGERS CONTENT, GO BEHIND THE
SCENES AT GLOBE LIFE FIELD, AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT YOUR FAVORITE
PLAYERS ON THE TEXAS RANGERS
OFFICIAL YOUTUBE CHANNEL AT
YOUTUBE.COM/RANGERS, AND TAP
SUBSCRIBE.
YOU CAN FOLLOW YOUR RANGERS.
A LOOK AT CHRIS WOODWARD, THAT
IS WHAT HE HAS BEEN PREACHING.
HE WANTS TO GIVE FANS ACCESS,
INSIGHT, AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS TEAM IS STILL GOING OUT
THERE, TRYING TO PICK UP WINS.
IT IS NOT COME AS EASILY AS A
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK AND YOU HEAR
THE CLICHE ALL THE TIME.
IT IS A GAME BUILT ON FAILURE,
IF YOU ARE BATTING .300, THAT IS
30%, TECHNICALLY A GOOD NUMBER.
EVERYTHING IS OPENING BACK UP.
HE CAN HAVE FACE-TO-FACE
INTERACTION WITH MEDIA WHO
SHARES THE STORIES AND THE
PLAYERS CAN FINALLY TALK AND
INTERACT WITH PEOPLE AS WELL.
IT HAS BEEN A HUGE DIFFERENCE IN
THEIR GAME.
YONDER: FOR THE PLAYERS AS WELL,
IT IS A HUGE BOOST.
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT ROUTINE
IN FRONT OF FANS, BEING ABLE TO
PLAY IN FRONT OF THE FANS, IT
GIVES YOU THAT EXTRA ENERGY.
IT IS A LONG SEASON.
YOU NEED THE FANS.
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE GAMES
WHERE YOU ARE NOT 100% COME 3:00
OR 4:00.
7:00 COMES, ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOU
FEEL 100%.
YOU GET THE ADRENALINE NATS,
FEEL LIKE YOU CAN DO IT.
I ALWAYS ENJOY PLAYING IN FRONT
OF FANS.
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
KID THAT CAN COME TO THE GAME
AND SEE YOU WORKING A 3-2 WALK
OR HIT THE BALL THE OTHER WAY
AND HE MIGHT TAKE THAT HOME AND
WORK ON THAT SAME CRAFT.
ANYTIME YOU HAVE FANS IN THE
STADIUM, YOU CAN LEARN ABOUT THE
GAME.
IT IS A PLEASURE TO SEE ALL THE
FANS BACK.
MELANIE: SOMETHING THAT ALWAYS
DROVE HOME AS WE WERE TOLD
COMING UP, YOU TREAT EVERY GAME
AS IF IT IS SOMEBODY'S FIRST
GAME.
NOT JUST A CERTAIN TEAM OR THE
BIG LEAGUES OR THE MINOR
LEAGUES, BUT THEIR FIRST
INTRODUCTION TO THE SPORT.
THAT REALLY STARTS TO SHAPE
THINGS AND WITH GLOBE LIFE
FIELD, THEY WERE THE FIRST TO
HAVE FULL CAPACITY BACKS, AND
GETTING TO TALK TO OTHER PLAYERS
AROUND THE LEAGUE, YOU WALK OUT,
AND FIRST OF ALL, IT IS A BIG
YIELD, AND THEY WOULD TALK ABOUT
GETTING GOOSEBUMPS, RECOUNTING
HOW IT FELT TO HAVE THAT ENERGY
AFTER PLAYING IN A VACUUM
ESSENTIALLY LAST YEAR.
YONDER: RIGHT.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A KID,
GOING TO MARLINS STADIUM, JUST
ENJOYING THE ATMOSPHERE,
WATCHING GUYS WARM UP, WATCHING
GUYS THROW, WATCHING THE PITCHER
GET READY.
THOSE WERE THE MOMENTS I WILL
SOMETHING NEVER FORGET.
MELANIE: ELVIS ANDRUS, FLY BALL
TO LEFT FIELD.
IN.
ANOTHER QUIET INNING FOR THE
ATHLETICS HERE BUT AS WE HEAD TO
THE STRETCH, THEY ARE STILL ON
TOP 9-4.
>> THEY SET THE TONE IN THE
DIVISION SERIES AS THE RANGERS
VANQUISHED THE TAMPA BAY FOR THE
FRANCHISE'S FIRST POSTSEASON
TRIUMPH.
>> RANGERS MOVE ONTO THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP
SERIES.
>> BUT THAT MOMENTUM CAME TO A
GRINDING HALT IN GAME ONE OF THE
ALCS, WHEN THEY SUFFERED A
HEARTBREAKING LOSS TO THE
YANKEES.
>> THEY HAVE TAKEN GAME ONE.
DOWN 5-0.
THEY WIN IT 6-5.
>> YOUR BACK IS UP AGAINST THE
WALL.
EITHER WIN OR GO HOME TIME.
>> THEY HAD NO INTENTION OF
GOING HOME.
OUTSCORING THE YANKEES ARE D8-19
IN THE SERIES, ON THEIR WAY --
38-19 IN THE SERIES, ON THEIR
WAY.
>> HERE COMES THE PITCH.
BREAKING BALL STRIKE THREE
CALLED.
IN THE RANGERS ARE GOING TO THE
WORLD SERIES.
>> THAT WAS A HUGE MOMENT FOR
US, CLINCHING GAME SIX, WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WIN A WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> PANDEMONIUM IN ARLINGTON.
♪
MELANIE: NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK FOR THE 2021 SEASON IS
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME,
WHERE FANS WATCHING ON MOBILE
DEVICES AND COMPUTERS CAN VOTE
FOR WHICH PLAYER WILL RECEIVE
THE TROPHY DURING THE POSTGAME
SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME POLLING OPTIONS LATER ON IN
THE SHOW.
GOT QUITE A FEW TO CHOOSE FROM
TODAY AS THE RANGERS HAVE
STARTED TO FIND THEIR GROOVE AT
THE PLATE.
OF COURSE, YOU HAVE THE LIKES OF
MARK CANHA AND MATT CHAPMAN
RAMON LAUREANO THREATENING.
TRYING TO TAKE OVER HERE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE YOUTUBE FAN
POLL RESULTS.
THE MOST IMPRESSIVE DEFENSIVE
OUTFIELDER RIGHT NOW.
MOOKIE BETTS CONTINUES TO RUN
AWAY WITH THE CONVERSATION.
RAMON LAUREANO RIGHT BEHIND HIM.
I STILL REMEMBER WHEN THIS TRADE
HAPPENED AND MOOKIE GETS SHIPPED
FROM BOSTON TO L.A., THE LAST
THING YOU WANT TO DO IS UPSET
RED SOX NATION.
THEY ARE A VERY LOUD GROUP,
AMONGST SOME OF THE BIGGER
BASES, AND AS SOON AS THE WINS
ABOVE REPLACEMENT BETWEEN MOOKIE
BETTS AND BABE RUTH CAME UP, AND
THEY SAW HOW MUCH BETTER HE WAS,
THEY ELEVATED BABE'S STATS TO
WHERE THEY MATCHED, THAT WAS ALL
THE TALK.
HERE IS THE CURSE.
IT WILL BE TWICE AS LONG, 200
YEARS BEFORE THEY SEE A WORLD
RAYS, AND CREDIT TO ALEX CORA.
HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO TURN THE
TEAM AROUND SANS MOOKIE.
BUCK: ALEX CORA -- YONDER: ALEX
CORA IS ON PACE TO BE THE
MANAGER OF THE YEAR FOR THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE, RIGHT?
IF WE TALK ABOUT MOOKIE BETTS
AND EVERYTHING HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE, A GUY WHO CAN -- HE CAME
IN AS A SECOND BASEMAN.
HE PLAYED SOME RIGHT FIELD --
GOLD GLOVES AS A RIGHT AND FOR
THE DODGERS PLAYING CENTERFIELD
AS WELL, AN ELITE AS AN ELITE
PLAYER, THE SKY IS THE LIMIT FOR
THIS GUY.
MELANIE: SERGIO ROMO TAKES OVER
FOR BURCH SMITH, JUST ONE INNING
OF WORK, AND ROMO COMES IN.
HE HAS A K ON HIS FIRST BATTER
UP.
BUCK, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
BUCK: MOOKIE BETTS IS THE BEST
RIGHT FIELDER I HAVE EVER SEEN.
I'M SERIOUS.
I HAVE SEEN A FEW RIGHT
FIELDERS, BUT HE IS THE BEST
RIGHT FIELDER I HAVE EVER SEEN,
THE WHOLE PACKAGE.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE REALIZE HOW
BIG A DIFFERENCE HE MADE.
HE WAS SUCH A GAME CHANGER,
ESPECIALLY IN HOME GAMES.
HE WAS VERY ACCURATE THROWING,
DID NOT HAVE TO LEAVE HIS FEET,
AND THAT MADE HIM BE ABLE TO
MAKE AN ENSUING THROW, AND I
THINK ALEX CORA BEING OVER THERE
HAS MADE THEM COMPETITIVE AGAIN.
I THINK THERE IS A CERTAIN
CONFIDENCE LEVEL.
NONE OF US WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
OUR WHOLE CAREERS JUDGED BY OUR
WORST DECISION.
HE HAS COME BACK AND DONE A
GREAT JOB.
I DON'T THINK THE RED SOX ARE
GOING AWAY.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO BE A
THORN IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
EASTSIDE THE WHOLE YEAR.
MELANIE: THEY HAVE A STRONG
CHANCE.
THEY TOOK THE TOP SPOT BACK FROM
THE RAYS, WHO REALLY STRUGGLED
OVER THERE ARE SEVEN GAMES AS OF
LATE AND THESE TWO TEAMS COULD
NOT BE ANY MORE POLAR OPPOSITE,
BUT IT HAS MADE THE A.L. EAST
VERY INTERESTING.
YONDER: DO YOU THINK THE BOSTON
RED SOX WILL GO INTO THE TRADE
DEADLINE TRYING TO GET A
STARTING PITCHER OR DO YOU THINK
THEY HAVE ENOUGH GUYS WITH A GUY
LIKE CHRIS COMING BACK HEALTHY?
BUCK: I TALKED TO CHRIS YOUNG,
THE G.M. OF THE RANGERS, TODAY
ABOUT SOMETHING LIKE THAT AREA
YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
IT DEPENDS ON WHERE THEY ARE IN
THEIR DEVELOPMENT OF THE
ORGANIZATION.
DO I THINK PEOPLE IN BOSTON ARE
EXPECTING THEM TO MAKE A TRADE?
OF COURSE.
IT IS BOSTON.
I THINK THEY ALSO KNOW WHO THEY
ARE.
I THINK OAKLAND IS KIND OF THE
TAMPA BAY OF THE WEST BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WHO THEY ARE, THEY
KNOW WHAT TYPE OF PLAYERS THEY
GO AFTER, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
USE PAYROLL AS AN EXCUSE, THEY
KNOW THAT THE PIECES THEY NEED
-- THEY KNOW THEY HAVE A MANAGER
WHO COULD USE THE PIECES.
THE WAY THEY PUT THEIR CLUB
TOGETHER.
MELANIE: SWING HERE AND A BIG
ONE FOR ELI WHITE, HEADING BACK
OUT, AND DO NOT EVEN TRY TO GET
THIS ONE.
IT IS AN UPPER DECK SHOT.
ELI WHITE WITH A MASSIVE LAST.
THEY ARE WITHIN FOUR.
9-5.
THREE-HIT PERFORMANCE FOR WHITE
TODAY AND HE KEEPS ELEVATING ONE
AFTER THE NEXT.
YONDER: HE IS TURNING 27 ON
SATURDAY, BUT MY GOODNESS, THIS
IS A FREE GIFT TO HIS BIRTHDAY
CELEBRATION, ABSOLUTE BOMB.
MELANIE: 440 FEET, AND YOU KNOW
THAT IS A NEW PARK SO YOU KNOW
THERE ARE NOT A LOT OF NAMES ON
THE UPPER DECK LIST YET.
BUT MAN, IF HE HAS NOT PUT
HIMSELF OUT IN FRONT AT THE TOP.
YONDER: AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
BOMBS, IT ALWAYS COMES OFF
BREAKING BALLS.
IT FEELS LIKE YOU DO NOT HIT
YOUR FOR THE BALLS ON A HEATER.
YOU HIT THEM ON HANGING SLIDER'S
LIKE ROMO JUST THREW RIGHT THERE
AND THAT WAS SUCH AN EASY SWING,
THE FIRST-ROUND TYPE OF HE WHERE
YOU LET YOUR LEGS WORK, STAY
THROUGH THE BASE, STAY SHORT,
AND BOY, DID HE MAKE THAT SWING
JUST EXPLODE OFF THAT BALL.
MELANIE: HE IS GETTING ALL SORTS
OF CUBS FROM THE DUGOUT RIGHT
NOW.
AND THE FANS ARE ABSOLUTELY
EATING IT UP.
IT IS 9-5, A'S ON TOP, BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN QUIET SINCE THE THIRD
INNING.
IT HAS BEEN ALL RANGERS SINCE
THEN.
AND AGAIN, HERE IS A DULLES
GARCIA, THE RANGERS STRONGEST
CANDIDATE, PUSHING TO SEE HIS
NAME PUNCHED FOR DENVER.
SIX GAME STREAK.
HE CAME IN TODAY AND EXPANDED
THAT WITH A SINGLE IN THE FIFTH.
IF YOU ARE CHRIS WOODWARD, YOU
WOULD LOVE TO SEE A LITTLE MORE
ENERGY, AND HOW ABOUT IF ARMOR
RANGER -- FORMER RANGER WARMING
UP IN THE BULLPEN FOR THE A'S?
HE IS A VERY -- IT IS A VERY
HAPPY REUNION.
THEY ALL HAD TIME WITH THE
RANGERS.
AND ALL SMILES.
DIEKMAN GETTING HOT.
JOEY GALLO IS ON DECK.
YOU WANT TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT LEFTY BECAUSE AGAIN, A GUY
WHO HAS BEEN SITTING BACK, AND
HE IS DUE.
PICKED UP A WALK IN THE FIFTH
INNING.
TRYING TO TARGET A LEFTY-LEFTY
MATCHUP.
GARCIA SWINGS, AND THIS ONE
POPPED UP IN THE INFIELD.
AND AN OUT FOR THE A'S.
WON'T HAVE TO CALL ON  BIG BLASI
WHITE.
RANGERS TRAILING 9-5.
WE WILL BE BACK WITH THE EIGHTH.
>> HE WAS PERFECT, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN AROUND.
HE KNEW HOW TO WIN.
HE WAS AT THE END OF HIS CAREER
FOR THE MOST PART AND HE WAS
ENJOYING HIMSELF.
EVERYBODY ELSE ENJOYED HIS
ENERGY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JUST FLEX A LITTLE BIT.
>> I MEAN, IF YOU CAN SEE THIS,
I MEAN --
>> HE HAD A WAY OF CONNECTING
AND THE MESSAGE WE ALL TOOK WAS
CLOSENESS OFF THE FIELD
TRANSLATED TO A BOND ON THE
FIELD THAT MADE YOU
COMPETITIVELY BETTER.
HE WAS PERFECT FOR US.
>> THIS ONE IS DEEP TO RIGHT AND
THE GAME IS TIED.
>> THE 37-YEAR-OLD -- IS JUST
WHAT THE A'S WERE LOOKING FOR.
IN HIS TWO SEASONS IN OAKLAND,
THE CLUB AVERAGED 102 WINS.
>> BEST TEAM I EVER PLAYED FOR.
YOU SEE SOMEONE TO PUSH HIM TO
DELEGATE.
>> THAT IS A GROUND BALL TO THE
RIGHT SIDE.
YES, HE IS THERE IN TIME, AND
THE A'S ON THE WORLD CHAMPIONS.
>> THE SECOND ONE IS NICER.
MELANIE: GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING
TO POWER STATCAST TO REVEAL NEW
INSIGHTS, TAKING YOU DEEPER INTO
THE GAME THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
BIOTECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
WE HAVE GOTTEN SOME VERY
INTERESTING INSIGHTS THANKS TO
STATCAST THIS EVENING.
ELI WHITE LIGHTING UP A 440 FOOT
GLASS IN THE SEVENTH.
THE RANGERS FIFTH RUN OF THE
GAME.
THEY ARE COMING INTO PLAY THOSE
LATE INNING CONTENDERS TODAY.
JORDAN LYLES IS BACK OUT FOR THE
EIGHTH.
HE GETS A FOUL HERE FROM -- A
FREE SOUVENIR FOR THE FANS.
YONDER: I WANTED TO ASK YOUR
COME IN THE SITUATION OF THE
GAME, TOP OF THE EIGHTH, THE
OAKLAND A'S --WHAT IS HIS
THOUGHT RIGHT NOW?
YOU ARE IN GRAND SLAM RANGE, IN
A POSITION WHERE YOU CAN MAYBE
PUT THE GAME AWAY, BUT ANY
LITTLE BIT OF AN ATTACK HERE,
YOU ARE ON PANIC MODE, CORRECT?
BUCK: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT PANIC.
YOU GOT SIX OUTS TO GET BEFORE
THEY SCORE FOUR RUNS YOU
SIMPLIFY IT.
YOU KNOW THAT DIEKMAN MATCHES UP
AGAINST GALLO AND CALHOUN MET
INNING, YOU LOOK AT THEIR BENCH,
TWO LEFT-HANDERS AND A SWITCH
HITTER WHO HITS BETTER FROM ONE
SIDE, SETTING UP YOUR BULLPEN
THE REST OF THE WAY, AND SAYING
TO YOURSELF, IF I CANNOT GET ITS
OUTS BEFORE THEY GET FOUR RUNS,
YOU ARE NOT A VERY GOOD CLUB.
NEVER ASSUME ANYTHING TO GET I
GUARANTEE IT WAS 9-0.
BOB MELVIN WAS NOT ASSUMING
ANYTHING.
HIS FIFTH INNING GOT BACK IN IT.
TWO BLOOPED AND A BLAST.
YOU LOVE TO SEE THE MORALITY IN,
SO TO SPEAK, MOMENTUM OF SCORING
ONE MORE RUN.
IF OAKLAND COULD PUSH ONE
ACROSS, I THINK IT WOULD PUT
TEXAS IN A DIFFERENT MINDSET.
YONDER: I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT ON
POINT WITH THAT IN REGARDS TO
DIEKMAN.
I THINK HE WOULD BE THAT PIVOTAL
BLUE GUY TO BRANCH OUT TO THAT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE THAT
WHO IS JUST A FUNKY
THREE-QUARTER GUY WHO THROWS 94
TO 96 MILES PER HOUR, WHO COULD
PUT AWAY THE GAME AND THE EIGHTH
INNING, WE TALK ABOUT THE FIFTH
INNING BEING ONE OF THE MORE
IMPORTANT INNINGS IN ALL OF
BASEBALL, BUT THERE IS MORE
IMPORTANT AS WELL THAN THE
EIGHTH INNING BRIDGE TO THE
CLOSER, THREE OUTS TO PUT THE
GAME AWAY.
BUCK: YOU LOOK AT WHO THEY WOULD
PINCH-HIT FOR AND HOW THEY WOULD
COMBAT IT.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE BULLPEN IS
THEY ONLY HAVE ONE LEFT-HANDERS
SO DIEKMAN WILL FACE 2-4 HITTERS
AND ALSO HE WILL TAKE ALL OF HIS
LEFT-HANDED PINCH HITTERS OUT OF
PLAY IF HE PITCHES.
YONDER: WOULD YOU HAVE DIEKMAN
WARM UP AND THEN ANOTHER GUY
PIGGYBACKED AFTER IT --
PIGGYBACK AFTER IT?
LIKE PETROSIAN?
BUCK: WHEN YOU HAVE TRIVINO AND
CULBERSON -- IT'S NOT SO MUCH
WHO THEY ARE GOING TO FACE BUT
WHO THEY MIGHT POTENTIALLY FACE
IN A PINCH-HITTING SITUATION.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF -- THEY
ARE SET UP PRETTY GOOD BUT AS
LONG AS HE HAS DIEKMAN UP AND
THROWING IN THE BULLPEN,
SOMETIMES, YOU CAN CHANGE THE
WAY A MANAGER THINGS BECAUSE HE
CANNOT USE ANY OF THE
LEFT-HANDED PINCH HITTERS OFF
THE BENCH IF HE HAS DIEKMAN
SITTING THERE BUT THEY ONLY HAVE
ONE LEFT-HANDER IN THEIR
BULLPEN.
YONDER: I GUARANTEE YOU -- YOU
KNOW THIS.
HE WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS TO
INNINGS BEFORE.
-- TWO INNINGS BEFORE.
BUCK: HE BETTER.
BOB IS ONE OF THE BEST.
HE IS THE REAL DEAL.
THERE'S A LOT OF FALSE
NARRATIVES SOMETIMES.
BOB IS THE REAL DEAL.
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO MANAGE
HIM AND HE WAS ONE OF THOSE
GUYS.
HE RAISED HIS HAND AND WENT, O
GOD, HERE COMES A GOOD ONE.
YONDER: THE BEST THING IS HOW
TRANSPARENT HE WAS AND HOW HE IS
AT A COMMUNICATING LEVEL OF
MANAGERS IN THE GAME TODAY.
HE IS AT THE TOP.
THIS GUY WOULD HAVE A
COMMUNICATION.
HE WOULD SEND YOU A TEXT AT 9:00
IN THE
HE WILL SEND YOU A TEXT AT 9:00
IN THE MORNING OR 1:00 A.M.,
LETTING YOU KNOW YOU ARE NOT
PLAYING TOMORROW.
OR TEXT YOU AT 9:30, LETTING YOU
KNOW YOU WILL NOT BE IN THE
STARTING LINEUP TODAY.
THIS GUY UNDERSTANDS WHAT IT IS
TO BE A BIG LEAGUER, WHAT IT IS
TO NOT ONLY HAVE A FAMILY AND
THE STRESS OF PLAYING BASEBALL.
THIS GUY, OVER 800 WINS.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE IS DOING ON AN
EVERYDAY BASIS.
WHAT I LOVE MORE ABOUT HIM IS HE
IS INVOLVED.
THIS GUY THROWS BATTING PRACTICE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
MELANIE: HE KNOWS IT IS THE BIG
AND LITTLE THINGS ALL AT ONCE.
HE STARTED OFF WITH EVERY
REPORTER WITH GOOD MORNING.
THAT COMES OFF TO CHAMPIONSHIP
SUCCESS.
THEY ARE STILL LOOKING FOR THE
BIG ONE.
BOB MELVILLE CHASING POSTSEASON
AFTER POSTSEASON WITH THE A'S
AND IT HAS BEEN SOMETHING TO
TAKE IN WITH A CLUB THAT PEOPLE
HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT FOR A
WHILE.
THEY HAVE MADE IT SO YOU CAN'T
NOT TALK ABOUT THEM.
EVEN WHEN THEY STARTED THE SKID,
MAN DID THEY EVER COME BACK AND
MADE YOU FORGET THEY STARTED OFF
LOSING.
YONDER: A LOT OF CREDIT TO BOB
MEL, BUT A LOT OF CREDIT TO
HIS STAFF.
THESE ARE ALL BASEBALL GUYS.
YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE DARREN BUSH,
THE HITTING COACH, WHO HAS DONE
A TREMENDOUS JOB.
I HAVE HAD MULTIPLE HOURS WITH
THIS GUY HITTING AND MOST OF THE
TIME HE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAN
HITTING.
MELANIE: ELI WHITE MISSES THE
PLAY, PICKS IT UP, GETS IT INTO
ISIAH KINER-FALEFA AS MARK IS
TRYING TO ADVANCE IN ON SECOND
BASE.
THEY MAKE THE TAG.
WHAT A PLAY AS CANHA IS GETTING
GREEDY ON THE MIS-PLAY BY WHITE.
HE RECOVERED BEAUTIFULLY BECAUSE
THE RANGERS MAY KNOW THE PLAY OF
THIS PARK BETTER THAN ANYONE.
WHAT'S THE BUCK SHOWALTER
PRELIMINARY READ ON THIS PLAY?
BUCK: I DON'T THINK THEY WILL
OVERTURN.
I CAN'T REALLY SEE THE FRONT
FOOT, BUT I THINK THEY TAGGED
CLOSE ENOUGH.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING FOR A
DEFINITIVE --
I TELL YOU WHAT, I DON'T KNOW.
DID HIS FOOT COME OFF THE BAG?
MELANIE: GOT A LOT OF TRAFFIC IN
FRONT OF THAT VIEW.
THEY ARE WATCHING IT ON THE
REPLAY SCREEN NOW.
BUCK: I THINK THEY SHOULD CHANGE
THE RULE THAT IF A PLAYER PUTS
HIS HANDS TO HIS HEADSET TO THE
MANAGER TO CHECK, YOU WANT TO
GO, YOU DON'T THINK WE ARE
ALREADY CHECKING?
THERE SHOULD BE A PENALTY FOR
SAYING CHECK IT AND YOU ARE
WRONG.
FORTUNATELY HE DIDN'T BECAUSE I
THINK HE WAS EMBARRASSED ABOUT
BEING OUT THAT MUCH.
SOMEBODY SHOULD CHECK THAT.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
OVERTURN THAT.
THERE ARE TOO MANY THINGS IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION FOR IT TO BE
OVERTURNED.
MELANIE: REGARDLESS WHICH WAY IT
GOES, WE WILL LET YOU KNOW.
YOU ARE THERE.
YOU CAN LET US KNOW.
IT IS TOUGHER TO OVERTURN A CALL
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN MADE.
BUCK, YOU ARE 1-1.
YONDER: YOU THINK HE WAS TRYING
TO MAKE UP FOR THE PLAY EARLIER
ON IN LEFT FIELD?
BUCK: I THINK HE WAS SPECTATING
THE PLAY OUT OF THE BATTER'S BOX
AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON SECOND.
HE WAS WAITING TO SEE IF IT IS
GOING TO FALL.
MELANIE: WITH THE OUT, THAT IS
LYLE'S SECOND OUT OF THE INNING.
BUCK: I THINK HE IS -- THAT'S
NOT BAD.
YONDER: I'VE SEEN WORSE.
BUCK: YOU WOULD LIKE TO SAY THEY
ARE ALL 100%, BUT YOU WANT TO
SEE IF THE BALL IS GOING TO
FALL.
MELANIE: THIS ONE FALLS FROM
MATT THE GLOVE OF
ADOLIS GARCIA.
INTO THE BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH,
JOEY GALLO LEADS IT OFF, TRYING
TO COME BACK FROM A 9-5 DEFICIT.
>> DEEP TO CENTER.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> ONE RUN IS IN.
HERE COMES THE POTENTIAL TYING
RUN.
THE BALLGAME IS OVER!
ANOTHER SPECTACULAR DEFENSIVE
PLAY TO FINISH THIS ONE AND THE
RANGERS ESCAPE 9-8.
>> IT'S GOOD!
THREE RUN HOME RUN, ADOLIS
GARCIA, AND THE RANGERS WALK IT
OFF 7-5.
MELANIE: MAJOR LEAGUE ALL 30
CLUBS ARE DOING THEIR PART FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH THROUGH MLB
VACCINATE AT THE PLATE, A FREE
TICKET INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR
RECEIVING COVID-19 VACCINATIONS
MELANIE: FOR MORE INFO --
VACCINATIONS.
FOR MORE INFO, VISIT
MLB.COM/VACCINE.
CHECK OUT THE OAKLAND A'S
YOUTUBE CHANNEL FOR A GLIMPSE
BEHIND THE SCENES, HIGHLIGHTS,
AND LAUGHS.
LIKE AND SUBSCRIBE NOW AT
YOUTUBE.COM/ATHLETICS.
ATHLETICS STILL HOLDING ONTO
THIS ONE AFTER THEY JUMPED OUT
TO AN EARLY LEAD.
THEY HAVE NOT SCORED A RUN SINCE
THE THIRD, BUT IT WAS A BIG NINE
RUN PERFORMANCE THROUGH THOSE
FIRST THREE INNINGS.
JAKE DIEKMAN WILL TAKE OVER TO
RETIRE SERGIO ROMO, WHO GAVE UP
A HOME RUN TO ELI WHITE.
DIEKMAN STARTS OUT WITH LEFTY
JOEY GALLO, 0-2 WITH A WALK.
HE HAS HAD TWO IN THE SERIES BUT
STILL TRYING TO FIND HIS FIRST
HIT AGAINST OAKLAND.
YONDER: FOR JAKE DIEKMAN, A
TOUGH MATCHUP FOR JOEY GALLO, A
THREE-QUARTER GUY.
SLINGS THE BALL UPPER 90'S.
THIS IS NOT A FUN AT BAT FOR
JOEY GALLO.
BUCK: JOEY GALLO --
MELANIE: JOEY GALLO GETS A PITCH
ELEVATED INSIDE.
TAKE A LOOK AT STATCAST POWERED
BY GOOGLE CLOUD ON THE STRIKE
ZONE.
THE BOTTOM EDGE HAS BEEN THE
ACHILLES HEEL FOR HIM THIS YEAR
AGAINST BREAKING BALLS.
HE IS TAKING THEM ONE AFTER THE
OTHER.
26.
YONDER: I GUARANTEE HALF OF
THOSE ARE AGAINST LEFT-HANDERS
WITH NASTY SLIDERS.
THAT'S WHERE THEY GO TO.
THAT'S WHERE ALL THESE LEFTIES
GO TO, DOWN AND AWAY WITH
SLIDERS.
WHEN YOU ARE FACING A GUY LIKE
DIEKMAN WHO LOVES TO THROW THE
FASTBALL, ANY CHANCE YOU HAVE TO
PUT AWAY A POWERFUL HITTER LIKE
GALLO, LOOK TO THE SLIDER.
MELANIE: GALLO GETS A HOLD OF A
FASTBALL UP.
GET OUT, BALL.
GALLO ATTACKS JAKE DIEKMAN,
RANGER ON FORMER RANGER, AND IT
IS 9-6.
TEXAS IS THREATENING IN THE
EIGHTH.
HIS ACE OF 13 AGAINST -- HIS
EIGHTS OF 13 AGAINST LEFTIES.
YONDER: BOY, THAT BALL GOT OUT
OF HERE IN A HURRY.
THAT EXTENSION IS EXACTLY WHAT
JOEY GALLO WORKS ON.
BUCK: THAT WAS IMPRESSIVE.
OFF DIEKMAN?
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD SWING.
IT'S 9-6, YOU STILL HAVE TO GET
SIX OUTS.
IT'S GOING TO GET INTERESTING.
MELANIE: RANGERS HAVE PUSHED
FOUR RUNS IN THE FIFTH, A HOME
RUN IN THE SEVENTH, AND A HOME
RUN IN THE EIGHTH OFF JOEY
GALLO, COMING TO LIFE IN THE
BACK HALF OF THE BALLGAME.
AS THE DISCUSSION CONTINUES ON
SUBSTANCE CONTROL WITH PITCHERS
AND WHAT THEY CAN AND CAN'T USE
ON BASEBALLS, I HAD TO GET A
LAUGH ON FOR JAKE DIEKMAN.
HE IS OF THE MORE FAIR SKINNED
VARIETY, AND I COMPLETELY
RELATE.
WHEN IT CAME OUT THAT EVEN
SUNSCREEN WAS BAD, HE SAID, ARE
WE -- WAS BANNED, HE SAID, ARE
WE SURE?
I CAN'T WEAR SUNSCREEN AT ALL?
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK OUT FOR
ME.
THEY ARE UNDER THE ROOF FOR THIS
SERIES, BUT YOU HAVE TO
EMPHASIZE -- EMPATHIZE,
WONDERING HOW FAR-REACHING THAT
SUNSCREEN BAN GOES.
YONDER: PERSONALLY I'M OK WITH
GUYS WEARING SUNSCREEN AND I'M
OK WITH GUYS HAVING A LITTLE
SOMETHING TO CONTROL THE
BASEBALL.
THERE IS NOTHING SCARIER THAN
FACING DIEKMAN, WHICH I HAVE,
AND GETTING ONE IN YOUR RIBS.
YOU KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO FACE A
GUY WHO CAN GET ERRATIC AT
TIMES, WHO CAN THROW A 97 MILE
AN HOUR FASTBALL BEHIND YOUR
HEAD, AND IT'S NOT FUN.
GIVEN THE IDEA OF YOU CANNOT
HAVE ANYTHING ON YOUR HAND, FOR
ME IT BECOMES MORE OF A
STRESSFUL SITUATION FOR A
LEFT-HANDED HITTER THAN FOR
DIEKMAN HIMSELF.
WOULD YOU AGREE?
BUCK: I THINK THE PROBLEM IS
THEY TOOK AN INCH AND WENT A
MILE.
IF YOU WERE JUST TRYING TO GRIP
THE BASEBALL WHERE YOU CAN
CONTROL IT, IT WOULD BE ONE
THING, BUT PITCHERS WENT TO A
DIFFERENT LEVEL WHERE IT WAS
BEING TAUGHT IN PITCHING
PROGRAMS AND SOME ACTUAL
COACHES.
IT WAS BEING TAUGHT HOW TO
INCREASE VELOCITY AND SPIN RATE
INSTEAD OF JUST GRIPPING THE
BASEBALL.
THAT'S WHERE MLB HAD A PROBLEM.
IT WAS A LOT LIKE THINGS THAT
CAME INTO THE GAME THAT WE HAD
TO GET RID OF BECAUSE IT WASN'T
A NATURAL WAY TO INCREASE
SOMETHING.
MELANIE: TYLER GLASNOW WAS VERY
VOCAL ABOUT THAT AFTER HIS
START.
HE ENDED ON THE INJURED LIST.
HE SAID, I UNDERSTAND BATTING
CERTAIN SUBSTANCES, BUT SOME OF
US USED THE STUFF THAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN IN FAIRPLAY.
HE SAID THAT'S THE REASON HE
CANNOT GRIP THE BALL LIKE AN EGG
ANYMORE AND HE SAID HE WAS
STRESSING HIMSELF TO
OVERCOMPENSATE TO KEEP THAT
GRIP.
THEY EXPERIMENTED WITH A TACKY
BALL IN 2016.
PITCHERS WERE NOT CRAZY ABOUT
THE FEEL BECAUSE IT ALMOST FELT
SHELLACKED.
JAPAN HAS A BALL THEY MONITOR
THAT HAS AN EQUALLY DISTRIBUTED
STICKY SUBSTANCE ON IT THAT IS
THE SAME EVERY DAY FOR EVERY
PERSON AND THE PLAYERS ENJOY IT.
TAKE A LOOK HERE AT WHAT SERGIO
ROMO WAS DEALING WITH.
HE WAS A LITTLE HEATED AFTER THE
PERFORMANCE.
HE HAS IMMEDIATELY THROWN OFF
THE BELT, THE GLOVE, THE HAT,
EVERYTHING.
BUCK: THAT'S A GUY WHO JUST GAVE
UP A HOME RUN.
MELANIE: THAT MIGHT BE THE FIRST
FULL THROW DOWN WITH UMPIRES ON
A SUBSTANCE CHECK.
BUCK: I'M SURPRISED THEY DIDN'T
EJECT HIM.
THE UMPIRE IS JUST DOING HIS
JOB.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO HAVE TO DO
THAT.
I DON'T BLAME THEM.
THEY HAVE ENOUGH.
THEY HAVE CLOCKS, THIS, THAT,
REPLIED.
-- REPLAY.
THEIR JOB HAS CHANGED A LOT OVER
THE YEARS AND THE LAST THING
THEY WANT IS ANOTHER THING TO BE
IN CHARGE OF.
YONDER: I HAVE BEEN IMPRESSED
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF PLAYERS
SPEAKING OUT ABOUT THIS WILL
CHANGE.
FOR ROMO, MAYBE NOT NECESSARILY
TRYING TO SHOW UP THE UMPIRE,
BUT MAYBE SENDING A MESSAGE TO
THE LEAGUE.
FOR DIEKMAN, WE SEE THE BLAZING
FASTBALL.
BUCK: LET'S GO BACK AGAIN.
WHY DID THEY HAVE TO DO THIS?
BECAUSE THEY WENT TOO FAR WITH
IT.
ARE YOU GOING TO WAIT UNTIL THE
SEASON IS OVER?
I GUESS THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WANTED.
THEY TOOK SOMETHING THAT WAS
HELPING THEM GRIP THE BALL AND
MADE IT AN COMPETITIVE EDGE.
GO-AHEAD, I'M SORRY.
MELANIE: YOU NEVER HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE.
JAKE DIEKMAN HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
DEALING.
HE SEEMED TO BRING THE FASTBALL
BACK WITHIN THE ZONE.
BUCK: THESE ARE BIG OUTS.
THAT LAST OUT WAS HUGE, GETTING
READY TO GET AWAY FROM HIM.
EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT THINGS.
I HAVE BEEN ON THE COMPETITION
COMMITTEE.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT THE
SOLUTIONS.
WHAT SHOULD THEY HAVE DONE?
SHOULD THEY LET IT CONTINUE?
I THINK THEY SHOULD GO TO A
TACKY BALL AND HAVE A UNIVERSAL
PICTURES' -- UNIVERSAL PITCHER''
RAG BEHIND THE MOUND THAT
EVERYBODY APPROVES.
NOW EVERYBODY HAS A REASON TO
GRIP THE BALL WITHOUT A
COMPETITIVE EDGE.
IT IS 40 DEGREES AND YOU CAN'T
GRIP THE BALL.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT MLB IS
MOVING TOWARDS, BUT THEY HAD TO
DO SOMETHING IN THE MEANTIME.
MELANIE: IT WILL BE PEOPLE LIKE
YOU WHO THINK MLB HAS THE EAR
OF.
PLAYERS ARE POSITIVE THAT THEY
WANT THAT COMMUNICATION WITH THE
LEAGUE OFFICES.
DIEKMAN BLASTS ANOTHER FASTBALL
TO NICK SOLAK.
HE WORKS 10 PITCHES AGAINST ANDY
IBANEZ BEFORE HE WENT OUT WITH A
STRIKEOUT AFTER A FOUR-PITCH
HOME RUN TO JOEY GALLO.
YOU DON'T OFTEN SEE A PITCH
COUNT GET UP THAT HIGH-END THE
PITCHER IS ABLE TO WIN IT OUT.
TAGGING A FASTBALL FOUL.
YONDER: I COULDN'T AGREE WITH
YOU MORE.
I THINK THIS WHOLE MUD THING ON
THE BALL, THERE HAS TO BE A NEW
FORMULA TO THE BASEBALL RUBDOWN
SITUATION.
I DO BELIEVE NOWADAYS THERE HAS
GOT TO BE MORE OF A TECHNOLOGY
MECHANISM TO GET THESE BALLS
BETTER RUBBED AND HAVE THEM
NOT SLICK IN APRIL OR THE MIDDLE
OF OCTOBER IN A PLAYOFF RACE
WHEN IT IS COLD.
FROM THE PLAYERS' STANDPOINT, I
THINK THEY ARE NOT HAPPY WITH
THE RULE CHANGE COMING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SEASON.
BUCK: I WILL TELL YOU SOMETHING
CHAPMAN DOES THAT NOBODY ELSE
DOES.
CHAPMAN PLAYS THE DEEPEST THIRD
BASE OF ANYBODY IN BASEBALL
BECAUSE OF THE STRENGTH OF HIS
ARMS, BUT WHERE HE ALLOWS THE
SHORTSTOP TO PLAY.
IT IS 2-8 ARM STRENGTH.
HE IS A SEVEN.
NO THIRD BASEMAN PLAYS BACK
THERE.
IT'S HARD TO GET A BALL DOWN THE
LINE AGAINST HIM.
IT'S HARD TO GET A BALL IN
BETWEEN HIM AND THE SHORTSTOP.
HE HAS MORE DEPTH AND RANGE
BEING ABLE TO PLAY BACK THERE.
THERE IS ONLY ONE REASON HE CAN,
BECAUSE HE HAS THE ARMS TO MAKE
THE THROW.
MELANIE: TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SPRAY CHARTS FOR NICK SOLAK AND
YOU CAN SEE WHY IT IS IMPERATIVE
HE BE ON TOP OF THE GAME.
SOLAK WINS THE BATTLE.
TO SEE WHAT MAKES THE A'S
DEFENSE SO SPECIAL, YOU CAN'T
OVERLOOK MATT OLSON, BUT
PARTICULARLY MATT CHAPMAN.
PICKED UP IN 2014, 25TH OVERALL
SELECTION, ALREADY TWO GLOVES,
AN ALL-STAR SELECTION.
ALL OF THIS COMING BACK FROM HIP
SURGERY.
YOU DON'T SEE A TON OF PLAYERS
WITH HIP AND KNEE PROBLEMS WHO
ARE ABLE TO BE AS DEFENSIVELY
EFFECTIVE AS MATT CHAPMAN IS.
HE IS THE GUY YOU DO PUT NEXT TO
A BROOKS AND SAY THIS IS AN
UPPER ELITE LEVEL OF THIRD
BASEMAN.
YONDER: WE KNOW HE IS PLAYING
DEEP BECAUSE OF HIS GREAT
STRENGTH OF ARM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
MATT CHAPMAN.
HE HELPS THE LEFT FIELDER
BECAUSE THE LEFT FIELDER
TEMPLATE THREE STEPS BACK.
WE HAVE SEEN HOW GOOD HE IS WITH
BALLS GOING TO HAVE TOWARDS THE
FOUL LINE OR BLOOPED OVER HIM,
HOW HE GETS THEM.
THIS GUY IS THE OVERALL PACKAGE
WHEN IT COMES TO A THIRD
BASEMAN.
MELANIE: JUST A FEW ACCOLADES TO
CARRY AROUND, PUT IN YOUR HOME
OFFICE.
YONDER: HE IS SO SPECIAL.
HE CAN WOW YOU ANY GIVEN NIGHT.
THE PRESENCE HE BRINGS ANY
SINGLE DAY AT THE BALLPARK IS A
SPECIAL ONE.
THIS GUY TAKES CARE OF HIMSELF,
WANTS EVERYBODY TO SUCCEED.
WHEN I AM TALKING ABOUT THE LEFT
FIELDERS, CHRIS DAVIS, WHO
PLAYED FOR THE OAKLAND A'S IN
2017, 2018, 2019, HE HELPED THEM
A TON BECAUSE MATT CHAPMAN WOULD
PLAY SO DEEP, HE DIDN'T HAVE TO
GO AFTER BALLS ON THE FOUL
GROUND.
HE WOULD TELL MARCUS SEMIEN,
ANYTHING HIT OVER MY HEAD, I
DON'T EVEN RUN FOR IT.
MELANIE: THAT'S THE DEFENSE YOU
WANT TO SEE, AND THE
COMMUNICATION.
YOU ARE COMING INTO THIS NEWER
CLASS OF ATHLETES SO THEY ARE
STILL HAVING TO ADJUST.
A LOT MORE COLLISIONS.
YOU SEE THOSE IN WAVES
CYCLICALLY.
GUYS WORK MORE INTO THEIR
VETERAN YEARS.
HE IS SOMEONE WHO FOCUSES ON THE
LITTLE THINGS IN A DAY AND AGE
WHEN PEOPLE TRY TO BE FASTER AND
QUICKER AND STRONGER THAN
EVERYBODY ELSE.
TAKING OFF NOW GOES NICK SOLAK.
YONDER: HE GOT HIM.
HE CAME OFF THE BAG.
MELANIE: HE HAD TO TURN AROUND
AND SAY, AM I REALLY GONE HERE?
BUCK: YOU RUN THERE, YOU BETTER
BE SURE YOU ARE GOING TO BE
SAFE.
THAT'S A REAL RISK.
MELANIE: ELVIS ANDRUS AGAIN.
THIS BALLPARK IS SET UP VERY
SIMILARLY.
FOR ANDRUS, IT IS NOT MUCH OF AN
ADJUSTMENT IN HOW IT PLAYS.
BUCK: A LOT OF GUYS, YOU CALL
THEM WHITE SLIDERS, ESPECIALLY
THE GUYS WHO GO HEADFIRST.
CARRY THE TAG WITH THEM OFF THE
BAG.
WHEN YOU START THAT LATE, YOU
ARE GOING TO GO OFF THE BAG
SOME.
YONDER: SLIDING TOO LATE, IS
THAT WHAT THAT IS?
BUCK: WHEN YOU SLIDE EARLIER,
YOU CAN STAY CONNECTED TO THE
BAG.
THAT'S A RISKY PLAY AND I THINK
ANOTHER ONE THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO OVERTURN.
MELANIE: JAKE DIEKMAN'S PITCH
COUNT HAS BEEN CREEPING UP IN
HIS FIRST INNING.
27 ALREADY.
A HOME RUN, STRIKEOUT, WALK TO
SOLAK.
HE WAS BATTLING WILLIE CALHOUN
WHEN SOLAK TOOK OFF.
TRIVINO IS UP FOR THE A'S IN THE
BULLPEN, BUT ANOTHER LOOK AT
THIS PLAY.
BUCK: WHY DO THE RANGERS GET 30
SECONDS AND NEW YORK GETS TWO
MINUTES?
YONDER: THAT'S NOT FOR ME TO
ASK, OR ANSWER.
BUCK: YOU TALKING ABOUT
PRESSURE?
THE PRESSURE IS ON THE GUY IN
THE VIDEO ROOM THAT HAS 15 OR 20
SECONDS TO TELL HIM.
I TOLD OUR GUYS, I NEED TO KNOW.
IF YOU ARE WRONG 20 TIMES IN A
ROW, WE WILL FIND SOMEBODY ELSE.
MELANIE: THE FANS FEEL LATOS
WRONG, BUT HE IS OUT
NONETHELESS.
THE SECOND OUT AND JUST A THIRD
RUNNER IN 21 ATTEMPTS FOR SEAN
MURPHY TO TAKE CARE OF THIS
YEAR.
BUCK: THAT'S WHY I WAS SURPRISED
BECAUSE NOW THEY HAVE THE TYING
RUN AT THE PLATE.
I'M SURE BOB IS GOING TO MAKE A
CHANGE TO GO TO THE
RIGHT-HANDER.
MELANIE: ANOTHER LOOK JUST ON
THE MONEY, MURPHY INTO ANDRUS.
HE BEAT HIM OUT IN FRONT BY A
COUPLE OF STEPS, BUT SOLAK TIME
TO COME OUT TO THE WIDE SIDE.
YONDER: THAT'S WHY YOU KEEP THE
TAG ON.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR MIDDLE
INFIELDERS TO KEEP THE TAG ON.
WE TALKED ABOUT HOW THESE MIDDLE
INFIELDERS NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
BUSINESS.
ELVIS ANDRUS HAS BEEN KNOWN TO
DO THOSE THINGS.
MELANIE: THAT'S GOING TO DO DIE.
WE WILL BE BACK WITH LOU TRIVINO
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH, A'S
UP 9-6 OVER TEXAS.
>> HALL OF FAME, BIG-TIME RECORD
BREAKER, BUT NEVER FORGET RICKEY
HENDERSON WAS A TRAILBLAZER.
NOT SO MUCH FOR WHAT HE
ACCOMPLISHED, BUT FOR WHAT HE
THOUGHT A WHOLE GENERATION ABOUT
REAL STYLE.
>> WHO IS THIS GUY?
>> HE BROUGHT A STYLE, HE
BROUGHT THE WORD THEY USE NOW,
SWAG.
>> HE HAS IT.
>> RICKEY HENDERSON IS A FORCE.
>> RICKEY HENDERSON IS FULL OF
SUBSTANCE.
THERE IS THE SUBSTANCE AND HERE
COMES THE STYLE.
>> RICKEY GOT AWAY WITH IT
BECAUSE IT WAS GENUINE.
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO HIT ME
IN THE HEAD.
>> RICKEY WAS OK WITH THAT
BECAUSE NOW I AM STEALING SECOND
AND THIRD.
>> IT WAS ALMOST A LITTLE BIT OF
A REBEL BECAUSE HE WASN'T LIKE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE FIELD.
HE WAS RICKEY.
MELANIE: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
I AM MELANIE NEWMAN ALONGSIDE
YONDER ALONSO, BUCK SHOWALTER,
AND BRETT DOLAN.
THE RANGERS HAVE BEEN MAKING
THINGS INTERESTING AS WE CREEP
TOWARD THE FINAL OUTS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING OUT QUIETLY.
THEY LOOK THERE.
A -- THE ATHLETICS TOOK AN EARLY
9-0 LEAD.
HOME RUN TO ELI WHITE, ANOTHER
TO JOEY GALLO.
THE RANGERS TRACED JAKE DIEKMAN
BEFORE HE COULD FINISH THE
INNING.
LOU TRIVINO WILL FACE JOSE
TREVINO.
ONE WITH AN E, ONE WITH AN I.
32 GAMES ON THE SEASON.
TREVINO 0-3 TODAY ON THE PLATE.
YONDER: FOR LOU TRIVINO, THIS IS
POWER COMING RIGHT AT YOU.
NOT ONLY THE FOUR-SEAMER IN THE
ZONE, BUT THE BLAZING CUTTER
THAT HE CAN THROW TO RIGHTIES
AND LEFTIES THAT WE SAW RIGHT
THERE.
MELANIE: NATE LOWE IS ON DECK
FOR CHARLIE CULBERSON'S SPOT.
YONDER: BUCK, IN THIS TYPE OF
SITUATION WITH TWO OUTS, THIS
COULD BE THE MOST IMPORTANT
AT-BAT OF THE GAME.
MELANIE: TRIVINO -- TREVINO
DRIVES IT INTO SHALLOW CENTER
FIELD.
OAKLAND GETS OUT OF IT, BOARD
FOR THE RANGERS.
THEY TRAIL 9-6.
NINTH INNING COMING UP WITH MATT
OLSON.
>> IN SPRING TRAINING IN 1972,
REGGIE SHOWS UP WITH A FULL
BEARD.
>> WE HAD RULES, NO FACIAL HAIR.
>> AS REGGIE IS WONT TO DO,
TELLS EVERY REPORTER, I DON'T
CARE IF CHARLIE FINLEY DOESN'T
LIKE IT.
>> CHARLIE FIGURES HE IS GOING
TO USE REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY.
HE CAME UP WITH THIS MUSTACHE.
>> CHARLIE TOLD EVERYBODY IN THE
BALLCLUB, IF YOU HAVE A MUSTACHE
ON OPENING DAY, YOU GET 300
BUCKS.
>> THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A LOT
TODAY, BUT $300 WAS $300 BACK
THEN.
>> THEY THOUGHT REGGIE WOULD
SHAVE HIS BEARD OFF, BUT IT
DIDN'T WORK.
>> SOME GUYS TOLD ME NOT TO CUT
IT OFF AND TO KEEP IT.
>> I HAVE HAD IT EVER SINCE.
>> IT KEPT GETTING LONGER AND
LONGER.
I LIKE IT NOW, MY WIFE LIKES IT,
AND I WILL KEEP IT AS LONG AS I
CAN.
>> THE ONLY REASON I GREW THIS
THING WAS TO GET 300 BUCKS OUT
OF CHARLIE.
>> WE KEPT THE BEARD, THE
MUSTACHES, WE STARTED WINNING.
THAT BECAME OUR TRADEMARK.
MELANIE: WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ATHLETICS HISTORY AND SO FAR
WHAT MATT OLSON HAS BEEN ABLE TO
DO, HE DRAWS AN EERIE COMPARISON
TO THE LEGENDARY MARK MCGWIRE
THROUGH THEIR FIRST 487 CAREER
GAMES.
JUST ONE HOME RUN BEHIND MCGUIRE
-- MCGWIRE.
THE ON-BASE PERCENTAGE ALONG
WITH THE SLUGGING PERCENTAGE.
HE HAS GONE TOE-TO-TOE WITH
SOMEBODY WHO TORE UP ALMOST
EVERY PITCHER HE SAW.
OLSON GETS THINGS STARTED IN THE
NINTH.
YONDER: WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SLUGGERS IN OUR GAME, WHEN YOU
SLOG OVER .500, YOU ARE ELITE.
YOU DEPEND ON PUTTING THE TEAM
ON YOUR BACK.
MATT OLSON HAS DONE THAT
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE YEAR.
BUCK, HOW DOES IT FEEL WHEN YOU
HAVE A CELEBRITY LIKE THAT WITH
MATT OLSON?
IS IT SO EASY TO PUT HIM IN THE
LINEUP EVERY DAY KNOWING HE CAN
WIN A GAME FOR YOU EVERY NIGHT?
BUCK: YOU PUT IT WELL EARLIER.
WHEN YOU HAVE A LEFT-HANDED
HITTER THAT STAYS IN THE THREE
HOLE AGAINST A LEFT-HANDED
STARTER, IT'S IMPRESSIVE.
I LIKE THAT HE PLAYS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BALL.
HE CAN IMPACT YOUR GAME ON
NIGHTS WHEN HE DOESN'T HIT A
HOME RUN OR DRIVE IN THREE RUNS.
HE CAN WIN A GAME DEFENSIVELY.
INFIELDERS LOVE THAT HE IS GOING
TO PLAY DEFENSE.
I LOVE WHEN A GUY IS 0-4 AND
PICKS UP HIS TEAMMATES ON LOW
BALLS.
THE GAME IS PLAYED IN 90 FOOT
INCREMENTS.
HE KEEPS PEOPLE FROM GOING 90
FEET.
MELANIE: BUCK, ANOTHER QUESTION
FOR YOU AS OLSON IS GOING TO
BATTLE WITH DEMARCUS EVANS.
JORDAN LYLES COMPLETES SIX
INNINGS OF TWO-GROUND BALL.
THE GUY WHO IS GOING TO BE THE
STARTER.
OUT OF IS IT FOR WOODWARD -- HOW
TOUGH IS IT FOR WOODWARD TO PULL
HIM FROM THE START?
YOU PLAY THE GAME THAT THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN A DIFFERENT
SCENARIO HAD HE BEEN THE TRUE
STARTER, BUT YOU TRIED TO USE
YOUR BULLPEN TO GET THINGS
GOING.
BUCK: THERE IS AN OLD ADAGE.
BE CAREFUL ABOUT TELLING TRUTHS
TO HURT INNOCENT PEOPLE.
I THINK THERE IS MORE TO HIM NOT
STARTING TONIGHT THEN JUST HE
WAS TIRED BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE PITCHED HIM.
A LOT OF THINGS GO ON IN
CLUBHOUSES AND BULLPENS THAT WE
ARE NOT PRIVY TO.
CHRIS WOODWARD IS A GOOD MANAGER
AND IF HE CHOSE NOT TO PITCH
MILE, HE HAD A REAL GOOD REASON,
I WILL BET YOU.
PLAYING THE WHAT IF GAME WITH
THAT, I THINK THERE IS A MESSAGE
WHERE THEY ARE AS AN
ORGANIZATION AND WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO ESTABLISH AND THE
PEOPLE THEY ARE TRYING TO
SURROUND THEMSELVES WITH.
CHRIS YOUNG AND JON DANIELS,
THEY KNOW THERE IS A CERTAIN
TYPE OF PLAYER AND PERSON THEY
HAVE TO GET BACK TO.
MELANIE: THE PAYOFF PITCH INTO
MATT OLSON.
DIVING, AND A MISS FOR ADOLIS
GARCIA.
OLSON REACHES SAFELY AND ARRIVES
AT SECOND.
DA'S FEELING PRESSURE AS TEXAS
HAS PUSHED SIX RUNS.
THEY ARE WITHIN THREE.
GARCIA WITH A TOUGH READ.
YONDER: THAT'S HOW YOU HIT .300
IN THIS LEAGUE.
YOU BATTLE THE COUNT TO 3-2 AND
YOU CHOKE UP A LITTLE BIT.
TALK ABOUT MATT OLSON SAYING HOW
HE DOES CHOKE UP AT TIMES AND
WANTS TO BE A COMPLETE HITTER.
WE SEE A PURE HITTER GOING TO
WORK WITH HIS 18TH DOUBLE OF THE
SEASON, JUST DOING THE LITTLE
THINGS.
BUCK: WHAT'S INTERESTING TONIGHT
, WE HAVE SEEN THREE OR FOUR
OUTFIELDERS DIVE FOR BALLS.
THAT TELLS YOU HOW GOOD THE
ASTROTURF IS NOWADAYS.
YEARS AGO, IF YOU DOVE THREE
TIMES ON ASTROTURF, YOU WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE ONE OR TWO OF THEM
ON THE DISABLED LIST.
YONDER: IF YOU SEE A TEAMMATE
DIVE AND THE IMPACT THAT DOES,
YOU ARE STAYING AWAY FROM THAT.
BUCK: I THINK THEY MADE A GREAT
DECISION GOING TO ARTIFICIAL
GRASS.
IT'S SO HARD TO GET -- YOU CAN
PUT GRASS HERE, BUT THE ROOT
SYSTEM TO PLAY BASEBALL ON HIS
HARD TO DEVELOP BECAUSE OF THE
SHADOWS.
THE TURF THEY ARE MAKING TODAY
IS OUTSTANDING.
YOU CAN REALLY PATTERN YOUR TEAM
TOWARD THE FIELD YOU PLAY ON.
THAT'S WHAT CHRIS YOUNG AND
CHRIS WOODWARD ARE TRYING TO DO.
MELANIE: YOU ARE COMING UP
WEARING ESSENTIALLY MOTORCYCLE
JACKETS TO AVOID ALL SORTS OF
NASTY STUFF, DIVING ON THE
ORIGINAL TURF.
SPORTS SCIENCE HAS COME LEAPS
AND BOUNDS.
YOU SEE A LOT OF IT, ESPECIALLY
AS ADVANCED STATISTICS OPEN UP
ON THE BACK END, BECAUSE OF HOW
MUCH THEY ARE ABLE TO LOOK AT.
YONDER: WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
BUILDING A TEAM FOR THE STADIUM,
DO YOU TALK ABOUT A TEAM LIKE
THE RANGERS BEING SIMILAR TO THE
KANSAS CITY ROYALS YEARS WHERE
THEY HAD THE POWER PITCHING,
BACK END OF THE BULLPEN
DOMINANCE?
OR DO YOU TALK MORE ABOUT A
SLUGGING TEAM?
BUCK: YES AND NO BAMA -- YES AND
NO.
THOSE FIELDS WERE SO FAST.
THE TURF CAN SLOW THE GAME DOWN.
THEY FIGURED OUT HOW TO SLOW
DOWN IN TAMPA.
YOU LOOK AT THE INDOOR STADIUMS
WITH ROOFS.
TORONTO CAN'T GET BACK HOME YET.
THERE IS AN ADVANTAGE IF YOU
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
IT IS SO MUCH MORE SPONGY THAN
IT USED TO BE.
SOME PEOPLE TELL YOU IT IS
HEALTHIER TO PLAY ON THAT THAN
ON GRASS.
THE STUFF THEY ARE MAKING NOW,
THERE IS DIFFERENT COTTS, YOU
CAN SLOW THE BALL DOWN, TAKE THE
BOUNCE OUT OF IT.
I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO SEE A
CERTAIN TYPE OF PLAYER FOR THE
RANGERS THAT'S GOING TO GO
FORWARD, AND IT'S A WAY TO PUT A
DIFFERENT CLUB TOGETHER.
I THINK CHRIS YOUNG AND CHRIS
WOODWARD ARE GOING TO EMBRACE
THAT.
YONDER: THOSE ARE THE BENEFITS
OF HAVING GOOD TURF.
YOU SAVE YOUR BODY A LOT MORE.
MELANIE: BASE HIT, RAMON
LAUREANO.
THE ATHLETICS, WHO HAVE BEEN
QUIET, PUSH A DRIVE OUT TO LEFT
FIELD.
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS AGAINST
THE YOUNG DEMARCUS EVANS.
MATT OLSON ADVANCES TO THIRD.
AND A PITCH RIGHT TO THE HEART
THAT LAUREANO GETS A READ ON.
HE CERTAINLY HAS HAD A NIGHT
TONIGHT.
HIS THIRD TIME REACHING TONIGHT.
IF YOU WANT TO VOTE IN THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME, HERE
ARE YOUR OPTIONS -- ELVIS ANDRUS
AND RAMON LAUREANO GOING BACK
AND FORTH WITH EACH OTHER.
OF COURSE MATT CHAPMAN ADD MARK
CANHA AS WELL.
ANDRUS OPENING UP TONIGHT AFTER
HE HAD AN EMOTIONAL RETURN TO
TEXAS YESTERDAY.
HAD NOT PICKED UP AHEAD.
HE HAS HAD THREE ON THE EVENING.
YONDER: TALKING TO SOME PEOPLE
WITH THE A'S ABOUT RAMON
LAUREANO, A GUY WHO WANTS TO
LEARN, WHO IS A SPARK PLUG, A
GUY WHO WHEN YOU SEE HIM EVERY
DAY, YOU THINK HE PLAYS WITH A
FIREWORK DISPLAY ATTITUDE.
FOR HIM INSIDE THE CLUBHOUSE,
THIS IS A GUY WHO WANTS TO LEARN
AND LEAD, BUT MAN DOES HE BRING
IT.
HE IS EXCITING TO WATCH EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
GOING BACK TO MATT OLSON IN
REGARDS TO THE AT-BAT THAT HE
HAD, NOW YOU ARE PUTTING RUNNERS
ON AT FIRST AND THIRD.
YOU CAN PUT THE GAME OUT OF
REACH FOR THE TEXAS RANGERS.
BEING ABLE TO DO THOSE LITTLE
THINGS THROUGHOUT THE GAME GO
UNNOTICED, BUT BOB MELVIN KNOWS
EXACTLY HOW A TEAM IS
CONSTRUCTED.
MELANIE: THE ATHLETICS TRYING TO
GET A LITTLE SPACE HERE.
YONDER: GOING TO THE TURF TALK
WE WERE HAVING EARLIER, WHAT I
HAVE NOTICED WITH THE NEW TURF
IS HOW MANY PEOPLE NOWADAYS ARE
STILL WEARING CLEATS.
EARLIER IN MY DAYS, YOU WOULD GO
TO A TURF FIELD AND MAKE SURE
YOU PACK PLASTIC CLEATS BECAUSE
YOU KNEW YOU WERE GOING TO BEAT
UP YOUR KNEES, YOUR BACK.
NOWADAYS, YOU ARE SEEING MORE
GUYS PLAYING WITH JUST METALS.
IT IS A RECOGNITION TO THE
TECHNOLOGY OF TURF, BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THESE GUYS PLAY IN
WHATEVER THEY FEEL MOST
COMFORTABLE.
90% OF PLAYERS PLAY WITH CLEATS.
MELANIE: IT ADDS TO THE
CONSISTENCY.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO CHANGE THE
WAY THEY KNOW THEIR BODY IS
GOING TO FEEL, REACTING TO MAKE
THOSE PLAYS.
THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ABLE TO BUILD ON THE NEXT
THING, INSTEAD OF GOING TO A
FIELD THAT HAS A TURF WHERE YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE PLASTICS AND
CHANGE HOW YOU ARE REACTING TO
YOUR OWN ENVIRONMENT.
THAT MIGHT PUT YOU IN A FUNK.
YONDER: WHEN I WOULD WEAR TURF
CLEATS, I KNEW MY ANKLES WERE
GOING TO HURT MORE BECAUSE IT
WAS MORE PRESSURE ON YOUR FEET.
WHEN YOU HAVE CLEATS, YOU DON'T
DEMAND SO MUCH WITH THE GRIP.
THE CLEATS ARE SUPPORTING THAT
GRIP.
IT'S A NICE PLAYING FIELD.
YOU KNOW YOUR BODY WILL FEEL THE
SAME WAY RAKING UP -- WAKING UP
EVERY DAY AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT
YOU HAVE GOING INTO A GAME WITH
A TURF STADIUM IS THE SAME AS
HAVING A REGULAR SURFACE.
MELANIE: DEMARCUS EVANS HAS HAD
FOUR STRAIGHT STRIKES.
A LATE TIME CALLED AT THE PLATE
BY JED LOWRIE.
PICKED UP A WALK IN THE FIRST
INNING, STILL LOOKING FOR HIS
FIRST HIT OF THE GAME.
EVANS, A LITTLE FRUSTRATED AT
THE LATE TIME CALL.
FOR PITCHERS, YOU RUN INTO A
SITUATION OF ONCE YOU START YOUR
MOTIONS, AN ABRUPT STOPPAGE,
THAT'S WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
LITTLE INJURIES THAT CAN POP UP.
HE DROPS IN A BREAKING BALL IN
FRONT.
HE STRUCK OUT CHAD PINDER.
YONDER: I THINK THAT WAS A
LITTLE LATE.
THE UMPIRE DECIDED TO GIVE IT TO
HIM.
YOU DEFINITELY WANT TO BE
CAREFUL.
BUCK, I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THE TURF SITUATION.
WHEN IT WAS THE BAD TURF IN
TAMPA, WOULD YOU SEE A
DIFFERENCE WITH PLAYERS, HOW
THEY WOULD COME OUT OF THOSE
SERIES?
BUCK: WITHOUT A DOUBT.
BIG HIT.
MELANIE: JED LOWRIE WITH A
DIFFERENCE MAKER AS HE DRIVES
ONE INTO LEFT FIELD.
THE A'S PUSHING DOUBLE DIGITS,
AN R.B.I. SINGLE, AND IT IS 10-6
OAKLAND.
BUCK: I ALWAYS GO BACK TO CURT
SCHILLING.
THAT'S WHY YOU GOT LOWRIE, WHAT
A GREAT PIECE OF HITTING.
YOU WANT TO STAY OUT OF THE
MIDDLE OF THE FIELD BECAUSE THE
DOUBLE PLAY IS IN PLAY.
THAT'S WHY YOU ACQUIRE A PLAYER
LIKE HIM.
THAT'S A BIG RUN FOR THEM.
CURT SCHILLING USED TO TALK
ABOUT GOING INTO COLORADO AND
PITCHING.
IT WAS NOT THAT OUTING THAT
PHYSICALLY TAXED HIM, IT WAS THE
WAY HE FELT THE NEXT DAY BECAUSE
HE HAD HIS BEST FASTBALL, HIS
BEST BREAKING BALL.
THE WEAR AND TEAR OF PITCHING.
HE ALWAYS FELT HE HAD TO TORQUE
EVERY PITCH HE THREW.
THAT'S LIKE PLAYING ON THE OLD
TURF THAT WAS TOUGH ON THE
BODIES.
I DON'T SEE NEAR THE RESIDUAL
EFFECTS ON THE TURF.
TAMPA HAS A GOOD TURF, TORONTO
HAS A GOOD TURF.
THEY HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB.
SCIENCE HAS MADE THE TURF SO
MUCH BETTER.
MELANIE: PITCH GETS AWAY AND
RUNNERS CONTINUING TO APPLY
PRESSURE TO TEXAS IN THE NINTH.
THEY MOVE UP TO SECOND AND
THIRD.
IT DRAWS THE INFIELD IN.
A BIG CHASE FOR SEAN MURPHY OFF
DEMARCUS EVANS.
YONDER: THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE I DON'T NECESSARILY NEED
TO POINT MY A SWING ON A BALL.
I NEED TO GET SOMETHING UP IN
THE ZONE AND MAKE IT WHERE IT IS
THE FIRST ROUND OF BATTING
PRACTICE, WHERE YOU TRY TO HIT A
GROUND BALL TO SECOND BASE.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE SECOND BASEMAN
ALMOST BEHIND THE PITCHER, THEY
ARE ESSENTIALLY GIVING YOU A
RUN.
YOU TREAT THIS LIKE A GET A GUY
OVER SITUATION.
YOU DON'T NECESSARILY NEED TO
BRING ALL THEM IN, DON'T NEED TO
TRY FOR A HOMER, JUST PUT THE
BALL IN PLAY.
GOOD HITTERS HAVE A KNACK FOR
R.B.I.'S BECAUSE THEY DON'T TRY
TO DO TOO MUCH IN A SITUATION
LIKE THIS.
BUCK: LAUREANO IS GOING TO SCORE
ON THE GROUND BALL TO SECOND
BASE.
YOU CAN TELL BY HIS LEAD THAT HE
IS GOING ON CONTACT.
IF HE HITS A GROUND BALL TO
SECOND BASE, LAUREANO IS GOING
TO SCORE.
HE IS TOO FAR AWAY FROM HOME
PLATE.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY GOOD
DEPTH FOR THE SECOND BASEMAN
BECAUSE HE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
THROW LAUREANO OUT AT THE PLATE.
MELANIE: 2-1 PITCH, SWING,
ANOTHER DEEP TO LEFT FIELD.
OAKLAND HAS FOUND LIFE AFTER
THEY WENT QUIET FOR THE LAST
FIVE INNINGS.
THEY ARE POURING IT ON, NOW 12-6
AND A BASES CLEARING DOUBLE FOR
SEAN MURPHY.
YONDER: WHEN WE GET THE PITCH UP
IN THE ZONE, EXACTLY WHAT THE
DOCTOR ORDERED.
HE WAS ABLE TO CONNECT, NOT
TRYING TO DO TOO MUCH.
ANY GUY TRYING TO DO TOO MUCH
CAN EASILY ROLL OVER TO THIRD
BASE.
FOR HIM, HE WAS ABLE TO GET THE
BALL ON TOP.
MELANIE: HERE IS OUR FAVORITE
FOGHORN IN THE DUGOUT, SEAN
MANAEA.
BUCK: HASN'T SAID ONE WORD, BUT
COMMUNICATES BETTER THAN ANYBODY
IN THE DUGOUT.
I GOT ONE FOR YOU.
YOU ARE THE MANAGER OF OAKLAND.
YOU HAVE BROUGHT IN YOUR CLOSER
TO KEEP FROM GETTING THE TYING
RUN TO THE PLATE.
NOW THE SCORE HAS GONE 12-6.
DO YOU BRING SOMEBODY ELSE IN
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS NOT PITCHED
FOR 4, 5 DAYS.
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE ANYBODY
BEHIND THAT GUY.
OR DO YOU STAY WITH THE CLOSER
AND LET HIM FINISH THE GAME?
THE DECISIONS NEVER STOP.
BOB MELVIN IS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IF HE CAN SAVE SOME WEAR AND
TEAR ON HIS CLOSER.
YONDER: I THINK THAT'S THE RIGHT
CALL.
STAY AWAY FROM THE CLOSER IF
IT'S NOT A SAVE SITUATION.
BUCK: THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT NOW.
YONDER: TIME AND TIME AGAIN, YOU
BRING A GUY IN WHO HAS NOT
GOTTEN HIS WORK DONE AND IT
MIGHT BE HIS WORST OUTING OF THE
YEAR.
BOB MELVIN HAS BEEN IN THIS
SITUATION BEFORE.
GIVE A CLOSER HIS ROLE, CLOSING
OUT GAMES THAT ARE NEEDED THE
MOST.
IF IT IS A 10 GAME SPAN WHERE
YOU DON'T PITCH, THEY MIGHT USE
YOU FOR 10 GAMES IN A ROW.
WHEN YOU HAVE YOUR BEST WEAPON
AND YOU CAN KEEP HIM FRESH,
TOMORROW YOU CAN THROW A FLAT
GROUND, FOR ALL I CARE.
FOR ME I THINK YOU SAVE YOUR
CLOSER AT ALL TIMES BECAUSE WHEN
YOU DO NEED HIM, YOU ARE PRAYING
HE COMES INTO THE GAME BECAUSE
THAT'S YOUR BEST WEAPON.
BUCK: THE OTHER PART OF THAT IS
HE HAS NOT PITCHED SINCE FRIDAY.
HE THREW VERY FEW PITCHES LAST
INNING.
BAXLEY DECISION.
DO THEY TRUST THE GUY COMING IN
THAT THEY DON'T IMPLODE AND GIVE
UP SIX RUNS?
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
I THINK IF THEY SCORE ANOTHER
RUN, THEY WILL TAKE HIM OUT.
IF IT STAYS 12-6, THEY MIGHT LET
HIM FINISH.
WHAT GETS RELIEVERS IS THE
UPS, NOT NECESSARILY THE
PITCHERS.
WE CALL IT SOMETHING ELSE I
WON'T SAY ON LIVE TV.
THAT'S WHY GUYS ARE STARTING
PITCHERS AND GUYS ARE RELIEVERS.
YOU TAKE YOUR CLOSER AND YOU GET
HIM UP TWO TIMES, THAT'S TAXING.
YONDER: BOB MELVIN DOES SUCH A
GOOD JOB WITH THAT.
I REMEMBER LOOKING AT HIS
SCORECARD.
MELANIE: THEY ARE STILL DRIVING
OFF DEMARCUS EVANS.
BASE HIT OUT INTO RIGHT FIELD.
COMING ON NOW, 13-6 OAKLAND.
BOLT ARRIVES SAFELY AT SECOND
BASE.
IT IS NOT DEMARCUS EVANS.
HIS 32ND PITCH OF THE INNING
AFTER TEXAS HAD BATTLED TO COME
WITHIN THREE.
THE A'S HAVE DOUBLED WHAT THE
RANGERS WERE ABLE TO PUT ON THE
BOARD AS YOU LOOK AT BOLT
DRIVING HIS FIRST HIT OF THE
SERIES.
YONDER: THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO
DO WITH A FASTBALL DOWN THE
MIDDLE, STAYING SHORT THROUGH
THE BASEBALL, USING YOUR LOWER
HALF.
MELANIE: THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
LINE FOR DEMARCUS EVANS THIS
EVENING.
CHRIS WOODWARD KNOWS HE NEEDS TO
GET HELP FROM HIS ROOKIES.
WE WILL BE BACK WITH THE NEW
PITCHER IN THE TOP OF THE NINTH,
A'S AND RANGERS.
>> THE TEXAS RANGERS, LAST IN
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE WEST, WITH A
NEW MANAGER, BILLY MARTIN.
>> BOB SHORT UTTERED THOSE
FAMOUS WORDS, I WOULD FIRE MY
GRANDMOTHER TO HIRE BILLY
MARTIN.
>> THE MANAGER, BILLY MARTIN.
>> THAT 1974 SEASON WAS AMAZING.
>> THEY HAD A SONG, THE
TURNAROUND GANG.
>> ♪ THERE IS A MAN NAMED BILLY
MARTIN
WHO TURNED THIS TEAM AROUND
HE GAVE THEM STRENGTH AND TAUGHT
THEM TO FIGHT ♪
>> ♪ THEY CALL THEM THE
TURNAROUND GANG
BECAUSE THAT'S JUST WHAT THEY
DID ♪
IT GOES ON FROM THERE.
>> YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT BILLY
HAD COME FROM ODESSA.
HE HAD A LOT OF COWBOY IN HIM.
HE IS OUT THERE GOING NUTS ON
THE FIELD, OFF THE FIELD AT
TIMES.
PEOPLE LOVED IT.
>> THIS WAS A TEAM THAT LOST
OVER 100 GAMES THE YEAR BEFORE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE
BATTLING FOR A PLAYOFF SPOT.
>> WE FELT IF WE WENT INTO A
SERIES WITH A TEAM WE WERE EVEN
WITH, WE HAD A BETTER CHANCE TO
WIN BECAUSE HE WAS OUR MANAGER.
>> THE LEGEND OF SEAN DURFEE.
THESE GUYS HAVE OPENED.
RUNS HAVE COME THROUGH.
MELANIE: I THINK I'M GOING TO
MAKE SEAN MANAEA'S SCREAM FROM
THE DUGOUT MY NEW ALARM CLOCK.
IF THAT DOESN'T GET YOU MOVING,
I DON'T KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO
COME UP AT ALL.
THEY HAVE A THOUGHT MORE -- THEY
HAVE A THUMB WAR GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
KEEPING IT LOOSE IN THE DUGOUT.
THAT MIGHT BE THE NEXT QUESTION,
WHO IS THE BEST THUMB WAR
ATHLETE IN THE DUGOUT?
PAXTON COMES ON TO SHELL OUT
DEMARCUS EVANS.
HIS ONLY TWO OUTS CAME ON
STRIKEOUTS.
THE A'S HAVE 15 HITS THIS
EVENING.
13 RUNS TIES THERE SEASON-HIGH
AS THIS WENT 13-6 PRETTY QUICKLY
IN THE NINTH.
SPENCER PATTON, JUST HIS SEVENTH
APPEARANCE ON THE SEASON.
SIX WHAT ONE PRODUCT OF SOUTH
ILLINOIS -- 6'1" PRODUCT OF
SOUTH ILLINOIS.
HE INHERITS THE RUNNER AT SECOND
BUT HAS TWO OUTS TO WORK WITH.
YONDER: THE 33-YEAR-OLD HAS
PITCHED WELL.
HE IS A FASTBALL-SLIDER TYPE OF
GUY.
LOVES THE SLIDER AND HAS A GOOD
ONE.
IT'S DEFINITELY A PLUS PLUS
PITCH.
MELANIE: 13-6 AND FIRES IN A
STRIKE.
YONDER: I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE PITCHING CHANGE.
IT WAS A BAD SCENARIO.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IN REGARDS TO A RULE
CHANGE RIGHT AWAY?
BUCK: YEAH, I GOT A RULE CHANGE.
WHEN A GUY CAN'T GET ANYBODY
OUT, HE SHOULDN'T GET CHECKED.
YOU THINK IF I HAD SOMETHING, I
WOULD HAVE USED IT?
DID YOU NOTICE I COULDN'T GET
ANYBODY OUT AND YOU ARE CHECKING
ME?
COME ON, MAN.
THAT FALLS UNDER THE COME ON,
MAN CATEGORY.
I'M DONE.
YONDER: IT IS A GREAT RULE
CHANGE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A TALK WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
YOU GO OUT THERE AND GIVE IT UP
AND DO YOUR THING, HAVE A
SLURPEE AND GO HOME.
THERE IS NO NEED TO CHECK A GUY
WHEN HE HAS BEEN GETTING
CRUSHED.
BUCK: CAN YOU IMAGINE?
WE ARE GOING TO CHECK TREVOR
BAUER WHEN HE DOES NOT GET OUT
IN THE FIRST INNING.
HOW DOES THAT GO?
MELANIE: IT MIGHT GO BETTER FOR
SPENCER PATTON.
A STRIKEOUT FINALLY PUTS THE
NINTH INNING TO BAT AGAINST THE
ATHLETICS, BUT THEY HAVE MADE
QUITE A HILL FOR THE RANGERS TO
CLIMB BACK ON TOP OF, BLASTING
INTO THE NEW SEASON-HIGH 15 HIT
WE WILL SEE WHAT THE RANGERS CAN
PUT TOGETHER WHEN WE COME BACK
WITH THE FINAL THREE OUTS.
>> GLOBE LIFE FIELD WAS NOT ONLY
BUILT IN TEXAS, THE BALLPARK WAS
BUILT FOR TEXAS AND WITH TEXAS.
FROM LOCAL SUPPORT TO MATERIALS
SOURCED FROM THE LONE STAR STATE
, LIKE BRICK, STEEL, AND
LIMESTONE.
IT'S NO WONDER THAT IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL NEW HOME OF THE TEXAS
RANGERS, THE ART WAS CREATED FOR
TEXAS AND BY TEXANS.
WELCOME TO THE GLOBE LIFE FIELD
ART COLLECTION.
WE WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO A FEW OF THESE TALENTED
TEXANS.
EACH WILL TELL YOU ABOUT THEIR
CREATIVE PROCESS AND HOW IT
FEELS TO BE PART OF THIS
PROCESS.
YOU WILL ALSO GET A GLIMPSE INTO
THE MAKING OF THE ART AND THE
STORY BEHIND IT.
THERE IS NO BETTER WAY TO
EXPERIENCE THE ART THAN TO SEE
IT IN PERSON.
UNTIL THEN, THIS SERIES INVITES
YOU TO GET TO KNOW THE ARTISTS
AND THEIR WORK THAT IS PROBABLY
PART OF THE GLOBE LIFE FIELD ART
COLLECTION -- THAT IS PRO
UDLY PART OF THE GLOBE LIFE
FIELD ART COLLECTION.
MELANIE: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THE NEXT MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
JUNE 30, MARINERS AND BLUE JAYS.
FRIDAY, JULY 9, THERE MIGHT BE
SOME FIREWORKS.
REDS AT BREWERS AS EACH OF THESE
TWO HAVE HAD A LITTLE BIT TO
WORK WITH THIS YEAR.
CERTAINLY SOME EXCITING MATCH
AHEAD.
THE MARINERS ARE JUST GETTING IN
THE GROOVE.
THE BLUE JAYS, KIND OF AVENUE
AND FLOW -- KIND OF EBB AND
FLOW.
THEY GOT SCUFFED UP BY THE
YANKEES.
IT HAS BEEN 14 RUNS FOR THE
ATHLETICS, FOUR OF THEM IN THE
NINTH INNING.
THEY WILL NOT BRING LOU TRIVINO
BACK OUT AFTER HE GOT THE FINAL
OUT IN THE EIGHTH INNING.
YONDER: IT'S INTERESTING WITH
THAT DECISION.
HE HAD A CHANCE TO GET A SAVE.
WITH THE CONVERSATION WE SAW
EARLIER WITH BOB MELVIN AND THE
PITCHING COACH, WHAT LED INTO
THAT?
BUCK: THEY ARE ASKING, IF HE
THROWS ANOTHER INNING, CAN HE
PITCH TOMORROW?
IF WE CAN'T KEEP THEM FROM
SCORING SEVEN RUNS BEFORE WE CAN
GET THREE OUTS, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE VERY GOOD OVER A SEASON.
IF HE FACES THREE OR FOUR MORE
HITTERS, HE WON'T BE ABLE TO
PITCH TOMORROW.
IF THAT'S WHAT THE PITCHING
COACH IS TELLING YOU, YOU MAKE
THIS MOVE.
NOW YOU HAVE EVERYBODY READY.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY PEOPLE
WOULD LET THE CLOSER FINISHED
THE GAME.
COSTING HIM A SAVE?
WE ARE TRYING TO WIN THE
PENNANT.
I GUARANTEE THAT'S HOW BOB WILL
EXPLAIN IT.
WE ARE TRYING TO KEEP YOU AROUND
FOR THE LONG HAUL AND WE NEED TO
WIN TOMORROW NIGHT.
TAKING YOU OUT GIVES US A BETTER
CHANCE TO WIN TONIGHT AND
TOMORROW.
MELANIE: THEY GO TO DALE
ESQUERRA -- THEY GO TO GUERRA.
YONDER: BOB MELVIN DOES SUCH A
GOOD JOB WITH THEIR BULLPEN.
THIS GUY PUT A COLORCODE ON EACH
BULLPEN GUY THAT WILL GET UP,
GREEN, YELLOW, AND RED.
ANY TIME HE WOULD CALL SOMEBODY
UP TO GET LOOSE, HE WOULD PUT A
YELLOW MARK ON HIS NAME.
HE WOULD CHECK WITH GUYS THE
NEXT DAY DURING BATTING PRACTICE
AND LET YOU KNOW, I GOT YOU UP
TWICE, THREE TIMES, YOU ARE OFF
TODAY.
I WOULD RATHER USE A POSITION
PLAYER.
THAT'S WHAT I LOVED ABOUT HIM.
HE TOOK CARE OF THE BULLPEN AS
MUCH AS HE DID THE POSITION
PLAYERS.
IT WAS ALL THE RESPECT FOR THE
POSITION GUYS WHEN IT WAS A 10-0
GAME.
YOU WANTED TO DO YOUR JOB BUT
YOU UNDERSTOOD BOB MELVIN WAS
TAKING CARE OF YOU.
MELANIE: WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW
MUCH BULLPENS ARE HAVING TO BE
GUYS THAT FILL THAT STRETCH,
THEY HIT MORE INNINGS THAN 2020,
AND YOU CAN'T GO TO THE STARTERS
TO HAVE COMPLETE GAMES ANYMORE.
YONDER: VERY RARELY DID YOU SEE
BOB MELVIN GET YOU UP ONCE AND
IF HE WOULD GET YOU UP THE
SECOND TIME AND NOT PUT YOU IN
THE GAME.
THAT SAYS A LOT BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING WORSE FOR A BULLPEN GUY
THAT BECOME BACK AFTER A WIN OR
A LOSS AND COME INTO THE
CLUBHOUSE WITH A SAD FACE.
THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THAN A
BULLPEN GUY LETTING YOU KNOW, I
GOT UP THREE TIMES AND DIDN'T
COME INTO THE GAME.
MELANIE: ISIAH KINER-FALEFA HAS
A POP-UP TO THE MAN HE REPLACED,
ELVIS ANDRUS, WHO GETS CHEERS
FROM THE FANS.
HE HAS BEEN WELCOME BACK, HIS
FIRST TIME BACK IN TEXAS WITH A
CROWD.
DA'S WITH A BIG 13-6 LEAD.
A MAN WITH A HOME RUN ON THE
EVENING, ELI WHITE, LOOKING TO
GIVE HIS NUMBERS A BOOST.
BUCK: YOU THINK THIS GUY IS
TRYING TO GET HIS FOURTH KNOCK
IN A 13-6 GAME?
MELANIE: HE SWINGS AND IT'S A
SQUIB.
MATT CHAPMAN RECOVERS.
THE THROW IS IN TIME.
THE STELLAR CORNERS FOR OAKLAND
TRYING TO PUT THE FINAL OUT.
CHRIS WOODWARD HAS THE STOP SIGN
UP FOR A BRIEF MOMENT AS THEY
TAKE A LOOK BACK, DEBATING IF
THEY REPLAY THE TENTATIVE FINAL
OUT.
AND THEY WILL NOT.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE BALLGAME
FOR THE A'S.
THEY TAKE IT 13-6 AND EVEN THE
SERIES.
TAKE A LOOK HERE AT THAT BALL AS
IT TOOK A SHORT HOP OVER.
AWKWARD BOUNCE.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT WITH MATT CHAPMAN.
HE IS ON THE MONEY.
THE BIG STRETCH FROM MATT OLSON.
HE HAD TO PLAY THAT A LITTLE
AWKWARDLY.
AND THEY GET EVERYTHING TAKEN
CARE OF.
WE ARE GOING TO HEAD INTO THE
STATE FARM POSTGAME SHOW.
ATHLETICS EVEN THE SERIES, A 15
HIT NIGHT AND A COUPLE HOME RUNS
ALONG THE WAY.
SEAN MANAEA IS STOKED.
WELCOME TO THE POSTGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
OAKLAND STARTED THIS ONE STRONG
WITH NINE RUNS.
THEY FINISH STRONG, COMING BACK
WITH A FINAL FOUR IN THE NINTH.
IT WAS A BULLPEN DAY FOR TEXAS.
JORDAN LYLES WENT FOR SIX
INNINGS IN THE MIDDLE.
YOU SAW THE A'S GO QUIET AND
THEN FIND A RESURGENCE.
ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
THE A'S COMING BACK ONCE AGAIN.
WHAT IS IT LIKE TO GO THROUGH
THAT LULL WHERE YOU HAVE A BIG
OUTBURST IN THE FIRST COUPLE OF
INNINGS, YOU START TO SEE A TEAM
CHIP, AND YOU COME BACK?
BUCK: EVERYBODY THINGS THAT WAS
A CAKEWALK.
IT WAS VERY CLOSE GETTING BACK
INTO THAT GAME.
I KNOW IT IS 9-0, BUT ONE OF
YOUR BIGGEST JOBS AS A MANAGER
IS NEVER ASSUME ANYTHING.
YOU CAN'T TAKE ANYTHING FOR
GRANTED, ESPECIALLY AT THIS
LEVEL WHERE LEADS CAN EVAPORATE.
EVERYBODY IS A HOME RUN THREAT.
YOU ARE AT 9-0 IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES, YOU ARE GOING TO WIN.
THE BIG LEAGUES, YOU BETTER STAY
ON TOP OF IT.
11 PITCHERS TONIGHT.
THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO STEM THE TIDE OF THE
OFFENSE.
MELANIE: THE OFFENSE COULD NOT
BE STEMMED FOR THE ATHLETICS.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME GOES
TO THE MAN WHO HIT THE FIRST ONE
OUT OF THE PARK, MATT CHAPMAN,
HAVING AN ABSOLUTE DAY.
YONDER, THAT MAY HAVE BEEN YOUR
PICK OF THE DAY.
40%.
MATT CHAPMAN.
THE PLAYER OF THE GAME WILL JOIN
US NOW.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS GAME TWO OF
THE SERIES, BUT THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
YOU GET A TROPHY IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE SEASON.
MATT: IT'S A LOT HEAVIER THAN I
THOUGHT IT WAS.
MELANIE: TAKE US THROUGH THE
FIRST INNING, SETTING THE TONE
OF THE BALLGAME.
YOU BLISTERED A HOME RUN OFF A
GUY WHO CAME INTO A SPOT START
SITUATION ANNOUNCED EARLIER
TODAY.
MATT: WE WERE NOT SURE HOW LONG
HE WAS GOING TO GO BUT WE KNOW
HE HAS GOOD STUFF.
HE HAS THE GOOD FASTBALL
WORKING.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO BE SHORT.
WITH THE VELO, I WAS JUST TRYING
TO GO TO THE FASTBALL.
I WAS KIND OF SELLING OUT TO THE
HEATER AND GOT A GOOD SWING AND
WAS ABLE TO PUT US ON THE BOARD
EARLY.
IT'S NICE TO JUMP OUT AHEAD,
ESPECIALLY AFTER A LOSS LAST
NIGHT.
NICE TO GET SOME MOMENTUM.
BUCK: DO YOU FIND YOU HAVE TO
CONFIDENTLY MAKE ADJUSTMENTS --
IT WAS INTERESTING THE HOME RUN
YOU HIT WAS A BALL, BELOW THE
STRIKE ZONE, BUT YOU GOT GREAT
EXTENSION.
PITCHING FOR GUYS LIKE YOU, YOU
EXTENDED YOUR ARMS.
MATT: DEFINITELY.
THAT PITCH WAS DOWN, OUT OF HIS
HAND.
IT WAS HARD TO TELL IF IT WAS
GOING TO BE BELOW THE ZONE.
HE WAS WORKING ME IN THE PITCH
BEFORE AND I WAS ABLE TO MAKE
THE ADJUSTMENT.
WITH HOW HARD THESE GUYS ARE
THROWING, YOU HAVE GOT TO STAY
SHORT AND LET THE VELO DO THE
WORK FOR YOU.
YONDER: HOW IMPORTANT HAS IT
BEEN TO HAVE NOT ONLY CANHA AT
THE TOP OF THE ORDER, PROVIDING
THE WAY HE SEES THE AMOUNT OF
PITCHES, GETTING YOURSELF,
OLSON, AND THE REST OF THE
GROUP, TO PUT THAT GAME UP TO
PAR WITH WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
FIRST INNING?
HE WAS ABLE TO WORK THAT COUNT
AND THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW, YOU
WERE BANGING HIM FOR A HOMER.
MATT: WHAT HE DOES IS AMAZING
EVERY DAY.
HE FLIES UNDER THE RADAR A
LITTLE BIT, BUT HE IS ALWAYS
TAKING BRO AT-BATS.
HE CONTROLS THE ZONE AND DOESN'T
STRIKEOUT MUCH.
WITH HIS ABILITY TO GET ON BASE
AND GIVE A GOOD LOOK AT PITCHERS
EARLY IN THE GAME, GIVE ME TIME
TO GET MY TIMING DOWN, SEE HOW
HE IS PITCHING A RIGHT-HANDER
BEFORE ME.
OLSON HAS BEEN DOING A LOT OF
DAMAGE THIS YEAR.
MARKS SETS THE TONE.
IT IS NICE TO HAVE A GUY AT THE
TOP OF THE LINEUP AND THROUGH
THE LINEUP WHO HAVE BEEN PUTTING
TOGETHER GOOD AT-BATS.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
WIN A LOT OF GAMES.
MELANIE: MATT, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
ENJOY THE YOUTUBE FAN POLE
TROPHY.
MASSIVE WIN.
MATT: ABSOLUTELY, YOUTUBE PLAYER
OF THE GAME.
THANKS, FANS.
MELANIE: TAKE A LOOK.
THE 10 GAME HITTING STREAK
CONTINUES FOR MATT CHAPMAN.
39 AT-BATS, 14 HE HAS PICKED UP
HITS, BOOSTING HIMSELF TO ACT
.359 AVERAGE.
CONTINUING TO TEAR THINGS UP.
THE OAKLAND A'S TOP HALF OF THE
LINEUP GOT TO EVERYBODY THE
RANGERS SENT TODAY AS THEY TAKE
HOME APLENTY MORE TO LOOK AT WHE
COME BACK ON THE POSTGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY STATE FARM.
13-6, A'S TAKE STATE FARM -- A'S
TAKE GAME TWO.
>> WHY CAN'T YOU TRUST
GEOGRAPHERS?
>> BECAUSE THEY TRAVEL TOO MUCH?
>> THAT'S A FAKE LAUGH.
>> WHAT SOUND DOES A DRAFT MAKE?
THAT'S A GOOD SOUND.
>> I'M SWEATING.
>> WHAT'S A SIEGEL MAKE WHEN HE
EATS A BAD FISH?
>> [SEAGULL CALL]
>> HE IS CHOKING ON A FISH.
>> HOW BIG IS THE FISH?
>> A REALLY BAD MINNOW.
>> A WALRUS WITH A BAD TO --
BAD TUMMY.
>> I'M DONE.
I CAN'T DO A WALRUS.
MELANIE: ANOTHER LOOK AT THE
STUNNING GLOBE LIFE FIELD
ENJOYING ITS FIRST SEASON WITH
FANS IN THE STANDS.
MAYBE NOT THE WAY THE FANS HOPE
IT WOULD TURN OFF -- TURN OUT AS
THE A'S KNOCK OUT THE RANGERS
13-6, 15 HITS ALONG THE WAY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE REST OF
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
FIRST, WHAT A ANDER0FUL
WORLD.
THE TOP RATED PROSPECT KNOCKS A
HOME RUN ALONG THE WAY.
BYRON BUXTON'S WOES CONTINUE,
BACK ON THE INJURED LIST.
JAVY BAEZ LOSES TRACK OF OUTS
WHILE HE IS RUNNING THE BASE
PATH AND HE GETS BENCHED FOR
DOING SO.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE SEEN A
LOT LATELY.
THE YANKEES HAVE BEEN ATOP THE
LEADERBOARD WHEN IT COMES TO
BASERUNNING MISTAKES.
BUCK, WE GOT TO GO TO YOU.
WHEN YOU SEE A GUY NOT KEEPING
UP WITH OUTS.
BUCK: THE PROBLEM IS HE HAS PUT
HIS MANAGER IN A TOUGH POSITION.
IF YOU DON'T DO SOMETHING, YOU
ARE TELLING EVERYBODY THAT'S OK.
I THOUGHT THE MANAGER HAD A
GREAT RESPONSE, JUST NEED TO GET
SOMEBODY IN THERE.
HE WAS JOGGING TO START WITH AND
LATER ON THE STARTING PITCHER
THREW A BALL TO THE PLATE.
HE NEVER EVEN TOOK A LEAD.
IT DIDN'T SEEM LIKE HE WAS
INTERESTED.
IF YOU CAN'T CONCENTRATE, YOU
NEED TO LET YOUR MANAGER KNOW.
TO PUT YOUR TEAMMATES IN A
POSITION BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
IT PUTS YOUR TEAMMATES IN THE
POSITION OF DOING SOMETHING.
THE WHOLE STORY IS ABOUT THAT
INSTEAD OF THE CUBS ARE PLAYING
GOOD, COMPETITIVE BASEBALL.
LOOK IN THE MIRROR BECAUSE YOU
HAVE NOBODY TO BLAME BUT
YOURSELF.
MELANIE: WE ALWAYS KNOW WE ARE
GOING TO GET HOW YOU REALLY
FEEL.
WANDER FRANCO COMES UP.
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS KID.
THAT IS MASSIVE PRESSURE.
HE DESTROYS A HOME RUN TO TIE
THE GAME IN THE FIFTH INNING
AGAINST THE RED SOX.
THESE TWO ARE BATTLING IT OUT
FOR THE TOP SPOT.
IS THE PRESSURE OFF NOW THAT YOU
HAVE DELIVERED A BIG HOME RUN ON
YOUR FIRST DAY?
YONDER: THE KID WAS BORN IN
2001.
THAT'S ENOUGH PRESSURE COMING
INTO THE LEAGUE AT AN EARLY AGE.
NOT ONLY JUST A HOMER, BUT A
GAME TYING HOMER, A GO-AHEAD
HOMER.
COMING UP AND HAVING THE FIRST
AT-BAT IN THE BIG LEAGUES, IT IS
VERY NERVE-RACKING FOR HIM.
HE WAS ABLE TO CALM HIS NERVES
DOWN.
TAMPA BAY IS WANTING ALL OF
WANDER FRANCO.
THEY WANT HIM TO SUCCEED, THEY
WANT HIM TO CARRY THEM.
THE FANS WANT HIM TO BE A BIG
PART OF WHAT IS GOING ON.
MELANIE: HE CAME ON THE FIELD IN
A BIG WAY.
THAT WAS A LOOK AROUND THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
STILL A LOT MORE TO LOOK AT.
WE WILL TAKE A LOOK AT OUR OWN
GAME, SOME HIGHLIGHTS FOR THE
A'S, 13-6 OVER THE RANGERS.
>> A LEADOFF WALK FOR TAYLOR
HEARN.
IT DOESN'T GET ANY EASIER.
MATT CHAPMAN, A NINE-GAME
STREAK.
HE TEES THIS ONE OFF TO RIGHT
CENTER FIELD.
ADOLIS GARCIA LEAVES AT THE
WALL.
MATT CHAPMAN GETS IT STARTED
WITH A TWO-RUN BLAST.
>> USING HIS LEGS, HE WAS ABLE
TO PUT A GOOD FASTBALL DOWN IN
THE ZONE.
>> THAT'S THE LINE FOR TAYLOR
HEARN THIS EVENING.
MANAGER CHRIS WOODWARD IS GOING
TO THE BULLPEN IN THE FIRST.
ELVIS ANDRUS, HIS FIRST SINCE
RETURNING TO TEXAS.
THE A'S KEEP PILING IT ON.
>> A FLY TO DEEP RIGHT CENTER.
GARCIA BACK AT THE TRACK WILL
WATCH IT FLY.
LAUREANO BLASTS A TWO-RUN HOME
RUN TO RIGHT CENTER.
THE A'S LEAD 7-0 IN THE SECOND.
LAUREANO'S 13TH HOME RUN.
>> SOMEBODY HAS TO BE TOLD, YOU
HAVE GOT TO GIVE US SOME
INNINGS.
THE WAY THIS IS GOING, VERY
HAPPY FOR THE ATHLETICS.
SOMEBODY WANTS TO PUT A RUN
DIFFERENTIAL.
ARCO ATHLETICS UP 7-0.
TWO RUNS, HOME ON THAT.
THE A'S ARE POURING IT ON.
9-0 OAKLAND IN THE THIRD.
IT'S A RIP FOR WILLIE CALHOUN.
THE RANGERS MAY FINALLY BE
GETTING ON THE BOARD.
COMING AROUND TO SCORE.
TEXAS WITH AN ANSWER.
NICK SOLAK REACHED ON THE HIT BY
PITCH.
WILLIE CALHOUN ON THE LEFT SIDE
WITH AN R.B.I. DOUBLE.
DAYBREAK ON THE BOARD.
IT'S A 9-1 BALLGAME.
ARCO IF YOU ARE THE HEADER AND
YOU GET THAT DOUBLE, YOU WANT
THAT GUY IN THE SAME WAY YOU
WANT A RUN.
I ONLY SCORE FOR MY FRIENDS.
THE GOAL IS TO SCORE RUNS.
MELANIE: THEY ARE PLAYING THE
CORNER.
CHARLIE CULBERSON UP THE RIGHT
SIDE AND THE RANGERS HAVE TWO IN
THE INNING.
WILLIE CALHOUN COMES HOME.
TWO EXTRA BASES GIVEN OUT BY
COLE IRVIN IN THE FIFTH.
HE HAS TWO OUTS BUT A RUNNER AT
THIRD.
THIS ONE DROPS IN FOR A BASE
HIT.
IT EVADES CANHA.
CULBERSON WALKS HOME AND WILL
HOLD UP AT SECOND BASE.
THREE DOUBLES IN THE INNING.
ELI WHITE HAS GONE BACK TO BACK
IN PLATE APPEARANCES.
9-3, A'S STILL WITH A
BIG-LEAGUE.
IT IS A HIT PARADE OFFER URBAN
IN THE FIFTH INNING.
HERE COMES ELI WHITE AND THE
RANGERS ARE FINDING THEIR GROOVE
AGAINST COLE IRVIN.
ADELL THIS GARCIA, HIS FIRST HIT
OF THE GAME.
IT GOES FOR AN R.B.I., 9-4.
A BIG ONE FOR ELI WHITE.
DON'T EVEN TRY TO GET THIS ONE.
IT'S AN UPPER DECK SHOT.
ELI WHITE WITH A MASSIVE BLAST.
TOUCH THEM ALL.
THEY ARE WITHIN FOUR.
9-5.
THREE-HIT PERFORMANCE FROM WHITE
AND HE KEEPS ELEVATING ONE AFTER
THE NEXT.
YONDER: HE IS TURNING 27 ON
SATURDAY, BUT THIS IS A
PRE-GIFT.
AN ABSOLUTE BOMB.
MELANIE: 440 FEET.
AND YOU KNOW THAT IS A NEW PARK
SO THERE ARE NOT A LOT OF NAMES
ON THE UPPER DECK LIST YET.
THEY WERE NOT DONE.
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH
INNING, JAKE DIEKMAN COMES ON,
THE LEFTY TO FACE THE LEFTY.
GALLO LOOKING FOR HIS FIRST HIT
AND IT WAS MAMMOTH.
OUT OF HERE AGAIN.
THE TEXAS RANGERS FIND THEIR
SECOND HOME RUN, CUT THE LEAD
9-6 AND THINGS WERE LOOKING UP.
THE TOP OF THE NINTH, DEMARCUS
EVANS TAKES OVER AND IT BECAME A
HIT PARADE FOR THE A'S, BLOWING
THE GAME OPEN.
A RUN ALREADY IN AND SEAN MURPHY
DOUBLES TWO MORE.
TWO BATTERS LATER, SKYE BOLT
DRIVES IN MURPHY WITH ANOTHER
DOUBLE.
11-6.
DEOLIS GUERRA ON FOR THE BOTTOM
OF THE NINTH.
A WONKY PLATE AT THIRD, BUT NO
PROBLEM FOR THE A'S.
THEY CONNECT CORNER TO CORNER,
SECURE THE WIN, AND TAKE A 13-6
VICTORY.
LET'S LOOK AT STATCAST POWERED
BY GOOGLE CLOUD AND THE SPRAY
CHART OF OAKLAND HITS.
15, A NEW HIGH.
THE FIRST THREE INNINGS, THEY
CAME IN WITH EIGHT.
THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW YOU ARE
SETTING THE TABLE.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH YOU SENT TWO
LONG BALLS OUT OF THE PARK, BUT
YOU ARE MIXING UP A LITTLE BIT
OF EVERYTHING.
GAME SUMMARY PRESENTED BY STATE
FARM.
MARK CANHA, 3-5.
MATT CHAPMAN, THE YOUTUBE PLAYER
OF THE GAME.
FOR THE RANGERS, A ROOKIE
STEPPING UP, ELI WHITE, 3-5 AND
A HOME RUN.
WE CONTINUE THE POSTGAME WE COMS
GAME TWO 13-6 WIN.
ATHLETICS ON THE ROAD IN TEXAS.
>> THE HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> A SPLIT ON HOME PLATE.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> SHOULDN'T BE LAUGHING.
BAD IDEA.
>> THERE IS NOBODY AT FIRST.
THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE.
JAVIER BAEZ STOLE A RUN.
>> 2-2 PITCH, A LITTLE POP-UP.
>> NOT ONLY DID HE MAKE THE
PLAY, HE MADE THE PLAY WHILE
HOLDING HIS CELL PHONE AND
VIDEOTAPING HIMSELF.
YONDER: WELCOME --
MELANIE: WELCOME BACK TO THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
LET'S SEND IT BACK TO GLOBE LIFE
FIELD AND BRETT DOLAN.
BRENT: THIS WAS A REMINDER FOR
ME HOW MUCH FUN THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS CAN BE TO WATCH.
THEY WERE 13-2 AT ONE POINT THIS
MONTH.
THEY LOST A COUPLE TO NEW YORK,
INCLUDING THE GAME ENDING TRIPLE
PLAY, AND GOT ROUGHED UP IN THE
OPENER OF THIS SERIES BEFORE THE
BIG OUTPUT TONIGHT.
THEY GOT AWFULLY GOOD DEFENSIVE
PRODUCTION FROM CHAPMAN AND
ANDRUS.
CHAPMAN STARTED SLOW COMING BACK
FROM THE HIP INJURY.
ONDRUSEK HAD THE TOUGH START
HITTING .160.
HIS LAST MONTH HAS BEEN A BRIGHT
SPOT.
IF THOSE GUYS CONTINUE HITTING
LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN, THAT WILL
LENGTHEN THE OAKLAND LINEUP.
EVEN THOUGH THE ASTROS HAVE WON
EIGHT STRAIGHT GAMES, THEIR
SCHEDULE STARTS TO LIGHTEN UP --
SORRY ABOUT THAT, MELANIE --
OVER THE NEXT WEEK.
THIS OAKLAND TEAM ARE AWFULLY
FUN TO WATCH.
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE WEST RACE IS
GOING TO BE ENTERTAINING BETWEEN
OAKLAND AND HOUSTON.
MELANIE: AS YOU MENTIONED THE
STANDINGS, LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
THE HOUSTON ASTROS ARE PUSHING
THROUGH TO THE TOP SPOT.
OAKLAND ARE NOT GOING TO GO AWAY
QUIETLY.
BOTH TEAMS AT THE 45 WIN MARK.
SEATTLE IS TRYING TO FIGURE
THINGS OUT AT THE MIDDLE OF THE
PACK.
ANGELS WITHOUT ROSTER HAVE NOT
FOUND AN ANSWER YET.
THE RANGERS DOWN THERE, 26-47.
MANAGER CHRIS WOODWARD TRYING TO
DO HIS BEST, BUT HE DID GET TO
WELCOME BACK ELVIS ANDRUS,
SOMEONE WHO IS VERY WELCOME
DESPITE THE FACT HE IS IN THE
GOLD AND GREEN.
HE HAD QUITE THE DAY AFTER
FALLING 0-9.
HE KNOCKED A SINGLE IN THE FIRST
INNING, CAME BACK AROUND.
TO MAKE THINGS INTERESTING, HOW
ABOUT A DOUBLE?
ON DREW'S UP THE MIDDLE.
HE WASN'T DONE YET.
SOME GOOD READS, FINISHING 3-5
ON THE DAY.
ON DREW'S -- ANDRUS HAS STARTED
TO HEAT UP WITH OAKLAND, AND
THEY NEEDED.
HE IS LOOKING FOR HIS FIRST HOME
RUN STILL, BUT FALLING BEHIND IN
OTHER RANKINGS.
.567 OPS, BUT SOMEBODY WHO HAS
MADE 67 OUT OF 74 STARTS.
HE HAS BECOME CRUCIAL.
AS MUCH AS HE HAS HEATED UP, DO
THE ATHLETICS STILL SHOP FOR A
SHORTSTOP?
YONDER: STILL TO BE KNOWN.
FOR ELVIS ANDRUS, CONTINUE TO
GET BETTER.
HE HAS BEEN PLAYING BETTER AS OF
LATE.
IT'S NEVER TOO EARLY TO START
THINKING.
MAYBE A GUY LIKE TREVOR STORY, A
GUY THAT CAN MAKE BIG WAVES?
IT MIGHT BE.
HAVING TREVOR STORY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE LINEUP WITH THE
REST OF THOSE GUYS, WATCH OUT.
THE OAKLAND A'S INTO SOMETHING.
MELANIE: THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST SHORTSTOP FREE AGENT
GLASSES IN RECENT HISTORY.
WE MENTIONED JAVIER BAEZ.
TEAMS ARE GOING TO TRY TO
OVERLOOK THE BASERUNNING
MISTAKE.
CARLOS CORREA, COREY SEAGER,
MARCUS SEMIEN, TREVOR STORY,
ANDRELTON SIMMONS, A VETERAN FOR
PRETTY MUCH ANY TEAM.
ALL FREE AGENTS AFTER THE 2021
SEASON.
BUCK, DO THEY SHOP A SHORTSTOP?
BUCK: ALL THOSE GUYS, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ANDERTON THEM AND,
ARE A ONE YEAR RENTAL.
YOU ARE GOING TO GET BIG ENOUGH
CONTRACTS WHERE YOU WANT TO NOT
NECESSARILY BRING THEM IN
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO LEAVE.
SIMMONS IS THE ONLY GUY YOU
COULD PROBABLY SIGN.
THAT'S WHAT OAKLAND HAS TO
FIGURE OUT.
THE ONLY GUY WHO FITS FOR THEM
IS POSSIBLY SIMMONS.
IS HE GOING TO BRING ENOUGH
OFFENSE TO FIT THE LOSS OF
ANDRUS?
THE REST OF THOSE GUYS ARE ONE
YEAR RENTALS AND YOU HAVE TO
GIVE UP A LOT FOR THEM.
MELANIE: HOW MUCH DOES THIS PLAY
OUT AS YOU ARE WAITING THIS?
SOMEBODY WITH VETERAN PRESENCE,
GOOD CHEMISTRY, SOMEONE WHO CAN
KEEP THE CENTER OF GRAVITY LIGHT
OVERALL VERSUS THIS IS WIN MODE
AND IF IT IS NOT A GREAT
PERSONALITY, IT IS STILL A GUY
THAT BRINGS WINS.
YONDER: ELVIS ANDRUS IS A
WINNER.
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU ARE GETTING A
GUY THAT YOU DON'T KNOW WHO HE
HAS.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN VERY
PRODUCTIVE BUT ALSO HAS WON.
LOOK AT A GUY LIKE SIMMONS OR
TREVOR STORY WHO MAYBE HAVEN'T
WON.
THAT TAKES A LOT OF POWER INTO A
DECISION-MAKING.
HE HAS BEEN A BIG USED TO THE
OAKLAND A'S IN THAT CLUBHOUSE.
YOU TRADE HIM?
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT IT?
BUCK: YOU HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT DISRUPTING A
WINNING ATMOSPHERE AND WINNING
SITUATION, BUT YOU ALSO REALIZE
WE HAVE TO GET BETTER AT THIS
SITUATION BECAUSE YOU ARE TRYING
TO BE THE LAST TEAM STANDING.
THAT'S WHERE THE PERSONAL PART
OF IT, AS MUCH AS BOB MELVIN AND
BILLY BEANE LIKE THEIR PLAYERS,
THERE IS THE BUSINESS SIDE OF
IT.
WHEN YOU ARE GETTING THAT
PRODUCTION OUT OF A SHORTSTOP --
ELVIS HAD A GREAT NIGHT IN
TEXAS, GOOD FOR TEXAS FANS AND
BASEBALL IN GENERAL, BUT THEY
HAVE TO GET BETTER AT SHORTSTOP.
CAN THEY DO IT AND WHAT DOES IT
COST?
MELANIE: YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT
RAMON LAUREANO FOR MOST OF THE
GAME.
IF YOU HAVE THE SOLO VOTE, HE
MIGHT TAKE THE HARDWARE FROM
MATT CHAPMAN.
HE IS A SPONGE.
HE WANTS TO SOAK UP AS MUCH
INFORMATION, DOESN'T CARE HOW
LONG HE HAS BEEN IN THE GAME.
WHEN YOU SQUEEZE, HE GIVES YOU
EVERYTHING ALL AT ONCE.
IT'S ALL SIGNS OF WHAT HE BRINGS
INTO THE GAME.
YONDER: HE IS A TABLE SETTER.
ICA PITCH SELECTION TYPE OF GUY
WHO WORKS THE COUNT, CAN GO TO
RIGHT CENTER, BUT A GUY WHO IS A
FIRECRACKER.
YOU NEED GUYS LIKE THAT.
WINNING GUYS -- WINNING TEAMS
NEED THAT LEADERSHIP AND ALSO
THE FIRECRACKER AND THE GUY WHO
BRINGS THE ATTITUDE OF WANT TO
THE OAKLAND A'S.
HE HAS DONE THAT.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT IS GOING TO
DEPEND HEAVILY ON THE MIDDLE OF
THE FIELD.
LAUREANO IS GOING TO BE A BIG
PART OF IT.
MELANIE: THE ATHLETICS HAVE
CREPT INTO SOME OF THE TEAMS
WITH THE LONGEST DROUGHT LOOKING
FOR THE COVETED TITLE, 30
SEASONS.
THE LAST WAS IN 1990.
THAT MAKES YOU FEEL OLD.
THE A'S THREE STRAIGHT
APPEARANCES UNTIL 1990.
THIS GUY COULD PUSH THEM BACK
INTO THE FINAL PRECIPICE.
YONDER: THIS IS THE OAKLAND A'S.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY CAN BE.
BOB MELVIN WITH 800 PLUS WINS IS
GOING TO BE PULLING BAMA THE
RIGHT MOVES.
HE IS A HALL OF FAMER IN MY
EYES.
THE OAKLAND A'S ARE GOING TO BE
FUN FOR MANY YEARS TO COME.
MELANIE: WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW
THIS GAME UNFOLDED, YOU FACTOR
IN HOW YESTERDAY'S GAME WAS.
WHERE DO YOU GO FROM HERE AS YOU
LOOK AT THE LANDSCAPE OF GAMES
THREE AND FOUR?
BUCK: THE FOUR GAME SERIES ARE
TOUGH.
THE SAME PLACE AGAINST A TEAM
YOU PLAY SO MUCH WITHIN YOUR
DIVISION.
BOTH TEAMS ARE TRYING TO BE TRUE
TO WHO THEY ARE.
OAKLAND KNOWS HOW THEY HAVE TO
PLAY.
TEXAS IS STILL TRYING TO FIND
THAT TRACTION.
THEY HAVE A BIG DRAFT COMING UP,
GOOD ALL THE PITCHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE COMING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO ESTABLISH A
CREED OF THE WAY THEY WANT TO
PLAY THE GAME AND BE ABOUT WHO
THEY ARE.
I AM SEEING GOOD STRIDES.
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T LOOK THAT
WAY ON PAPER.
THEY ARE 21 GAMES UNDER .500,
BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS
BEING ESTABLISHED UNDER CHRIS
YOUNG.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO BE FUN
TO WATCH.
MELANIE: WE MIGHT HEAR OF YOU
BEING AT THAT PARK FROM TIME TO
TIME.
THIS HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE BLAST
TO SEE THESE TEAMS FACING OFF.
A COUPLE BLASTS OUT OF THE PARK
ON BOTH ENDS AS WELL.
ATHLETICS, 13-6 THIS EVENING.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE UPCOMING
SCHEDULE, MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
A WEEK FROM NOW, MARINERS AND
BLUE JAYS.
FRIDAY, JULY 9, THE REDS HEAD TO
MILWAUKEE AND TAKE ON THE
BREWERS.
ENHANCED STATCAST BROADCAST
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
AGAIN, FOR MELANIE NEWMAN,
YONDER ALONSO, BUCK SHOWALTER,
BRETT DOLAN, AND THE REST OF OUR
FANTASTIC CREW, HOPE YOU HAD
SOME FUN.
THE HAZE TAKE IT -- THE A'S TAKE
A 13-6 THIS EVENING.
THIS HAS BEEN MLB'S GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED
BY STATE FARM.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]